the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club time is the enemy and the clocks
are ticking at the St Louis rapid and
Blitz tensions were high the final day
of Rapid as players work to gain crucial
ground in the standings ahead of the
blitz section Ray robson's old friend
time pressure is still on his side as he
conquered the clock and the former world
champion Challenger to remain in clear
lead with a third win after a loss to
start the event Fabiano caruana has
roared back winning his second game to
jump into a tie for second Front Runners
are fing but with the field so close no
lead is safe day four of action-packed
Chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome to day four of the St Louis
rapid and Blitz we are here in front of
W's large chess piece and our tournament
has one of the largest priz fonts it
should be an exciting day let's go back
to the studio and get
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America the St Louis chess club
proudly presents St Louis rapid and
Blitz today it's fast and furious action
Blitz starts right
now and we're so excited to welcome you
all from our studio in St Louis I'm
International Master Tanya sa and
alongside me as always to call the
action grandm yasa saravan and grandmas
Peter swiler Tanya as always it's a
pleasure to be with you and with Peter
Bose are we ready for Blitz today we are
so ready yes what a tremendous event we
had the rapid and now it gets even
faster absolutely more intense hello
everybody and welcome to our show as we
are about to Showcase some of the best
Blitz players in the world the rapid was
fun but now it's an entirely different
skill set as it's hand eye coordination
tactical vision and
calculation fast fast fast action Tanya
do the honors and tell us about our
current standings after the Rapids has
been concluded you're ABS you right yes
Blitz is a different animal and the
players are in form and shape as they
got a little warm up in the rapid right
few would have predicted the Weir anded
Ray Robson at the top of the leaderboard
taking the rapid stunning performance
whole Chess World it's amazing finishing
with 11 points going into the Blitz and
close behind him we've got Fabiano
caruana world number two and the current
tore leader with 10 points along with
the 2021 World Blitz Champion we look at
the leader aard we look at that current
score and we know that it is a field
wide open it's going to be a close close
fight no question about it and now
having mentioned the grand chest tour uh
Fabio leading uh tell us about the grand
chest T standings this is where we are
in the season right now Fabiano Carana
with 20 GCT points at the top of the
leaderboard
$120,000 in earning the good news for
fabbi is he's played only two events
he's had a spectacular year so far he's
got two more events well this is one of
them he will be playing in this upcoming
singfield cup as well my eyes are on
that number four spot Ali Reza fuja who
played perhaps one of the most stunning
games of the season in the rapid he did
the player to beat Fabby in round one of
the rapid he is the player who's the
world number one Blitz and he can
overtake Fabby in the standings as well
I know and that uh game that Ali Raya W
uh played against Wesley oh that was
just outstanding tell us about the
format uh for this event it's a big
switch up yes from the action that we've
been seeing in the last three days with
the rapid now it's Blitz time and it
will be a double Round Rob in today nine
rounds of Blitz followed by another nine
rounds of Blitz uh the players will play
against each other twice with colors
reversed they start with only 5 minutes
in the clock uh the kind of good news
here is that every time they make a move
they get 2 seconds but yes an increment
of two seconds that's barely any time
it's true it's not at all and nine
points up for grabs today tell us about
the remaining schedule not much left we
just have two more days of action left
but there's a lot more chess coming up
with the sinkfield cup to follow but
right now it is about the blitz action
nine rounds as you said today another
nine rounds in the final day of the St
Louis rapid and Blitz thank you Tanya as
we turn to you Peter uh nice to see you
in
studio tell us about the players and how
they got to where they are absolutely
it's soon to become irrelevant
potentially but here are the winners of
the St Rose rapid section and the man at
the top there is the young American Ray
Robson who had a stellar tournament uh
and even the loss in the last round
didn't shake his uh uh position at the
top of the tree uh as you can see there
three wins the only person in the field
to win three games uh and clear first
after the end of the uh rapid section
and closely chasing him are Maxim V gra
who is a former World Blitz Champion so
he's very looking very much looking
forward to the next two days uh very
very solid tournament as you can see no
losses one win in round six and Fabiano
Carana who uh began the tournament by
losing his first round game to Ala fuja
but had a very very solid performance
from then on winning two games and
ending the rapid section tied for
second and the next graphic tells you
the absolutely Stellar company Ray Upson
is aiming to join if he uh continues
playing really well and wins the whole
thing these are the players who won the
rapid section of the rapid Blitz in the
history of grest store and went on to
win the entire event and as you can see
this is the the Fantastic gallery of the
best of the best in the
world and on that note look at how
strong our field is uh we have nobody
outside of the world top 50 uh Ray
Robson I think after the rapid everybody
should understand that his ratings are
not really indicative of his actual
strength and we also have the world
number one uh playing ala fuia is almost
2900 in Blitz fantastic fantastic rating
for him so very very strong field a lot
of exciting games
ahead
and I am very
sorry about my momentarily pause there
we are throwing over to R grandmas
Anastasia Carlovich who's been keeping a
very close eye on the action closer to
the
games thank you Peter thank you that you
remembered about me hello yaser hello
Tanya hello guys it's really nice to see
you today I look looking forward for the
blitz event and I'm your expert of
social media and bringing you some news
and actually it was really nice to see
visha Anand himself praising Ray Robson
for his great performance during the
rapid section of the St Louis rapid and
Blitz we can see the tweet on the
screens um
vishant really told him that it was a
really good performance so great he
called it a great achievement by Robson
to win in rabbit section I believe that
really he showed fantastic result and
and um it was actually the first time
for a Robson to participate in grunch
tour but I have another very special and
sweet tweet which was addressed to yaser
Sahan himself is there anything sweeter
than the smooth sounds of yaser sans
continues exactly keeping me company
while I cook dinner at a very dark 5:47
p.m. I really don't think there is I
ready to check it myself also once I
will cook the dinner it doesn't happen
that often but I promise y I will open
YouTube channel and I will listen to
your voice to make
sure so okay so please it it was so nice
to get such a great tweet so nice
feedback and I'm asking all all our
viewers all our followers not to forget
about our social media accounts
grandchester St Louis chess club please
stay with us also in social media and
now throwing it back to you Yas and
Anastasia I accept on behalf of all the
commentators we're going to come come
over to your place for dinner you just
tell us where and when I'm coming to
that dinner party I'm rsvpd already and
this is our party right now which is
about to start uh the tournament leader
Ray Robson with the black pieces takes
on the two times World Championship
Challenger yan neishi yan had an up and
down event at the rapid but he seemed to
have found his rhythm in the last couple
of games I I I feel that's the Cas this
will be the game that we focus on
because the blitz is so fast but tell us
about all the games the pairings please
do the honors for this round one of
Blitz it's a long and an exciting day of
Chess ahead with of us and this is what
we start with Sam savan takes on a
Jeffrey jong a tour leader Fabiano
Carana against his big rival Wesley so
Wesley so he really needs to find his
form in the blitz had a dismal
performance in the rapid it's Liam
taking on
the Frenchman with three names Maxim
Vash Yan naishi plays AR Robson and the
final bearing also catches my attention
as Ali Resa fuja takes on Anish giri and
that one promises to be equally spicy
absolutely well again we'll have our
Marquee match up with NE Po and Ray but
fuja G and Fabby Wesley will be great
reserves backups and what are they
fighting for Tanya quite a lot yasa as
we go into uh the penultimate day of the
St Louis rapid and Blitz the overall
winner will go back with $40,000 and not
just that grand Chester points to be won
as well for that big bonus purse of the
overall winner $100,000 at stake for the
top prize and we start exactly they're
underway in a Joko piano and A2 A4 uh
very very early and as we know in the
Joko piano it's so flexible Castle C2 C3
H2 H3 just a plethora of moves A2 A4 is
a little bit to my taste early but there
are reasons why white wants to make uh
the bishop squares available on A2 Tanya
there are so many switch UPS in the move
order in the Italian which moment you
play A4 when do you Castle when do you
develop that queenside Knight and it's
always a very complex opening to face
with the black pieces because white has
variety of choices of move water and we
see there that Ray Robson has decided to
stop any further advance of white on the
queen Side by pushing the a pawn himself
over to A5 a bishop trade has been
offered uh it's going to be quite an
interesting battle we know that's what
happens with Italian a slow start till a
player gets a central break yasa I want
to ask you what are the chances of Ray
Robson being able to continue his in
immense form that we saw in r rapid he
was one of the underdogs and he took it
all away so convincingly absolutely no I
mean it is a stunning performance I
cannot say that often enough he is the
Wild Card uh is going up against our
regular tour Champions if you will and
to perform at this level and to do it
consistently over 5 days that's the
challenge now today I mean I think it's
all about just simply starting well um
when you play Blitz I can't say it often
enough but you it's a very very streaky
thing that happens to uh Blitz players
you get on a streak whether it be a
losing streak or a winning streak and uh
it carries you through the day so a good
start by Ray is really what's going to
be required and in the blitz that Tempo
that momentum is so important because
it's the one format where it's easy to
go on a tilt as well if you have a
couple of rough games is really
difficult to come out of that rabbit
hole absolutely it is going to be all
about who gets those wins in 18 points
at St overall and we've already seen a
trade happen in this position white has
managed to double up his bonds but in
compensation gets more control over
Central squares and opens up the F line
that's very important the idea of D
Dynamic use of the F line is the
compensating factor for the two pounds
by the way I noticed that this uh move
by nepo very quickly uh Knight H4 before
Ray was able to get his Knight to G6 the
idea being that Knight G6 could
potentially be met by the move Knight F5
so Ray just by the way who has who's
been playing a it feels like Ray's
played a little slower are you surprised
no not really but in Blitz you know it
it's one thing to be playing on
increment when you have 10-second
increments when you got two seconds you
don't build up much of a an a fat if you
will uh Queen G3 C C7 C6 Queen G3 sorry
Yesa we're on move number 11 okay uh Yan
has just made the move Queen G3 and
already on the clock Ray is down by two
minutes that's huge that that's
unacceptable a lot yeah I'm sorry I mean
that I was about to say that Queen G3
his intention was Knight takes G6 and
queen takes G6 but there is
fortunately uh D5 so if you if you
capture twice with the Knight and the
queen there's D6 D5 keeping in mind that
that would uh win material sorry very
nice point and I think we can show that
line really quickly as Yan is still in a
bit of a think that you don't want to
get greedy with the pawn here as you
pointed out the bishop does pin F7 but
there is a blow with D5 which hits the
bishop hits the queen and it's black who
ends up winning material he does take
once on the board he's captured on G6
he's not going to take it twice I'm a
little bit surprised by that I was
expecting for some reason I had a fixed
idea that the Knight was going to F5 on
the contrary Knight takes G6 I suppose
now is the time to bring the
reinforcements into the battle Knight to
D2 it's already starting to get pretty
tricky I can Envision ideas like Knight
D2 maneuvering it all the way to G5 and
that is the good good point about
doubling up those G pawns there's no 86
that black has to kick that Knight out
of G5 so imagine the Knight lands on G5
you put your queen on the hline on H4
and you're already threatening
checkmating ideas with a sacrifice on F6
this could start getting very tricky for
Reay really soon and he's under 2
minutes on the clock yeah he's feeling
the pressure right now and for nepo I've
always uh a great admirer of his Blitz
and his rapid skills he he calculates as
fast
as just anybody in the world for me Gary
Kasparov Vish and nand were just somehow
by themselves as far as rapid instant
calculators but neppo feels to me like
he could be he belongs there what king
h8 we were talking about the queen on
the hline and this just invites it over
with a check nepo didn't have didn't
mean to be asked twice he immediately
played Queen H4 check and yes the Knight
is heading to G5 we saw a check we saw a
shake of head by Ray Robson a retreat of
the king to G8 and Knight has landed on
D2 two moves away from setting up a
mating net yes this move King h8 was not
to be recommended Queen H4 King G8 and
just as you were pointing out you
maneuver the Knight to G5 and Rook takes
F6 is on your
agenda big time and Ray knows that he's
he's in trouble he's simply in trouble
at the moment because now after Bishop
takes Pawn takes these double pawns
really are genuinely really weak they're
they're so vulnerable to direct hits
hits such as Rook F3 and Rook G3 but and
well nepo hits the pawn Rider way with
Queen G3 I'm that I like it because
after the last trade the G6 point that
that you were highlighting becomes a
clear Target now the knight from D2 is
not only heading to G5 but also to H4 a
square which has just been vacated by
the White Queen to put more pressure on
the G6 PA what makes Yan she so
dangerous in these fter time controls is
that instinctively he is a very
aggressive Dynamic player he's able to
take those critical decisions which
create a mess on the board ask these
questions on the board very quickly
putting a lot of pressure on the clock
for his opponent and he is playing it
very fast he he's he's in the zone now
Queen E8 came to Def defend the pawn on
uh G6 but Knight C4 said excuse me but
I'm going to tickle both the pawn on D6
and the pawn on A5 Ray said uh the
Lesser evil is you're welcome to my A5
pawn and well you don't ask ask me twice
I'll take that pawn that's a goodie Ray
Robson down to under 15 seconds with
just a 2C increment and a position that
to me looks lost it looks busted it
simply is it simply is a very very good
pawn and knows it he Ray's been around
the block he knows that he really blew
it that move King h8 was just so ill
timed and he's not going to get the
chance to recover if we see a trade of
Rooks and A5 A6 I got to think that this
is this is Neo's game to Claim by the
way all I I like these guys who get in
that lift just when you know just it
it's nice now our King doesn't have to
worry about back rank mates we've always
got A6 as a way of breaking up the
Queens side Tanya yes it's 3 minutes
worth of 3 seconds on the clock yeah
it's over and you just it it's so hard
to recover from this type of deficit
that you're down on the clock and you're
down upon as well it's not just the
clock you're down material in the
position and where do you create your
tricks where do you create your chances
here as black you're only trying to
defend and hold and with just a 2C
increment there's no hope of bundling up
of catching up on time of getting that
increment to give you more seconds to
play he's going to be playing on two
seconds for the rest of the game and Ray
Robson I think it's just a matter of
time before neppo wraps this up yeah
it's collapsing and it's almost like one
of the worst players to be behind on the
clock because nepo is a is a naturally
gifted player he plays so quickly uh on
Instinct and he's not going to let you
uh get any time to think the only hope
hope that I see for R Robson here is
that we know we've seen time and time
again that Yan's biggest strength of
playing quickly can sometimes just make
him miss these critical moments if
somehow that happens at this in this
position it's hard to imagine with the
peace placement that we have White's
Rooks and that beautiful Knight which
has just landed onto E5 it certainly did
Ray Robson just hoping for that one
moment of rashness by Yan I don't uh
think that this was bad uh play at all
by Yan I like I like what he's done but
I was also thinking Queen D6 might have
been you know lights out type of a move
before he played Knight E5 there was a
move Queen D6 this he's down to 1 second
I mean and two second increment is not
going to get you any padding in terms of
being able to play the one thing the
queen endings
are can be extremely extremely
tricky and we're getting a big update
that we've got our first result of the
blitz Ali Resa fua world number one
Blitz player yes he takes done Anish G
and I had my eye out on that game it was
a stunner as well was it uh White just
played a very powerful move Queen to F5
posting up on this absolutely dominant
Square uh ideas of Queen C8 checks
suddenly start lurking in the air just
tickling this Pawn remind ing black that
uh after moves like Knight G6 Queen C8
will really be very power Queen D7 looks
very good as well Queen D7 just trading
queens and there we are indeed no Queen
no Queen trade because the Knight would
reposition itself Queen um to
uh Queen to F6 you could also you know
dreaming of a Perpetual check I would
que a check transposes to a b ending but
Yan decides not to bother yeah I'm
pretty sure he's winning anyway doesn't
really doesn't really need
that and uh just uh that was that was my
mouth slip Queen takes Knight G6 I like
this move because it controls the F4
Square as we can see on our live board
right now R Robson has one check the
king moves forward and I'm expecting him
to resign as the f8 Knight is about to
fall but don't pick it up with the
Knight because that could end up in a
Perpetual check and there you have it
very impressive performance let's go to
the game of Fabiano versus weso our
grand chest tour uh leader uh is up upon
against Wesley and it looks like a draw
whoa whoa whoa we're waiting to see
where the kings are I think it's on the
center of the board and looking at the
live board that we have as well but
we're getting an update W yeah he won
he's a pawn up he won but did he flag
Wesley we still have action we will get
a confirmation on that but this is our
Wesley did flag indeed against Fabiano
Karana and here we've got Maxim Basher
lra he's got an extra Pawn a dominating
Knight in the center of the
board and a Fabby head blocking
everything and wait a minute what is
this we take and we go
H3 is that is that the intent or just
simply Knight takes g i three I think he
just played Knight takes G3 yes and uh
white king is reflected towards the king
side to stop the H Pawn and Black's
going to head over to the queen side
grab all the pawns nice technique there
by Maxim vagra absolutely uh King coming
into C4 Knight taking the B4 pawn and
the B Pawn will March forward he's going
to pick up the a pawn eventually as well
and this is a win uh for mvl there it
seems not so long ago but there was a
time that Liam had clear first and
dominated through five rounds but it was
that round six loss and Rapids that cost
him and uh this is the final game of the
round as we have four results already in
the books four results three decisive
results and this is going to be the
fourth one Maxim vagra needs to show a
little bit of technique here but those
two pawns I don't think it's going to be
too hard the a pawn advancing forward
exactly and you could come in with a
check on A2 as well I think what you
really want to do before you play the
move A2 is put your knight on E E1 so
you get the smothered mate right away uh
convincing victories uh Peter I want to
say in this round only one draw only one
draw and uh a very very interesting
round that game could also not have been
drawn but uh I'll I'll wait uh for for
it nicely to tell you more about that
one uh let's talk briefly about the end
game we just finished uh uh watching on
our screens the game that mvl won with
the black pieces against L Liam I think
what happened there is what often
happens when white plays these uh types
of uh uh quin's G accepted where I think
you don't know if you're playing for a
win or for a draw because you're playing
an ultra solid line with white you're
playing sort of with your with a draw in
your pocket right and then at some point
maybe you think maybe I'm slightly
better maybe I'm supposed to push right
and instead of just at some point
accepting your Fai trading everything
along the open files and offering a draw
you you make a few extra moves with this
intention of perhaps playing for a win
and then suddenly you have to defend
this yeah this is still completely fine
of course this is even this is still
completely fine and then somewhere
around here I think Le made a few
inaccurate moves and by this point uh
you start seeing the outlines of the end
game that we saw him lose because he's
left with this dark Square Bishop on E1
his pawns on the queen side are on the
same color so they they will be fixed at
some point and they will become
weaknesses and it's a long game but as
you can see uh simplifications aren't
actually helping you very much this is a
type of an end game where this night in
particular because there is this
wonderful Target on C4 for this Knight
to aim for this is an end game you have
to defend and you have to defend it very
carefully and he ended up in the end
losing it as you can see currently the
machine says is completely equal but I
think in human terms it's much more
pleasant to play with black and this is
exactly what happened already this is
very very bad it's somehow the Rooks
have come off the Knight is three two
moves away from landing on C4 this is
very unpleasant already and no surprise
that mvl ends up winning this game and
another Victory is a game uh ala fuja
won against Anish giri this was an
English in which uh alza says no I would
like to play Sicilian just goes D3 D5
cd5 Knight D5 E4 so pretty much playing
uh I would say this is probably a NE
even though the pawn is still on A2 but
it's in Bowski it's in spirit it's one
of those two
uh we're playing ailan with colors
reversed with white obviously having an
extra move and very normal development
happens I think all of this is pretty
logical and I think the very critical
point happened around here ala made this
very very tricky move Rook C2 okay and I
think Anish didn't really fully
appreciate what this idea was because
yes of course we're un pening The Rook
because the bishop on G5 was x-raying
this Rook on C1 but we're also defending
the bishop on E2 which maybe was the
detail that Anish Ander appreciated
because he made a kind of a logical
looking move A7 A6 denying the B5 Square
for the Knight and so on perhaps
intending to play Knight D4 next move
and he was hit by this move Knight
D5 and I'm guessing here he realized
that if he just does this the bishop is
not hanging so we are actually winning
the B7 Pawn for free so he ended up it's
not panic stations yet but I think the
change in scenery was such that he
reacted uh in in a way that wasn't
really all that great and if you look at
at this position this is
already fairly off the rails yeah we
have this Knight on A5 which will be
very very difficult to bring back in the
game and after a few more moves white
was able to develop a massive attack
Bishop G4 is constantly a threat so at
first Anish had to play G6 to have a
five as a reply to Bishop G4 now he had
to play H5 and then his King side just
got blown apart wow uh and uh nicely
done as you can see this is still maybe
manageable and 10 moves later andish
more or less resigned so a very nice
efficient Victory there by alira who
once he assumed initiative never let go
and punished every single mistake very
very harshly wow and well Tanya uh thank
you Peter that very very nice Tanya
could you just tell us the standings
after the first Blitz round of Blitz
very inspired chess as we saw All Around
by the players and uh there we have our
standings going into round two Fabiano
Karan with his win still at the now has
overtaken the leaderboard Ray Robson
lost he is now tied three three players
Maxim Ray and Fabby all with 11 points
and thanks to their victories Ali reaza
Yan narrowed the Gap and now only Trail
by one Yana pishi made that one look
easy against the tournament leader it
start to finish with the white pieces
and all the four victories that we saw
very convincing play well let's let's
look at the those victories Tanya let's
throw it over to Anastasia in studio
Anastasio tell us about the two games
that you had your eye
on I had my eye on the game between two
American players who represent the new
generation and you know always those
bottles are very tough and um it started
all with uh side variation in Sicilian
and actually I think Jeffrey who had
black pieces got really nice comfortable
position he sold all his um opening
troubles after playing B5 and then D5
and I know in Sicilian if you manage to
play D5 then things should be going in
the right direction so after a few moves
I mean I same probably feeling that
situation is uh going out of control
play this E5 Knight E5 and after Knight
E6 I don't know why Jeffrey didn't go
Knight F3 just winning a pawn maybe he
didn't like something over there that
the six Pawn is weak or something else
but he didn't go for this variation he
just St on E6 and after that after
Bishop B5 position was about equal uh
but things went crazy once again after
this moment when um suddenly um Jeffrey
played this move E5 and probably he
missed this Knight F5 very strong move
from Sam and after Rook F5 Queen D5
actually everything is just uh Fallen
apart and he's losing a Pawn on D5 as
well as later white took this Knight on
D7 and position looked really really
good for white but Jeffrey decided to
try his last attempt and you know
created some kind of an attack let's say
on the king's side pces came to the
second rank but actually here Sam had
had to make only one clear move to
finish all the hopes of black here Rook
A1 to make sure that this Rook will go
out forever from the second rank because
now if you take on uh A2 things will go
crazy after Rook C8 right so you
shouldn't do so black has to change the
Rooks and after that I inan position um
will be absolutely winning for for white
after that I mean you can see even
visually that it's two two pounds up so
it didn't happen after Rook F1 um black
played Queen it to exchange with the
queens and after that I think really Sam
didn't feel uh the danger of this Rook
on the second rank which took all the
pawns later on Bishop D4 and then Rook
D7 and black got enough initiative uh to
finish the game in a draw the second
game I was checking you actually saw the
ending between Fabiano Carana and Wesley
so this game started with a sharp line
in the Queens Gambit I think both
players were in a bit aggressive mood
and uh Wesley played this move G5 opting
for this bishop on D3 yes he took the
bishop but later on I think Fabby got
quite comfortable position uh he made
this famous maneuver Bishop H7 King h8
and then came back to F5 um it's clear
that all the the white squares on the
king side are really weak and um you
know um at one point um I think Wesley
didn't feel really good about his
position so he tried to CH change a
little bit the situation on the board he
played this move C5 and look I mean what
happened after so fabbi understood that
now he has also another nice weakness on
the black's camp this D5 pawn and he
changed completely the track of um his
plan and he literally brought all his
pieces on the defile I really like how
it looks like you know Queen is on D2
Rook on D4 Rook on D1 and he simply
wanted to get this Pawn later and
actually he managed to do so uh at the
end of the day so actually here he black
had to play G4 because Bishop F3 was
also a threat so um another weakness on
G4 and Fabby played this game really
well the way he converted it you could
see it later um on the screens so um I
think the first round first um Day first
round I mean of Blitz was really really
tough and interesting thank you
Anastasia I must say the quality of the
games seemed very good for Blitz play
really good games by the way one of the
things I Tanya I mean we watch three
days of rapid and I'm holding my heart
watching Ray Robson play you were
holding your heart during the rapid as
well but that was with 10c increment now
it would go down to 1 second almost
would play but he would play incredible
chess with that one second but with just
two seconds to increment every time I'm
going to sayas I'm worried about ra
clock management as we saw in the rapid
as well the many struggles and the many
uh manyi heart attacks that we had in
our studio a montage of uh some of the
rapid action coming your way let's take
a look at Ray Robson in action this is
against Wesley Wesley there you go two
seconds final round of the rapid the big
win that Wesley scored and once again
just with 2 seconds and having to adjust
his pieces in his opponent's time
exactly uh we're not done yet we're just
still getting started right this whole
one game right this is just one game
yeah yeah 3 two
one yeah I don't know how I like how Cal
Wesley is through all of that Wesley is
just completely un undisturbed so chill
yeah I mean he's got a position where he
can chill as well that definitely helps
but
Robson and his uh time pressure tell me
a better love
story I don't think I
can tell us about the pairings let's
take a look round two round two of the
blitz coming up yes sir and there we
have it it is Jeffrey Jang taking on
Anish giri who had a rough start losing
to Ali Raa fuja we've got Ry Robson oh
and the battle continues he's going to
be playing against alian and this is
such an important match let make it our
Marquee match up Ray currently tied for
first playing against peria is just a
one point behind but as a backup game
look at that uh Frenchman with three
names versus ano that will also be our
backup game for this blitz that's what
juicy match up given their style of play
how ambitious they get and just how
strong they are when it comes to Blitz
and Yas so what you said earlier it is
always such a pleasure to watch these
top players the best in the world with
little time on the clock when it's a
blitz format the quality of Chess Still
Remains incredibly High you don't see
blunders you don't see mistakes uh it's
just so much to take away from and I
think that's what makes them the very
best Peter yeah these guys are very very
strongly players obviously and round one
already shows that uh there's plenty of
time for expression there with there we
saw some positional games we saw this
explosive demolition job by Ala against
gir punishing what I think basically is
one mistake in very very uh good style
so um it's fantastic just how much they
they see and how much they're able to
show in the in this time control I
thought that nepo punished the one
mistake King h8 by uh Ray Robson very uh
conclusively as well Peter that is also
yeah very very nice efficient Victory
there by by Yan and looking at the at
the cross table we have the the people
who I would have thought will be
fighting for first all converging we
might actually have a rarity I think on
the tour these days a very very close
Blitz tournament because in the previous
couple events Magnus did unspeakable
things to the field and this one looks
like we might have alira and Yan playing
himself into form and Fabi of course
being a very very strong Blitz player
these days right and we we could have
two days of people joking for position
which would be a fantastic experience
for so it's not only going to be a fight
on the screen with the players but we wi
the commentators as well considering the
picks that we had at the start it looks
like we're headed that way I'm feeling
much better about life yeah I am too
funny you should mention
that let's have a look at our picks just
remind ourselves as to why we're so
pleased with our uh predictions and I
think Peter you've got probably maximum
reason to be pleased because Yan had a
shaky start and now he finds himself at
the top of the leaderboard you picked
nepo yeah I I took Yan and Yan is
definitely trending upwards Al in his
interview with Anastasia yesterday said
I only have to he didn't say only but I
think in his mind he meant I only have
to make make up two points and it's now
only one point and there is there is
your pick and n as well Anastasia and I
picked Fabby and we have this is what
you were saying fua Ali Raza said I'm
only trailing by two points I feel good
Absolut had the same situation I think I
think Yan is also going to going to be
feeling that it's now absolutely his if
not for the taking them for to to fight
for first and VAR has reason to be upset
because if he if his pick Sam hadn't
lost on time against Anish he'd be up
there right in and I think Sam is a very
good Blitz player as well so I think
he'll be he'll be very much in the mix
here did we discuss what the winner gets
well we know what the winner of the
grand Chester gets but what do the the
commentary yes I like how you're
pointing at yourselves I think the
ladies in case I win I'm accepting uh a
a homecooked dinner what about you all
right if we win yasa takes us out for
lunch lunch lunch lunch lunch okay or
dinner or both but right now food is not
on the mind of these players as they're
getting ready for round two Blitz is
about to start and there we see Sam
savian with the white pieces against the
tour leader Fabiano Carana who started
with a win in the first round and this
is yasa our big game absolutely now for
Ray Ray I was saying at the very start
of our show uh
streaks uh when you playing Blitz chess
you get into these streaks and uh they
carry fors don't ask me why but Ray has
to stop right now what just happened in
round one he cannot have a repeat of
that previous round because that will be
uh curtains uh people will just start
targeting him in the blitz as we're
underway in a Catalan with Bishop B4
Che Bishop B4 and he comes back and for
many watching it might be surprising
that you are inviting white to develop
the bishop to only return and yasa that
has a quite a deep idea in the Catan
because White's Bishop really belongs on
the A1 uh h8 diagonal you're kind of
misplacing your opponent's Bishop on D2
and we very of see that white has to
spend a move moving that Bishop away
from D2 vacating not only the square for
his own Knight to land there in certain
positions but also putting the bishop on
a better Square exactly it's a it is
confounding that the idea of Bishop B4
check followed by the bishop Retreat is
black is actually making the argument
your Bishop is actually better placed on
C1 than on D2 so I'm misplacing the
bishop because now as you just said
Tanya The Bishop's in the way of the
Knight and maybe the more desirable
diagonal would be to control the E5
Square from the square B2 I think you're
right I think it's time to play moves
like Bishop F4 and or you know you you
you can try to say to your opponent I'm
going to make a virtue of the fact that
youve put my Bishop on D2 I'm going to
advance on the queen side with the moves
B4 and A4 none of that happened we did
see in fact the move Bishop F4 and it is
where the bishop belongs once it's
landed on D2 you control the E5 Square
as well white lines up The Rook on D1
centralizing it against the queen and we
see that verua is rushing ahead on the
queen side I'm not very familiar with
the ideas of A5 A4 it it's one of those
questions you ask yourself what am I
doing with my queen just my Queen's on
d8 it's kind of it's oppressive you know
I don't have much going on as black but
if I could put my Pawn to A5 and I can
follow it up with Queen A5 well you know
I could uh
I'm more active and I could tease a
little bit The Pawn on C4 guess what we
just had saw the move Dak C4 and Reay is
saying I'm willing to trade my C4 Pawn
for your A4 Pawn that seems like a good
deal for black it does right because
it's a Central Pawn that you are giving
up for a flank Pawn on the a line not
only that but you open up the a file for
Black's Rook for further counterplay
exactly and right now watch out you
can't really take recapture on C4
winning that pawn back because black has
got ideas of B5 forking the queen and
the Knight winning material so the C4
Pawn is indirectly defended exactly I
think aliar should be pleased with the
opening outcome I would be elad actually
and we did see the move Knight C3 a kind
of indication that I'm inviting you to
capture the bishop not that I'm really
eager to double up your pawns I like the
Knight on D5 I personally would find
myself attracted to moves like Queen A5
B7 B5 and just you know staking out some
space on the queen side by the way in
case of E2 E4 I start to get more
interested in that case with Knight
takes F4 but don't forget that I can
also pop into the D3 score so uh B5 A4
on the board and that's a very
interesting uh what you pointed out a
very good thematic idea of the Catalan
that black provokes white to push E4
with the tempo hitting Knight on D5 but
on the other hand every pawn move has
its own set of consequences and in this
case the D3 Square becomes really weak
so even though it's tempting white
should hold on before pushing the
Central Pawn instead trying to Target
the queen side here A4 and now there's a
bit of a decision to be made the hand
move B4 pushing that B Pawn to attack
White's Knight creates weaknesses for
black because White's Knight can jump to
the center of the board on e4 and then
suddenly black has to end up defending
those Pawns on C4 most especially I
would find myself attracted to the move
that Ali Raza just made which is Queen
A5 uh when we played the move A5 A4 we
were making room for the queen in this
particular case uh aliisa is saying I'm
willing to sacrifice my queen go ahead
and capture my Pawn on B5 I'll take the
Rook on A1 and I'll cause you a little
bit of a conflict on the first rank
Bishop D2 came very very quickly now I'm
more attracted to playing the moves B5
B4 followed by B A6 yeah by the way
Peter on this in this exact position I'm
thinking nice Advantage black that's my
first first impression as well I'm
wondering what ala dislikes about before
because I think uh very often it would
already have been on the board to be
honest it feels just so much more
natural than pretty much anything else
he can play but he clearly either sees
something else else attractive or is
worried about something in those
positions something um B5 B4 Knight E4
Bishop A6 who's doing well on the clocks
Tanya and that's what I was just about
to point out we're seeing Ray Robson
realize that he cannot afford to have a
big time time deficit not the two
minutes that he did in round one no in
round one because it's only a two second
increment and all the critical decisions
having to make them with just seconds on
the clock you are going to collapse you
can make one good decision two good
decisions but not 20 in a row right ex
so we see a More Level clock situation
here and in fact for the first time it's
R Robson ahead with about 30 second and
eventually fuja decides to push the pawn
to B4 we see the Knight being
centralized and we're expecting black to
continue with development uh holding on
the pawn to C4 and I I I do agree with
you Black's position as we had pointed
out after losing that C4 Pawn for white
black just looks like you've got more
under control The Rook from f8 is going
to join the party at some
point and I there there there are tricks
of C3 and Bishop takes E2 on Black's
agenda watch out for so much I like what
you just uh pointed out the Rook can go
nicely to B8 it feels like I've got some
pal benko type of uh uh Dynamic play for
black without being a pawn down sorry
Tanya you about to say uh something
about the position just doesn't feel
right for white
100% And I think in Blitz what is most
important is to the initiative is the
initiative and the ability to make moves
quickly to have moves that improve your
position that you don't have to think
much about and I think Robson realizes
that so he needs to create something he
needs to change the dynamic of the
position jumps in with the Knight and
now the only threat that black needs to
watch out for is on the king side IA as
a bishop G5 I want to trade off your
dark Squad Bishop try and get my knight
to either G5 or D D6 a square that I'm
looking at uh guess what I agree with
your answer not happening anymore let me
chill your
enthusias enthusiasm for playing Bishop
G5 I got to play H7 H6 but not only as
you say it takes over the G5 Square it
makes lift and now you're back to what
do I do next T what does Ray do next
because it's challenging by the way we
have our first result in a second round
of Blitz we do and Anish Jeffrey jeang
has ended in a draw so for Anish it
probably also means just you know you
start with a loss the next game you want
it to be just kind of make sure things
don't go out of control exactly but he
needs to start winning games if he wants
to get up on the leaderboard and right
now the big question is Ray Robson how
does he keep things under control again
jumping in with the Knight to D6 and
fuja immediately responds with the idea
of C3 is he going to pick up the E2 Pawn
well I'm actually thinking I don't need
m wait a minute Bishop takes e no he's
just said look I'm I'm very happy
trading Knight takes C3 you want to give
me your two Bishops go ahead Bishop
takes C3 B takes
C3 and that is E5 is also hanging which
is quite relevant there I think he by
taking with the Knight he opened up the
queen on A5 to attack
the6 hands as which has just occurred he
is Ray is just captured on C6 now Rook
to B8 eight and are we ever playing
Queen takes C5 and sacrificing this
exchange the answer is probably no but I
would like to stop Bishop B5 from
happening all right I'm lost which
exchange are we talking about you mean
just to give it right just leaving The
Rook on pra there on a take on E5 Queen
takes E5 Bishop takes Rook takes I guess
yeah or or Bishop D6 yeah maybe
something like this you've got this pass
Pawn oh he goes for it it's on the board
Queen takes E5 what a big decision in
this format to just sacrifice Bishops
and a very powerful Bishop the light
Squad Bishop once it lines up on has
move que4 right now which gets the
Queens off the board but you do leave
the pawn on E2 hanging and you allowing
C3 C2 it's not an easy decision but
generally speaking getting the queens of
the board here would be very
very Queen E4 if I was in Ray shoes I
would be playing Queen B4 with alacrity
and he has not he's played the move
Knight B5 which also a good plan of
Simply stopping E2 now I'm just thinking
this is a little too romantic I don't
understand the exchange sacrifice at all
we go Rook C8 we put the bishop on B7
and we start saying your king actually
isn't that safe with the pawn on G3 Rook
C8 Bishop B7 he stops it he jumps in
with his own drook because if black is
able to create a battery on the long
diagonal that's bad news for the white
kinged but it's not happening for now
Rook D7 and first black needs to find
the square for the bishop moves it to F6
which by the way reinforces F6 very
important White's Queen is just stuck on
C2 white really cannot move it to allow
Black's Spawn from advancing he is not
something you want to allow at all Rook
B1 by the way just kind of gets off the
diagonal in case the pawn ever does move
you don't want your Rook hang hanging
Rook B1 clock times again Tanya as uh
we're we're we're getting to the crucial
moments absolutely for re Robson he's
under 30 seconds but not not that much
more time for Ali razar both players now
reaching the 302nd mark and more
importantly a very complex middle game a
very complex position a game for all
three results with draw again is the
least likely and I'm with you on this
yes it just felt like did Ali RAR really
need to give up material at that moment
by the way 20 seconds and counting for
Ali Raza as he understands he's an
exchange down he yes he's got the he's
got a good passer but he's not what next
yeah the the he doesn't have a pawn
either as com 7 seconds and wow he off
the queen really really used in
inordinate amount of clock time to play
the move Queen F5 so I think he just
couldn't find another move in the
position how do you improve from here
but a queen trade means there are no
potential attacks against the white king
it's immediately snapped up the only
thing black needs to White needs to
watch out for is C2 and then the bishop
coming to B2 which means you play Rook
C1 to stop exactly what you're just said
Rook C6 I'm blockading this PA Pawn I
like that he trades off the defender
because the knight from C7 will it's a
blunder what did he play it's a blunder
alert oh Bishop B5 yes oh and he just
and I thought that was a great idea
would have been except for oh he missed
it and no with no time on his clock Ali
Raza is
now oh my God but wait a minute wait a
minute he does have he does have tricks
with with the a pawn careful C and
then hang on Bishop c yeah King it's
still tricky Bishop Bishop C3 you take
the pawn you take on A5 but Black's got
to be better here no no not better
winning uh two Bishops versus the rook
and four pawns but but it's about the
clock now 5 Seconds both players are
playing with their increment oh but what
an oh there goes the F2 on and he
resigns two horrible blunders oh Peter
let's jump to the game between Wesley
and uh
Liam wow what I mean first place appears
to be winning here because the black
pieces is on the back rank up pin and
the hbor is just marching towards the
the queening square so that looks still
kind of flustered by I can't believe
what we just saw Rook C7 the most
natural move and that's the losing move
in the position and coming to this game
Wesley is he on the brink of Victory I
see an extra piece for white yes it's it
it's it's that clear now it is this has
to be winning yeah is an extra piece for
White Knight
Knight Will Will just come uh to there a
nice threatened as well watch out a fork
alert that's right but Rook to D7 and C7
is uh threatening Rook rook d8 and
that's the game and that's the game and
it's handshakes says well wle that was
it that was our last game I'm still
recovering from that Clash for first by
between Ray Robson and fua
that and Y Peter's pick for the
tournament finding his rhythm and that's
three in a row counting his last round
victory in the rapid wow it's between
you and I Peter it feels like happened
to fabbi by the way Fabby and this is
what I have on the screen Fabby Fabby
lost to samian Saar is also feeling
feeling quite cheerful and with the time
we we have we can't really go it's it's
a long game and a very complicated
strategic game Sam had a slightly
slightly more pleasant game out of the
opening and then he allowed the complete
closing of the king side and perhaps fby
felt he should start playing for a win
which is indicated by this exchange
sacrifice on C3 not bad but then after
Rook F3 he continued picking up stuff on
the King on the queen Side by playing
Bishop takes A4 and allowing this break
with F5 which changes the course of the
game very very very dramatically now he
has to defend uh the very weakened King
side F7 is very vulnerable he would like
to play Rook C7 but that square is
unavailable and then uh he just lost
control and somewhere here as you can
see the engine starts saying the black
position is collapsing and Fabian
instead of giving up the bishop on
E8 chose to chose to go for this but
this is maybe even worse and Fabi ends
up going down in this game loses to
saman might to turn around and another
game that uh we watched on our screens
was a l in a game between weso and lean
which is also was a very complicated
positional struggle and it came to a
head somewhere around here with uh only
really the Queens being exchanged and uh
Layman missed a very very good shot here
he could have played Knight C6 leaving
the pawn on H5 even with check hanging
but it picks up a very very important
Central Pawn on D4 instead of that he
played H5 H4 which also looks logical
with the intention of playing G4 KN G3
takes takes and now maybe he was to go
kn6 next move but unfortunately for him
F5 followed by C5 oh and suddenly the
kn7 is very very vulnerable he was
forced to go for this position that's a
beautiful and from here uh Wesley was in
control and ended up winning a very very
nice game as we have seen on our screen
so plenty of decisive results we once
again have around with only one draw
that was a beautiful uh tactic nicely
done Tanya uh after two eventful rounds
of Blitz tell us the standings that was
a roller coaster of we're shuffling the
leaderboard every time we had a
three-way tie for first and now we have
a five-way tire for first there are five
players with 11 points including Ali
Resa Fria including Fabiano caruana all
the commentators pick are in the mix
right now and there we see this is going
to be just completely unpredictable and
for more analysis let's head over to
Anastasia so I was covering had my eye
on the game which also was decisive it
was a game between V gra and Yan pishi
um crazy game actually strategical
Sicilian and both players were really I
think well prepared in the opening and
they were just maneuvering and you can
see that they actually exchanged most of
the pieces at one point but I think NEPA
was actually pushing the whole game he
brought his Knight on D4 um so white has
to exchange the Knight for the bishop
and you can see the that the pawn
structure of black is better so what
Young has achieved he managed to win a
pawn at the end of the day uh but still
it seemed like Maxim is having things
under control there were some tricks
couple of tricks in between but U let's
go to the very end where um they came to
this Rook ending with the pawn up for um
Yani pomi look how how well he played
this ending I mean he played this G5
move I think very good one trying to uh
get some squares uh the king side and
later on Maxim has done like few
inaccuracies which I mean easy to do
when you don't have so much time on your
clock and you know Yan who's playing
really well in this kind of situations
so now it turned out that this ending
already is better for for black is
winning for black actually so the king
is also like coming to the Queen's side
and um later on okay Yan created you
know couple of plants he was mixing two
plants and he managed to trick Maxim at
the very end so managed to win this I
mean with not so much time on your clock
I mean it's really difficult to defend
so the game finished eventually in favor
of yan and um now I mean he's I think
he's doing really well so far and it's
time to go for the commercial
[Music]
break ala welcome back to St Louis
welcome back to gr chour last year you
had such a great success really hard to
imagine how you can play even better but
in are you ready to repeat it yeah it's
impossible to play better but um maybe
it's impossible to revisit also but I
will try my best and we'll see I have
good memories here so yeah speaking
about the memories I mean when you
landed here in St Louis when you came
around let's say what did you feel how
was it you know yeah it's there is some
smell that is like good smell and I'm
very happy it's always like everything
is very comfortable the organizer and
they do everything for the players so
I'm really happy here and I hope it
continues all a lot more years and it
will be
amazing um I mean you are coming
definitely from Grand swis I mean just
finished one week ago uh how can you
assess your participation there your
results um what can you say yeah
definitely it was disappointing and I
lost 15 ratings but uh yeah I have the
candidate spot I'm favorite still and
here if I play decent I will clutch it
but we'll
see a lot of players Wesley has biggest
chance to catch me and it will be a very
close fight but um I I didn't play good
there but I hope I it was the experience
I learned and I could improve my play
here but yeah I mean I mean speaking
about this candidate sport um do you
regret for now for example that you
didn't take take part in Baku World Cup
let's say where you had another chance
opportunity to try to qualify because
now it's it's not really easy right to
qualify yeah um I mean I don't if I
really sced 100% about candidates I
would have played poku but it's
something that now I have chance I will
try to use it but if I don't make it
it's not the biggest deal for me I
really want because it's the candidates
also is very difficult tournament just
one player out of eight very good player
goes up so in general I want to improve
my chess and um I don't really think so
much about the candy spot but now that I
have the last tournament and the last
chance it's stupid to not care so but in
general I'm it would be good if I get
the spot but I will not try everything
right like that's very interesting what
you say because I mean I thought that
this is a main goal for the player like
you I mean who is really on the top and
who can fight for the world championship
title to be in the candidates tournament
so let's say what what actually happened
to your motivation let's say is it the
fact that Magnus is not playing is it
the fact that you have some other things
to do in your life like I mean just I'm
trying to understand it better um I it's
just beside Baku I played everywhere I
played Norway chz I played Romania I
played Zagreb but um I I mean Magnus
dropped also it means that there are
things you can play around not only
world championship and I like for
instance I prefer to have number one
rating spot also like it's uh there are
many goals you can achieve in chess it's
not like just or winning Grand chest
tour is also a big thing so um
candidates is also One path but you can
choose other path wow that that's
exactly let's say you have different
goals in Chess World the yeah wow that's
really interesting do do you have um
like is it more important for you for
example to replace Magnus on the top
yeah of course the rating I think is
also very important because if for
Magnus is the best player in the world
he's not world champion so it means
rating is also very important and um
ranking number one is good thing so I
also would like to achieve that but it's
a difficult task CU he's very at top now
let's say can you imagine yourself
participating in Grant to stour in 10
years let's say what do you think your
life will be in 10 years I definitely
see myself playing chess but um if
grandchester exist it's very good news
and I will if they invite me I will
participate but um yeah I see myself
playing chess I hope I achieve my
goals and um we'll see but I definitely
see myself playing CH that's great uh
thank you so much ala and all the best
for you in the tournament thank
you
[Music]
the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches its
epic conclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cup and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 20203 grand
chess tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess club's twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
1st to find
out hello I'm women's Grand Master viim
janova I will be creating content for
Grand chest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit worldes h.org
[Music]
we hope you got your popcorn ready and
the coffee refill as the entertainment
continues in the blitz three rounds the
third round is coming up yes two games
down already should we take a look at
the standings absolutely they were fast
fast fast and here we have it after two
rounds of Blitz after two rounds of
Blitz it's half half the players are on
top of the leader boards a total of five
with 11 points yes it is a close close
fight crowded at the top Al raaza Fab
Yan mvl Ray Robson all with 11 and Sam
Sean if that one game you hadn't lost on
time uh VAR would be looking very happy
right now only half a point
behind feta what do you think looking at
the standings right now with yanan's
performance how are you feeling about
your I'm just you know I'm very very
excited for for the next two days I
think a close race is exactly what we
need and here are the pairings and Yan
plays against Wesley so we've got Fabby
against Jeffrey Jeong Liam versus Sam am
and ala against fuja that's got to be
our Mari match up abely I'll go with
that one no question about it we'll
focus our energies there but Gary versus
Ray Robson just so many great matchups
uh Peter uh you one of the high quality
chess it is we keep we keep on returning
to this but uh we see fully expressed uh
chess art and uh also of course a lot of
split split second decisions and
intuition playing the the very very
important part I'm just stunn how that
game turned around between Fabby and Sam
when Fabby played the move Bishop takes
A4 winning the pawn but allowing the
move F5 it was like Sam just played
perfectly there after wins a game and
maybe he was seriously worse it's
possible the engine definitely suggested
Fab had the upper hand there but another
topic we could be coming back it's
better to do it with a diagram in front
of us but uh the it's much easier to
attack than rather than defend in and in
that game we saw the moment Sam went on
the offensive the tables turned very
very comprehensively and Fabi found it
very difficult to to manage his position
once he had to defend Tanya what stood
out for you two rounds of Blitz just
amazing chest throughout but I think Yan
this man in front of our screen he's the
one to beat he's the one to watch out
for it just feels like we're seeing a
completely different Yan in the blitz
than what we saw in the rapid very
convincing victory in round one against
Ray Robson he made it look sharp and
good in round two as well a determined
Yi in front of us who's impressed you
the most I know it's early in the day my
pick
F he started two out of two he defeated
uh tournament leader Ray Robson in the
second round now I have to say Ray
gifted in those two moments with Rook C7
as well as the F2 Pawn but you call it a
gift yes but it felt like it was
pressure building up when you're playing
on seconds these things happen at that
moment precisely if uh Ali Raza was
putting on the pressure and it it really
is virtually impossible will play
Flawless chess where you don't make a
mistake especially Under Pressure Tanya
predictions in this one ala against
Maxim let's start with Peter on this
Peter how does this end I like ala for
this one me too yeah easy pick for you
you know what just because both of you
went with ala I'm going to say Al FR
let's go Maxim very good very good as uh
this uh game uh is surprisingly enough
between uh two of the top five
leers French number two there you have
it five which makes me realize Al France
didn't really work I was going to say
that was that was hedging your bet very
very I was 50/50
there nicely done Tanya wow but I have
to say once again uh for me the quality
of the games has been very very high
furthermore it's sort of like I I I
blinked and two rounds just went by they
it happened so quickly it's Blitz it is
Blitz it's Blitz and that's the nature
of the game the clock so important and
we've been seeing some high quality Top
Class chest by the players I just saw
something that suddenly intrigued me it
was a picture of the playing Hall I'm
watching the Arbiters if you're an
Arbiter uh Peter in uh the blitz what
are the things that you look out for as
an Arbiter what are you concentrated
upon I'm not entirely sure we have seen
some uh double-handed play already in
this tournament you could be looking for
people for players to uh you know adhere
to the rules of Chess closer than you
normally would In classical where those
situations don't really come up but
putting your putting your pieces on the
squares and not sliding them or
something like that pressing your clock
but I think I think in this field with
people playing uh fairly cleanly and uh
correctly if you will and and correctly
I think the Arbiter is don't
really I think the best day in in in
arbiter's life is where you don't have
to do anything because there are no
conflict situations theam yeah there are
no uh contentious moments that arise at
all and I don't think we will see very
many frankly in this field no I do too I
think that the players have so very very
well behaved indeed at the board and uh
are aware that in Blitz they have to be
you know more careful uh by the way I
just want to say that in this opening
this particular English I've always
liked the position for white I find that
I if Black's Queen gets bumped around
too much and white gets a big lead in
development the only way and this is the
move H7 H5 is to make a little
contentiousness because if you allow
white a comfortable life castles D4 it's
good H5 kind of throws a spanner in the
works H4 Bishop T Bishop to H3 sorry
Place yeah you're absolutely right and
it's the kind of move that can be really
disconcerting especially in Blitz when
you've got little time to face it to
find the best response and we see Ali
resa's taken a pause because do you go
Castle because that just invites black
to push further that's exactly right no
I don't want to encourage my opponent
Castle's H4 would how the black sorry y
it's okay I was just going to finish the
point about allowing H4 The Black Queen
on E5 which is centralized is just
ideally placed to slide over over to H5
a square when the player will slide over
to H5 he's not going to put it in the
middle of anything that's going to be a
very clear lining up of the rook and the
queen attacking the king side so he
stops it all with H3 so that if black
ever goes H4 you want to close down the
king side with G4 exactly that's the
intention H3 in order to meet H4 with G4
Bishop to F5 an indication by the way
that we're not playing H4 anytime soon
and
maybe it depends this Knight has to go
E3 uh first to question where do you
want to go with the bishop I do want to
go Knight E3 sorry
T no 93 is a really great idea but I'm
just wondering that you know we're
talking about H4 G4 but we might that
might still be on the cards because it
weakens dark squares as well in in a
preceding middle game we might be seeing
the bishop and the queen lined up so for
white it's still a choice are you ready
to go kingside castling you can't go
longside
anyway no I'm not going to go long side
I'm not going to go short side uh too
soon either I do like this move very
much by uh White B2 B3 you want to put
your Bishop on B2 so you can smack the
queen around a little bit with the move
Knight to uh D5 Bishop B2 again
threatening a jump of the Knight the
queen drop back to E6 uh now the the
chances of uh castling into safety I
don't know how safe it is by the way but
uh castling uh does make more sense now
that the queen is not eyeballing uh H2
the queen and the bishop can't be lined
up so shot Castle is on the by the way I
think we saw A2 A3 I think that's a
Prelude to Queen C2 you may not want to
be disturbed by Knight B4 to D5 I really
like how no one's blinking with their
King right it's keeping the tension you
want to keep it in the center when are
you going to go sh Castle what is the
right moment and just waiting for the
other player to decide uh the safety
zone for the King exactly we just saw
Bishop D4 okay this Knight is going to
one day go to C5 or C7 and we did see B4
taking away the C5 Square so very
quickly Knight C7 and both players like
you mentioning T Tanya uh delaying their
own castling uh for me this bishop on B4
is frankly too strong I would play the
move Knight A4 he did it yes and I like
that because you're not only getting rid
of the bishop you're eyeing the C5
Square for the Knight to jump in exactly
and White's point is to wait for black
to go Castle on the king side of the
Rook from h8 uh slides over to f8 and H4
doesn't come in with that much power and
I'm I'm pretty sure that once Maxim
commits to castling that's when white
will decide that he's ready to put the
king to saf wholeheartedly agreed
wholeheartedly agreed in fact uh after
this move Queen E7 I find myself drawn
to the idea Bishop takes D4 and queen C5
then suddenly the idea of leaving my um
uh King in the center of the board with
the Queens off uh starts to take
precedent then I'm not so anxious to
Castle anymore Bishop takes D4 and Ali
Raza said no I want to play Knight C5 no
Queen C5 for you Knight C5 and we're up
to date with a play Queen B2 so now he's
threatening to take on E6 and The Rook
on D4 will hang so he need to retreat
with the Rook or defend it he decides he
reaches out for the rook and comes all
the way back to d8 exactly Rook d8 again
he's thinking maybe after Rook d8 to
play the move Queen E5 again uh with the
Queens off the board I'm not upset about
my king being in the center uh quick uh
why or black who do you prefer who do
you like black instinctively I I I don't
know and I'm maybe the computer would
disagree with this but I like Black
Knights there I like the idea of H4 in
the air it just feels a bit more active
my d8 Rook is eyeing d to you mentioned
this point of Queens being traded your
Rook on H1 is still far away from the
game um I'll pick black what about you I
hate the move Knight B3 I hate the move
a lot in fact and I did like H4 and
Knight F4 for black but I don't think
that uh Ali raza's Knight B3 was
inspiring it it gets the feeling that
something he's not happy about in the
position if you have to right right and
now suddenly this move H5 H4 really does
feel good even though NV didn't go for
it he played I'm somewhat surprised he's
been delaying it pretty pretty clearly
it's one of the main theme of the themes
of the position I think why probably
doesn't react for the time being maybe
Queen C7 is intended to make the idea of
H4 stronger because maybe alz Was
preparing to meet H4 with Queen E5
although the queen on E5 could be kicked
Away by Knight D7 for instance okay uh
but yeah there is this strange interplay
uh in progress right now where
H5 H4 is I think the major major idea
and white isn't stopping it and black
isn't playing it so I'm not entirely
sure and finally finally it does stop it
by the way uh again I if I had been in
mvl shoes and I've played the move H4 I
would have been finding myself my
optimism would been soaring uh missed
opportunity perhaps but with this move
H4 one of the things about this bishop
on G two it is cramped by this Pawn on
e4 the bishop now has an opportunity to
resurface on an active diagonal Bishop
H3 on White's agenda what do you think
black should be doing here if you're in
mvl shoes uh Tanya I like that plan that
you're pointing out Bishop H3 because
black would never want to double up the
pawns on E file and perhaps you're
already looking at The Rook sliding to
E8 as a response to that uh but for now
Maxim vasher lrav he centralizes the
Knight and asks the question to White's
Knight on E3 what you doing if you trade
on D5 I think black would be happy to
take with the pawn or or would you
consider Rook to D5 both I feel have
their own and we're going to find out
now which one we going to find out what
would you pick instinctively probably
with the Rook the problem I'm having
with the pawn is that it does allow Rook
C1 with the tempo and White's the first
to grasp the open file with a gain of
tempo so Rook takes D5 on the board uh
with the idea that let's keep this Pawn
backward if we can not anymore he
challenges it immediately with D3 and
it's not a pawn sacrifice because that
Bishop on G2 is xring The Rook on D5
well is that the case so if I take you
take the Rook I take the pawn I can hit
the bishop the rook and The Rook uh
there is E6 hanging sorry there was a
tactical sequence there that I think
favored white so that was why we saw
Rook E5 but now things are changing
again uh things have shifted once more
and I'm beginning to favor Ali raza's
position I like taking on e4 and I like
taking control of the defa with Rook to
D1 if you would take an E4 I think Maxim
is hoping to try and trade off the light
Squad Bishop with Bishop E4 which
inevitable I can't stop it yes and which
is a trade I think which black would be
happy with and I think we're going to
see that happen on the board actually
and Rook D1 as
advertised uh The Rook is actually you
you will take on G2 as you said trading
the light Square Bishops but this Rook
hitting the E2 Pawn will suddenly bite
on granite and is he threatening rookie
to Knight F4 in some positions uh these
are ideas that white needs to watch out
for could be a trap of course absolutely
so immediately E3 just taking away the
F4 square and by the way this uh Pawn on
E3 uh forestalls the activity of the
Rook now here's a key moment and I
wanted to say the key moment was I don't
think we should be trading Knights if
I'm in white shoes I like the idea of
utilizing uh my majority so my knight on
D4 is protected your knight is not
protected by a pawn I'm still liking
Black's position and I think that's
because of the the king situation the
diagonal a to H1 can be something that
comes into Black's favor at some point
once a queen lands on it the control
over the dile uh the Knight on e4 more
active than the Knight on F3 you just
compare each and every piece in the
position mhm and I feel that if anyone
has an edge here it's got to be Maxim
okay uh those are fighting words uh
because one of the things that I always
love about middle games where um uh
there's the major pieces and there's a
buildup of forces is who King is safer
just answer me quickly who King is safer
this is so tough here bit I'm going to
pick black actually and I pick white uh
because I have an extra and I pick the
side which has a minute against six
that's a brilliant point and we
completely forgot about the 17th piece
which is the clock 5 Seconds to Ali Resa
fuja no he's gone way too oh he went way
too down on the clock I wanted to say I
thought White's King was a bit safer
imagining White's Knight going to
G5 look at the queen it's London D5 on
the diagonal the F3 Knight is pain the
Knight on C5 nicely stops counterplay on
the SE line I'm still picking black here
yes okay uh again4 Knight E1 check
Knight E1 check is a big threat Queen F3
was a big threat in case the Rook moved
as well Rook C8 I'm still I'm still
thinking that if I could get in you know
a rook takes d8 and queen C6 there's
been a turnaround this is now definitely
more pleasant for white because the King
on G8 will feel a lot draf tier I think
well I was
saying it safer oh my God this is a
roller coaster now it's hard it's I have
to say that I agree with you yes the
night jumping on to G5 and look at that
aliv Resa with 5 Seconds has to control
this position Peter 5 Seconds assuming
control frankly Knight why are we not
playing Knight G5 there I guess Queen F6
yeah just could of six holds yeah but
wow that five seconds oh my goodness we
take on
A3 and we're getting an update that
yishi continues his fiery form in the
blitz as he takes down Wesley so and by
the way that's a I I stand corrected on
that Wesley so scores a big win against
Yan uh so Yan's hot Street comes to by
the way big turn around with that pawn
sacrifice what the heck is fuja doing
he's just blundering his pawns all over
the place yeah down down to for not very
much yeah and is back in pretty much
full control well he's got this game
under better than an attack Knight F6 is
just one threat you have to watch out
for there's a f in the air the times 10
seconds to what 12 seconds 32
now F's playing on increment he's
playing every move on increment and he
has been but 93 check this is this is
winning just simply winning now is he
going to just start pushing the pawns he
first just controls the position in a
classical game he would have win this oh
Queen ofan check coming in you have to
should be this should be very Comfort
that's Queen F1 wins and ala knows it
Max knows it you can jump in with your
knight to C5 but the a Pawn's too fast
and Ali Resa knows it's all over he
resigns Maxim wins the game Let's head
over to another player who is currently
leading versus Jeffrey big one and wait
is that an extra piece on the board yes
it is but it's very hard
if it's only one point but the crazy
part is the light squared Bishop is
hampered by these very good black pawns
F5 E6 F7 not so easy how do you break
through and that's very instructive the
way Jeffrey has placed his three pawns
limiting White's Bishop's uh scope of
activity here but just you have to watch
out for your king safety again any Queen
trade and it's game over white wins the
end game exactly and he has somehow
Bishop B8 Bish Bishop E8 this is this oh
and you see a little nervousness there
Bishop E8 is going to do it he gives a
few oh he comes back he's going for the
king but now you go Queen G8 and you
trade yes sir that is uh clear that is
clear but I yeah he's reaching but he
must be winning with this yes and the
good news for white is that he's got the
pawn on F2 and not H2 because that would
be the wrong Square so you've got the
pawns that you want and of course you
decline any trade trades
okay so jeffre is just trying to be as
obnoxious as he
can there very very little that you can
do uh anymore now you run out of moves
and White's King steps in the bishop
will defend the F3 pawn and you're going
to end up picking up all of black sponds
it's handshakes Fabby relieved I was
about to say I think this is our first
round where we have all decisive results
no draws Peter two draws out of 15 so
far and but no draws in r no draws at
all in this round and we can start with
this game where uh Fabi played something
that he has actually been playing in
Blitz in particular I think quite a bit
the jaava London with the nc3 bishop
before construction and as is often the
case in modern in the modern uh opening
Theory you just essay the move H2 h44
whatever reason roundabout move seven
and you look at your opponent
quizzically uh and it was a very
complicated game where uh you played H4
but you have no real Attack just yet and
uh somewhere around here there were
potential tactical uh opportunities that
black could have Avail them themselves
of but in the end they got to this
somewhat symmetrical structure in which
uh black is a bit hampered but generally
speaking position is around equal and it
continued being around equal uh with
white trying to launch some kind of an
attack on the kingside in Black uh
trying to stop it and critical moments
came later because uh as you can see
some traits have happened white is
trying to go for the king there's this
very nice blow here by Fabi going Knight
of six with the intention of meeting GF
with Bishop H7 as you can see this is
not actually made but uh Jeffrey decided
not to accept that sacrifice he took
with the bishop won this
pawn and this is still fine for Jeffrey
the King on E7 is reasonably safe uh the
check on before looks scary but Knight
C5 has a good enough reply to it and the
game continued in in reasonable balance
in fact Jeffrey maybe even had slightly
the better of it but a bit later
somewhere around here uh if we go to
this position the combined threat of B2
B4 attacking The Rook on C8 and also
Queen takes H6 resulted in Jeffrey uh
having to give up on H6 and once the H6
Pawn got taken off the board you
immediately understand why white would
be better because the King on E7 it's
not weak exactly but it's now far away
from actually stopping the passer many
end games become a problem for black and
from here on out it felt like Fabi was
in control and he ended up as we've seen
on our screen eventually uh the combined
threats of pushing the H Pawn and
attacking the pawn A5 resulted for black
in in the loss of the A5 pawn and that
pawn ended up questing black a piece and
uh three against two with an extra piece
was converted by by Fabby quite
convincingly and another game uh that I
will try to uh talk about a little bit
is a win for uh Liam Le against Sam
seian who uh after starting very well
didn't really I feel like this game he
didn't play to his best it was a this
kind of a nimzo SL Ragin type hybrid
with this move Bishop D2 which has
become very very fashionable in a lot of
structures these days and they both went
for what I think is the sharpest
possible structure in these types of
lines where white plays 95 tries to play
F2 F4 Bishop D3 and uh launch some kind
of an attack on the king side
and a bit further down we get to a
position like this
where this is a very committal decision
by Sam because uh obviously he wants to
start pushing his Queen side but with
the white having the advantage of two of
two Bishops and the bishop only one in
particular controlling the ideas of A5
B5 B4 it will be very very difficult for
black to launch anything serious on the
on the queen side whereas for white the
plan of playing F3 perhaps pushing
putting the bishop on uh G3 and then
pushing in the center is much more more
uh obvious and much I think easier to uh
to realize and if we go let's say five
moves later it seems like white is going
backwards but in fact this Knight which
was on E5 and it looked like a very
active Square it a that arguably the
best Square on the board this this C3
Square where it cannot really be
attacked by any of the black pieces and
will also be supporting the E34 March
and somewhere here it already looks like
black is in Desperate Straits frankly
because we are almost ready to go like
Rook C1 and start pushing in the center
and uh Sam felt desperate enough to just
give up this Pawn for instance just
stopping E34 was such a priority that he
felt that this is his best chance but
the position is just bad you're Pawn
down you still haven't even created the
thread of B5 before and everything is
collapsing in the center so a very I
think efficient victory for uh Liam l
very very decisive round of of
games thank you Peter and and uh Tanya
do the honors the standing Shuffle those
leaderboard for us if you will please
the shuffling continues five decisive
games are we not entertained yes at the
top of the leaderboard we've got world
number two Fabiano Carana and Maxim
vasher lra with 12 points and right
behind them with 11 points hot on Heels
ala fua Yi and Ray Robson well for me
that's a win by I oh MV was so big but
Anastasia what caught your eye in that
round nice stuff good G good round first
first of all my ask called the standing
s Fabiano Carano finally leading in the
tournament our boy with so I I checked
two games between Anish giri and R
Robson as well as Yan pom and in both
games we had Italian game as a as an
opening um I would like to show what
happened in Anish game from this moment
I think things went wrong a little bit
for Ray Robson former leader of the
tournament so he played this move C5 and
after that Anish just simply closed the
center and made sure that this bishop is
somehow is in trouble on A7 and he will
never come back to the game as you will
see later and Anish simply brought all
his pieces to the king's side let me go
until this point and it seems like uh
Ray didn't want to wait until Queen will
go to D2 Rook will come to G1 and play
this move G6 trying to get rid of this
Knight a really annoying one but Knight
H6 followed up and um this is how Anish
won my first Pawn in this game and of
course he it didn't solve any troubles
any problems for black because he just
continues his attack inj2 very nice move
with the idea to bring his Rook later on
H1 and you can see that Anish played
this game really well uh he was also
also I should say about his time
management Ry Robson was in time trouble
for the most of the game and after like
Rook H1 he didn't have almost any
troubles to convert this position into
winning um let's just check the final
position somewhere around here I mean
you can see that white is dominating so
let's go to the game between Yan Bish
and Wesley so um Wesley stopped Yan from
winning Yan W in two first rounds but
this game was not supposed to to be the
one um things were pretty interesting
until um until the moment they they also
exchanged the the queens and ended up
and descending and I must admit that
after this interesting move Knight A7
black is threatening to play something
like C6 and take this Pawn on A4 and as
well as take this bishop on B5 and then
play Bishop D3 so there are some threats
and Yan started with Knight A5 move
Bishop B7 but for example if you try to
to support this A4 Pawn I Knight B5 will
can follow and then F6 and Bishop D3 so
it it could be very unpleasant for Yan
so he found I think really good move
Bishop D3 he exchanged the Bishops even
though black won the pawn but I think he
could have continued um his uh play with
Rook E7 and later on maybe D5 if Rook a
for example air C8 like D5 and I think
white has enough uh compensation for the
pawn because like Rook A1 is coming and
you can see that this Rook on Seventh
rank can be really annoying at one point
Knight A5 as well so he didn't do so and
he played this move Knight B3 which was
still fine and after Knight C8 he played
Rook A1 which was was already a mistake
he could have um actually threatened the
same Pawn from the other side he could
play Rook A5 and this was much better so
in the game um black actually managed to
keep the pawn and after that Wesley
played really brilliantly he simply
didn't give any chance to Yan um in this
position and um just this Pawn started
to run and a very nice Sacrifice by
Wesley on B2 um I mean I B2 he gave to
nights but you can see that these paes
are simply running and they're
Unstoppable after that and he just
simply promote one of those so nice game
of Wesley I think his mood will be
better after this game and now it's time
to go back to the studio to Yer and and
Peter thank you Anastasia we just don't
know what Wesley so is going to do in
any single game I mean he just played a
marvelous game that was that was great
stuff and the round before this as well
it's Wesley but that's that's the kind
of chest that we love from Wesley when
he finds his rhythm when he finds his
farm he just become such a beast uh tell
us about the pairings coming up uh sorry
before the pairings I have a job I was
trying to get out of some work there
Tanya apologies uh we've come to that
point in the show where we check in with
our friends at Q Boutique and ask about
the 5% friends and family discount here
it comes the 2023 St Louis rapid and
Blitz vest we are proud to announce the
202 3 St Louis rapid and Blitz vest did
I just say that um these knit vests
sport the St Louis rapid and Blitz logo
on the chess and also show the grand
chess tour and the St Louis chess club
logos as well very handsome logos I must
say they are offered both in men's and
women's style so it is a perfect fit for
any chess lovers in your life stay warm
and stay stylish available at Q Boutique
stl.com and now the pairings would you
be so T we hope your friends and family
are also catching up on the action cuz
it is definitely heating up yes let's
take a look at round for Action tell us
about our Marquee matchups Tanya all
around juicy matchups Jeffrey Jang
versus Ray Robson but we are going to
keep our eye on Maxim vasher lrab one of
the tournament's leader taking on Anish
giri who needs to start scoring on the
leaderboard and another Fabiano Carana
my pick for the tournament also the tour
leader is playing Liam Le so two very
big games right there okay mvl will be
our Marquee matchup Fabby will be our
Reserve our backup okay not forget
Wesley so against Ali Resa also I mean
again uh some flip-flopping there for uh
Wesley in the Rapids where he really
didn't acquit himself that well Peter
but
Wesley when he does find his form he's
scary it also continues the story of yan
perhaps not playing his best against
Wesley specifically because they have
this longstanding history of Wesley
having maybe the better of that
particular matchup despite this
tournament clearly uh Yan is having a
better tournament than just not in their
personal games and the story of the
halves and Have Nots are I think there's
there's a split in the field or at least
there are some people who are lagging
behind we have I think seven players on
50% or above and we have Jeffrey who is
struggling and Wesley is despite this
Victory is still uh in danger territory
right uh but the how close it is at the
top is really really uh amazing to see
exactly it is and what does it mean for
the grand chest standings well we know
that Fabby is leading the grand chest t
as we speak he's got two events he's got
two events to go Tanya uh lots of
players are in the mix including Ali
Raza Wesley so and MBL and that's where
the big fights are notice the names that
you just took Fabby ala Maxim they
played only two events they are going to
be fighting it out in the sink field cup
to follow so there's still a ton of
points to be picked up in the Blitz the
remaining games as well as the next
event coming up Fabby feeling good at
the top but not safe no no no no uh not
at all as we see the players getting
ready for this round for and it just
again it just feels like everything is
going by so fast uh catch your
breath and some water just making sure
stay hydrated everyone and we see Wesley
there in a cheerful mood along with re
Robson and Liam
Le I must say that uh I see the players
and they're so friendly off the board
this is not a joke they really do enjoy
one another company they they play all
kinds of games together but at the board
no friendship and there are Gladiators
Rivals and Gladiators and I think they
really enjoy Blitz they really enjoy
this format a lot and you can see it in
the inspiring chest that we are being
treated to exactly as I'm just uh
getting to that game between MV and
Anish giri Anish giri does not lose that
often but sometimes he just lets those
better positions slip away we saw that
in the Rapids he had some very nice
positions that he just didn't score when
he scored he scored from a position he
was an exchange down and went on time
really remarkable uh very very very
strange Topsy terv event for Anish G but
at any moment like Wesley he can turn it
on but this is awesome to see Maxim b
top of the leader board Anish of course
needing those WIS to come in but just
before the start sharing some fun
light-hearted moments there uh and in
just a few moments it's going to be all
competitive all rivalry on the board
what are we predicting are we predict
we've got to do our predictions right by
the way on that note I did get it right
to last time what did you say Al France
Maxim I'm not going to give you that one
I'm going to have to go to the tape I'll
dispute that one as uh we get ready uh
hearty hand clasp and away we go and I
was going to say are we going to have a
night off by Anish G but an says I'm not
going into Maxim's territory and we've
got a Berlin on the board yes uh no
Berlin ending just the rookie one
variation and I just have a I have this
horrible feeling we may see a fizzle in
case we do by the way in case we see the
fizzle we will move to the Fabby game
uh this uh deserves comment this rookie
fight to E2 to E1 uh from a world
championship where you
Magnus Carlson Sergey where you
encourage black to play the move B7 B6
and fianchetto as Bishop making the
argument that the bishop actually isn't
as good as it would be on the F5 Square
you kind of tricked your opponent into
fiening the bishop it's not often that
you say it's a bad idea to fianchetto
the bishop usually Fen Shadows reinforce
the flanks and whenever we see a Berlin
on the board we get these groins right
oh my God not the Berlin again but
berlins can also have a lot of uh a lot
of uh game left in it and I think this
one I don't know how ambitious the
players are but they are going to
continue playing uh yeaha what do you
think are we going to see quick trades
on the E file and fizzling out to a draw
or will Maxim get more ambitious in this
Berlin as bent lson would say nobody
believes you Tanya oh my it's going to
be a fizzle we're going to see trade and
more trades and The Chopping Block is
the E file and The Rook comes to the E
file and there goes one pair of Rooks
and KN and the Knight is going to go and
we'll see I mean May the game might have
some interest if Anish goes for an
imbalance with D6 and C5 we'll see if he
yeah well okay just a second we'll hang
on we we we we might see a little action
if C5 arises on the board then there's
tension in the center it's not that easy
and as you mentioned the only open Line
it is the E file that's where the usual
trades happen exactly but and I see
Maxim he reaches out no Queen trades he
first hits the Knight on F5 so there
isn't time for C5 and he goes forward
with the Knight to H4 so eyeing the G2
Pawn along with the bishop uh on
B7 yeah intriguing I was thinking that
he was going to play Queen D7 rather all
Tempo Knight to
H4 it's getting a little
frisky Bishop to
G3 okay um Queen to D pardon me should I
go Queen to C6 I think if you move the
queen to D7 then white has time to
control the E file Queen C6 on the other
hand does have a direct threat of it's
It's cheeky it's cheeky you're
threatening if only Knight takes
G2 and if white was to give up the
bishop on G3 for the Knight on H4 well
at least it's a bishop Bear right then I
got something to play for right exactly
I'll find some no not no Intrigue there
he played a completely different
approach he said no the open E file is
the Gateway in the position and I want
to play Queen E6 and Rook E8 controlling
the foul and by the way you know don't
don't be anxious to develop your Rook I
may snip a pawn queen E6 what do you
think of that I like it it's like you
said it's uh of course got the natural
idea of bringing the last piece into the
game but it also eyeballs the pawn at
the other end and right now Maxim first
uh does a killer on that Bishop on B7
just blocks out that diagonal and very
nicely pointed out that is the obvious
idea you block out the bishop but now
the bishop on G3 opens up the option of
bringing the Rook into the game exactly
and that might have been the problem
with the move Queen E6 are you also
hinting at Knight E4 bringing the Knight
to the center def I love centralized
nights Knights really flower in the
middle of the board you put the Knight
on the rim it's dim as our PR
predecessors would say nights on the rim
are dim but the night in the center of
the board can be a magnificent uh
stallion I think the new version of that
is Knights on the edge fall off the
ledge or the Hedge something like that
yuck yuck yuck yuck yuck okay we're
sticking to nights on the room got to be
but that Knight on H4 well it had done
its job and after F3 provoked F3 yes it
did it did let's be fair Bishop again uh
White is anxious to play rookie one no
question about it but he doesn't want to
do it at the cost of the A2 Pawn so MBL
first played the move Bishop C4 which
was a Tempo drove the queen away but at
the same time now Rook E1 is going to be
met I would say immediately with Rook E8
and again chopping piece is off the
board
T absolutely and yes I'm going to let
you take the call this is a Berlin it is
a strategic fight but there is a lot of
excitement on another tournament lead
excitement uh shall we go to fabbi
versus Liam I I I really want to Let's
Do It Let's Do It Let's jump to Fabiano
Carana while the Berlin struggle
continues on our other board uh but
Fabby currently also on top of not just
the leaderboard and the rapid and Blitz
but also the tour standings abely
absolutely as we catch up with the
players Liam has the center he has the
two Bishops so far so good except
White's bishop and Knight are actually
very nicely placed this bishop on C5
hits a very vulnerable A7 Pawn the
Knight on C4 is nicely protected on the
C4 Square so the two Bishops have been
neutralized I don't know how do you mov
as well yeah we've had some moves so
let's catch up with our
and you pointed the bishop and the
Knight one of them has been traded off
but also notice that beautiful Knight on
B7 and that strong Pawn on A6 yes uh and
this can be a big distraction for black
to create anything on the king side but
he's got to go for it he starts
expanding with G5 wow I like G5 in
particular because I want to make sure
F2 F4 never happens I think it's more of
a defensive move rather than the uh the
offensive one even though you could at
some point go for an attack on the on
the king side supporting uh that
wonderful Bishop on D5 to be honest I
like this for black and that brings me
to my next question you know black has
got this mobile Pawn structure on the
king side I like White's Knight on B7 I
like the pawn on A6 but how are we
making progress trying to create
pressure on the A7 Pawn I don't like the
Knight on B7 I like a rook on B7 I'd
like to put the Knight back to
C5 more or less to neutralize the bishop
but if I can go Knight C5 Rook
A4 B7 whoa did not see C to C4 happening
aan more or less immediately by clearly
feeling that keeping the the structure
stable was dangerous something could
have happened to him on the king side
and there you see it Queen G7 with the
very clear hint at G4 G3 and uh just a
straight up attack against the the white
king now I do feel it necessary to play
moves like Knight D6 it's on the board
yes Knight D6 may have been missed
though because it hits everything by the
way yeah the Knight on B
7 was not great now the Knight on F5 if
I can M no I was about to say if I can
maintain it on F5 would be great but
Knight somehow went from B7 to
E3 it's been jumping around that's a
full on horse right there and the queen
can come to C5 as well you've got to
watch out for that B Pawn first so Fabby
puts it on B4 but I like that square on
C5 uh but again Liam threatening Rook B5
anytime the queen lands on C5 I it feels
to me that black is the one making
progress here not white I mean the
Knight on B7 was not attractive I prefer
the Knight on E3 but I feel like this
Pawn this pawn and this Pawn are more
weak weaknesses for for um white to have
to defend Bishop G6 Rook B6 Rook d8 it's
easier in my opinion for black to play
this position than for white let's see
how things develop Liam getting
aggressive on the king side but white
can start targeting the weaknesses that
you spoke about the Rook from E1 can
also slide over to C1 and I'm
threatening Queen takes Pawn I feel any
endgame Queen trade I would be very
happy with white because suddenly that
A7 Pawn becomes a big Target I think
you're right that anything where you
where A7 becomes vulnerable you have to
be careful because this Pawn is so close
to promotion on the other hand once
again if I do play Rook B6 if I do get
to play Rook d8 after all what is my
Rook doing I want to hit this Pawn on D3
and if I can win that pawn well it's all
good can white actually think about
tripling up on the sea line but Fabby
has other ideas has other plans he jumps
in with a knight to C4 and what are
these other ideas night take C5 was
possibly a threat and I think uh Le very
correctly takes some pieces of the board
so that he doesn't get night C5 here
Knight to D2 and now funnily enough
remember when the Knight was on B7 and
and I Wasing for nice nice by Fabby can
you go Knight E4 oh he does it it's on
the board Knight E4 so the queen on C3
you've got Knight F6 foring and winning
a pawn and the queen back exactly and
that gives him time to establish a
knight on C5 or retreat with the queen
to a good Square because otherwise he
would have to go to some very unpleasant
squares like A3 or B so King G7 Knight
C5 it's funny that the Knight was on B7
I was pining for it to get to C5 I love
it and after you know maneuvering all
over the board
literally all over I mean I'd love to
see all the night jumps I was about I
was about to ask if maybe our Graphics
team could show us the path of the night
for this for this game because it's been
to it's been to many a place it would be
like the George
Kowski uh night tour you know like on
every Bo every square of the board only
once mileage account is feeling up very
nicely yeah exactly Queen D5 Bishop G6
Rook d8 on Peter what do you think uh
white or black just around equal I would
I would think Tanya white I like Knights
you like Knights I like Knights and I
think that black king on G7 yes to me it
feels like you might have overexpanded
maybe someday I can dream about entering
on the seventh Rank and wow that's a
big but I like it if you open the E Line
you can actually think about rookie
seven at some point okay but that is a
pawn it is a pawn yeah you take it with
the pawn because then I probably put my
queen to D3 okay or or or G May by the
way we do have a breaking news on a
result we have uh Jeffrey uh Jang making
a draw versus who was Jeffrey Ray Robson
that one ends
peacefully by the way his first half a
point of the day half a point of the day
wow wow uh it's been a painful start for
Ray Robson as we just saw the move Rook
E8 want to trade Rooks and yes it is a
pawn and if you take on E8 the bishop
slides back and defends the B5 Pawn so
it's can you go Queen D4 here what do
you think about that end game Queen
takes pawn queen takes Queen Knight E6
Knight D4 I think you should do it I
don't yeah I wow he wants to come in
with the queen3 I'm telling you yes
Knights are so he's playing for
everything but the bishop coming to
C6 that that just you know like I could
play a move like um H4 here and provoke
no
say Bishop I liked your idea of trying
to threaten checkmate with C6 and at
least making sure White Queen stays
there and now Fabby breaking open those
overexpanded pawns on the king side yeah
wow uh big big uh changes going on in
this game uh as we did see a queen trade
after all of that Knight D7 but then
maybe King F5 I actually like what Liam
has done with with this Knight E4 on the
board as as
Fabby aspires to play Knight four
seconds for Fabby he's down oh but Liam
now in the driver's seat Bishop versus
knight this looks terrible for Fabby
terrible and Liam is just making it look
clinical he trades off look at that
bishop and King nicely placed in the
center an extra Pawn the Knight is so
far away from the A7 Pawn now it truly
is and I do see King D5 King uh C4 on
Liam's agenda
but why did he put his
Bishop okay the KN has to come to just a
little bit of Hiccup uh now H4
ISAT yeah no and now King D3 no he
walked into
a and Liam but does he have enough that
D3 pa3 isn't this a queen though Knight
D6 could be or Knight G5 yeah oh my God
and the players are playing on increment
but this King Pawn ending has to be lost
because black sking is so close to B4
but you have to give it up you don't
have an option you have give that up no
that was a very fortunate blunder very
fortunate blunder but now it's going to
be A different race Tanya who's winning
it looks like black should be faster
with the Bon advancing way faster way
faster and that's it what a game what's
left what's where are we going let's
head over to weso against let's go back
to uh our no I meant to say sam Sean
versus Neo let's do it yes and it's a
queen we just arrived to a three Queen
and resignations because there's no
Perpetual no
perpet W
so versus Ali Raza whoa whoa whoa we got
going on here this we've got a full
bodied
struggle and by the way uh
mvl ended up winning against an Gary the
game that we thought was all dry and
this is now very sharp yeah H4 and then
G3 this is probably going to end up
costing Wesley a piece it might still be
a draw though oh you have Bishop D5 you
could a bishop D5 Bishop c yeah okay so
this is this is the position I meant I'm
not sure it's winning for black I'm not
even sure it's much better for black
despite black having an extra Pawn an
extra piece these three pawns are in in
Practical terms going to be very very
difficult too I can't even see Al clock
okay now I can 9 seconds both players
under 10 seconds on the board and Ali
Raza is making moves but it looks like a
draw he's not finding the way as he's
just shuffling with the bishop on the
diagonal well just to butus uh Peter's
Point those pawns are just too good
there's probably a claim available but
yeah there you go they
just wow Peter our Marquee matchup we
missed the victory by take let's take a
look because I also stopped watching to
be honest you convince me nothing will
nothing will happen there
and the last sir the last position I I I
saw with was this and really nothing
should happen here but dead zero yeah
let's take a look so uh Knights come off
and then white suddenly starts
intimating that the king might reach the
G4 square and it does reach the G4
square and suddenly as you can see this
is just winning for white one single
move because the bishop on B7 is
extremely passive the bishop on E6 is a
monster and uh mvl slowly but surely
improved okay and yeah and this is very
clever by the way he provoked a A6 and
now he goes Bishop F5 check kicks the
king away from the G6 square and attacks
the PA A6 Tak F5 and then he takes the
F5 square and from this moment on you
have to assume everything is just going
to collapse so a very very uh nice
Victory there for for mvl from a
position honestly all of us thought is
not really going to offer us very much
in a way of excitement but we were all
completely wrong very nicely done by MV
from a desert to an oasis yeah and uh
the one that we finished watching on
screen this is uh another of those
jababa londons in the game between
Wesley so and lza fuia and uh in this
position uh this is another one where I
actually covered this
in let me PL plug my course for 10
seconds I think the two best moves in
this position are H3 and I I will give
you no prizes for guessing what's the
second
one develop H4 get out of here no you
you need to give squares to this bishop
on F4 and what happens if you don't give
squares to the bishop on F4 after Bishop
B2 ala played Knight H5 the bishop has
to be given up and you end up in a
position like this which engines just
instantly prefer for black and ala
seemed like he was very much in control
somewhere here because it looks like the
pawn on D5 is weak but it it will be
covered rather comfortably and if we go
a bit further let's say five moves later
we had a position like this which looks
fantastic for black right you have a you
have pressure along the C have this
proud knight on e4 yes there's a square
on E5 with Knight on F3 but the black
king is safer but Wesley somehow managed
this perfectly he took a couple of moves
to safeguard the king and then uh ala
decided to offload some pressure by
trading on C3 and From This Moment On
even though the position isn't really
better for white it felt like it's
definitely an improvement for Wesley uh
there's been a lot of obviously there's
been a lot of play and uh eventually alz
opened things up with B5 before as you
can see there's also some things
happened on the king side here the
structure has has been somehow changed
and Wesley is a pawn up here but he
ended up uh I guess messing up and the
the break on the king side that we we
saw uh ended up costing him here this
break ended up costing him the P but he
still he still defended quite well and
the game that very much attracted my
attention was this game between uh Sam
savian and uh Yan pishi where this is a
classical real where Yan says let's play
a marshall Sam says no Marshall for you
and to me i' I've been playing the
Spanish with both colors all my life
this is real relatively new and I think
this is maybe U one of those little bits
of uh Match Prep that is still remaining
in in Yan's Locker so I was very curious
about it Knight A5 obviously you can if
you
want win a pawn here but black will play
Bishop B7 black will play for very quick
D5 breaks it's not these types of
positions tend to end up being very
close to equality instead uh Sam play
Bishop A2 D6 he played B4 Knight C4 this
is still playable but his decision
somewhere around here I think was not
great I I don't really like the move A4
A5 stopping any kind of pressure on the
queen side and after D5 already uh black
is playing for Advantage takes takes the
point being that Central Pawn is
seemingly hanging but you can play Queen
C7 attack the Knight on 5 protect the
pawn on C6 and we will take on B4 next
move so is very comfortable here same
instead Play Bishop A3 and this already
doesn't look right at all no we have a
very passive Bishop on A3 we have a
backward Pawn on D2 no n is cruising
yeah
uh ended up in some kind of position
like this where we see a lot of Trades
but the pawn A5 is very weak as we will
see literally in the next couple of
moves black just picks up on A5 there
was some counterplay on the king side
because you you do land your knight on
F5 the Knight on F5 in any kind of a
Spanish position gives you some hope but
he undefended well uh didn't really make
and actually a very nice tactical
tactical Skirmish here which I think Sam
thought he set a very nice trap here
with Knight H6 check and if King h8 we
can take on E5 oo and then take on F7
nasty and win and win but unfortunately
for him after GTX HC he he thought he
was winning a rook here no such thing oh
[Music]
oh4 and and that led to Yan winning a
very nice game with the black pieces
incredible tactics all around and just
how sharp are these guys well let's take
a look at our standing Shuffle up the
leaders for us if you please oh it's a
sharp leader board as well right there
because we've got a sole leader with 13
points it is Maxim Bia lra and uh tied
for second going is Fabiano Carana and
Yan fi and then we've got Ali Resa and
Ray Robson with 11 and a half and with
more insights on all the chest let's
head over to
Anastasia Tom that was round four I had
my eye on the game between Ray Robson
and um and Jeffrey Jon and actually it
was a really important draw for Ray
Robson after losing four games in a row
if we also count the game from yesterday
sometimes it's really good just to make
a draw and actually he choose the line
which seemed to be the one um it's very
known itical battle where normally black
can keep the pressure but you know there
was this critical moment where after
rookie one Ray needs to develop his
pieces so he played this move Bishop B6
and Jeffrey came out with a nice um idea
F5 you know trying to ruin King's Side
Pawn structure and after G takes F5 he
played this move Queen G3 but instead of
this move he had a really nice blow he
could take on A6 and if black takes play
Queen F5 moving to really nice Rook
ending for white with this very active
Rook on A7 with good chances to win of
course black um could play something
different after Queen F5 they could play
Rook E8 but you can see that the
position is not so great and if we ask
about the king king's safety black king
doesn't look so great anymore so but um
Jeffrey quickly played this move Queen
G3 and then he thought for two minutes
trying to figure out what just happened
and what happened was just a repetition
after that he didn't find anything
better than just to repeat the position
and this is how Ray Robson finally made
the draw and um mean after very dramatic
start of the day yeah it's time for us
to go for the commercial break but
before that let's see the chat my chat
with Anish
[Music]
giri Anish welcome to St Louis welcome
to gr tour what was your last time
actually in s Lou and what was your
first time do you remember how many
times you've been here before wow I
wasn't prepared for this question I
don't recollect exactly what was the
first time I remember playing here in
2015 it was it was a very good year for
me in the granch tour uh I almost won
the Tour so I definitely played here I
don't remember if I played before uh as
well and um I haven't been here I think
for a while I think last time in 2019
you played
that's I have very bad memory for years
I don't remember like 19 like I have few
reference points in my life like I know
I have to remember my wedding
anniversary that's really important I
also very clearly remember when I met my
wife um I
remember that also because the was the
regima tournament that I won so I
remember the year very clearly uh so I
have few of these markers that I
remember but everything in between is
very bag for me it's getting even worse
you have three kids you have to remember
their birthdays too yes yes no I mean
they're very few numbers I can memorize
and um every different year I played
singold cup is not it's not doesn't make
the cuts with all due respect to the to
the event just doesn't make the cut I
just don't remember I I have I have good
memory for chess positions for chess
ideas um for like faces for things but I
have very bad memory for just these four
digigit numbers which are like years and
ratings like I just don't remember like
I'm 19 18 or like my rating also 26 I
don't know 53 52 I don't remember the
funny thing is you haven't played last
year but it was like it it feels like
you were with us you know commenting on
the event all the time you know this one
you should definitely remember people
tell me that everybody feels like I'm
with them the whole time really okay I
remember just your yeah you should just
log off Twitter sometimes and then
you'll feel some peace from me yes I see
and um um actually um you just come you
coming from Grand Swiss event which was
just finished recently one week ago how
can you assess your participation there
the tournament yeah I was very happy
with the way Grand Swiss finished I won
my last three games but I think um I had
the sort of short run at the Qatar and
Grand Swiss which are both open
tournaments I played a lot of low rated
players and I think that run came to an
end I think it was reasonably successful
I gained some crucial F circuit points
so I think that that's that's okay I I
accomplished sort of my um my goal um
for this uh for this sequence uh but but
now I'm back to uh the top tournament
with very different um uh kind of lineup
and just the your usual sort of
situation where uh it's all very close
in the level and you don't need to win
um so many games um and you you
know sort of the level and the um
tightness is just very different so I
think it's going to be a very different
tournament than the one I just played
and um looking forward to it yeah I saw
this interview where you said that you
had to adjust in your style because of
of the format of the tournament before
so do you said already you have some
issues with adjustment but I mean I mean
what would it means that now you play in
the tournament of different format you
will you have to be again more stable or
what exactly means like like you
mentioned I have issues with adjustments
so it means that probably I will I will
finally Len up here when it's too late
and uh start getting uh getting my ass
kicked so no I'm sure you will figure it
out I have feeling that you had enough
experience my uh you would think that
sort of uh
you know the the stability is something
I can um always fall back on but uh you
never know and also I'm looking forward
honestly to play in the rapid and blaz
and also in the classical event I I have
not too much to lose in a sense um my
main qualification path to candidates is
through Fe the circuit and then if I
play this event badly it's not not an
issue at all but it would really help if
I play it really well so yeah might
um might do you know things a little B
more we it
uh maybe I'll like not make like nine
drops maybe eight this time I mean also
I think people don't know exactly let's
say about these points and the
difference now between you and Wesley
and GES let's say in this F ccle there
is a difference and let's say can you
imagine some can you explain us the best
way scenarios and the worst case
scenarios which can happen let's say
because we know that grur is a part of f
circuit right so still there kind of
to get the spot yeah of course like
every tournament is part of that so um
uh I mean not to go into details but
like um clearly Wesley if he has a
tremendous performance here uh he will
get the lead um if I if I
don't um so there's still all to play
for but um yeah I'm in a good position
let's say and uh I'm looking forward
just to to play It's better of course to
to be leading right in this situ yeah no
it's always better to to win them to to
draw and to draw them to lose that's the
what I learned through my years of
experience that's for sure yeah I think
it's a really good moment to finish this
interview and wish you good luck in the
tournament thank
you hello everyone and welcome back to
our live coverage of the blitz Tanya
it's been fast fast pace it's been a
fast roller coaster and we're not
getting off it anytime soon as the
action continues we are about to kick
off round five well after four rounds of
Blitz tell us about the standings T and
there we we are we've got a sole leader
with 13 points it is none other than
2021 World Blitz Champion showing his
class here in the blitz he has leap
frogged into first position but just
behind him just a onepoint lead and
that's just too little to relax bbby and
Yan exactly and just behind them Ali a
Ray Robson we have
a matchup coming up pairings for round
five which is going to feature faban Yan
I'm going to think that that's got to be
a marquee you make the choice Tanya I'm
with you yes of course our tournament
leader it is um uh
Rays Ray Robson versus Maxim V we will
keep an eye out on that but with Fabby
against yanami both of them tied for uh
second place and given their form given
their style of play that's got to be the
most exciting one what about you Peter
what stands out to you in this bearing
those two are obviously the picks yeah
choosing between them is difficult but
having picked Yan for my fantasy for my
fantasy team I I want to watch that one
me too and I think Yan watching Yan play
Blitz is very I mean he's so emotive and
so expressive at the game that I think
having him on camera is very much an
added bonus it's a joy can you read him
by the way because I have a very hard
time reading OS tells if you will well
it helps if you know what's going on on
the board in in an unclear position not
so much but you will know if he's in
trouble I think yeah okay and we are
underway as round five is getting
started and we are following the game
between nepo and Fabby and we're going
to have our Reserve game the game of mvl
and Ray Robson as we've got this bishop
B5 check anti n or you want uh trading
and then we saw a very early E5 so it
looks like a very close position is what
we've got here looks like a bit like
copy cat chess had black just put that
Knight on F6 the pawns and the're very
symmetrical uh we've had a trade of
pieces the lights squ Bishop but very
symmetrical Pawn structure there so
there are no D4 D5 braks and very often
in this it's about the braks in the
Flank In the Middle game yes which side
gets in an F4 or an F5 or a B4 break on
the queen side exactly and this is a
very Cy setup I must say Bishop E7 to
d8 uh making room for the Knight on E7
just as you said so that the Knight
doesn't go to F6 and conflict with your
break F5 NE nepo went for the B4 break
as you said the it's about the flanks
now you've got to play B4 because you're
not playing F4 anytime soon I think
we're going to see both the breaks on
the board Black's going to go for the F5
kingside break while
nepo has managed to get in a play on The
Queen side with Fab's got to be thinking
about F5 right
now he doesn't go for itly enough no I
was going to support you wholeheartedly
he played in the move Knight G6 now if
I'm in Neo's shoes I'm thinking Knight
D5 Bishop E3 and Blasting open the B
file with a move B4 takes C5 so first he
starts with Bishop E3 saying please do
me a solid not GNA do it not gonna do it
B7 B6 and because the queen is
undefended this move Queen A4 is more
than annoying I'm about to say the night
is again
eyeballing you never want to fall for
Knight D5 and queen takes E6 it's on the
board it's on the board F5 has arrived
and that means it's going to be a lot of
fun so it's all about who gets to which
side first black clearly eyeing the
king's side while Yan has got all his
pieces including that Knight which has
just gone to D2 can land on e4 the other
Knight gets on D5 is looking for play on
The Queen side but I agree with you yes
it just feels like White's pieces are
better are are more ready are reier to
strike reier reier to strike nice love
it uh Knight E4 and again uh Knight will
come to D5 next and this KN on G6 is
looking a little forlorn one of the
things I would try to do if I was I was
about to say is I would if I was white I
would be trying to uh trade my Bishops
for one of the knights because I'm
thinking that these Knights on D5 and E4
will be very well placed whereas this
bishop on d8 as you notice doesn't
really have a good Square please Tanya
absolutely the one threat that you have
to watch out for is a move like F3 for
black I really that's the dream I really
want to get F3 especially considering it
Blitz and I'm just saying I'm coming for
your king F3 Queen G4 or queen H3 and uh
starting to Checkmate you so is this the
moment for Yan to actually stop that
forever with a move like F3 himself and
he does it
yes uh the answer is
yes sharp sweet and precise exactly but
you are very right you do not want to
allow your opponent the opportunity to
play F3 Yan put the kabash on that uh
idea for fab right away with F3 and
again from White's perspective Ive he
wants to play Knight D5 but okay where's
your next break uh neppo I mean you're
not going to play G3 you're not playing
D4 probably you want to play A5 but to
do that your queen you would like to
trade Queen so Knight to D5 trade Queens
get in A5 from Fab's point of view if
you're in Black's shoes here this Pawn
on D6 is a little
tender yeah what do what's your goal
here is black it's not so obvious for a
moment I was very excited for Black's
position spotting the F3 idea but now
that that's been stopped forever all the
points that you made earlier about the
knights jumping in the more mobility of
white spawns on the queen side it feels
as if black Fabby here has to be really
careful and I want to ask you if Fabi
was to jump in with the Knight the D4
seems like the Outpost that I want my
knight to land on an end game the queen
trades yep who does that favor white
white uh simply white because once again
that Bishop on d8 is not wear not
winning any Oscars for uh a
performance best performance and in fact
we've just seen the move H7 H6 an
indication that well I'll just make lift
I'll improve my position maybe I'll move
my king to the side but there's not
anything very concrete for is it that or
does he want to go G5 and completely
entertain us it feels G5 would create
more weaknesses than anything else but I
would be very very reluctant to reach
for the gon what I'm doing with white uh
is I'm recognizing that the E file is
the only open Avenue I'm thinking Rook
E1 I'm thinking Knight F2 I'm thinking
Rook E4 Knight to G4 so if you want to
play G5 and we in the F6 Square uh
you've got my attention but rookie one
feel and your approval as white go G5 it
does help white more than black and I
like this move that he's just made
putting that Bishop on H4 because uh Yan
did play Rook to E1 all right things are
getting spicy now G3
G3 uh Yan said okay I'll take the
gauntlet I'll I'll pick up the challenge
the bishop on d8 again was not playing a
role Bishop
H4 is Queen H3
ridiculous I was actually thinking about
taking on G3 and then going Queen H3 but
now that you mentioned Queen H3 I like
it as well but how are you following it
up after white captures on H4
and I'm suddenly getting a little bit
interested Peter how about you are you
getting interested absolutely and maybe
if we want to do it we need to do it now
because why definitely goes King G2 next
move if you don't and you will no longer
have he's that window closed in an
instant King G2 didn't ask twice
covering protecting pardon me against H3
and Fabby feels like he's a little
nervous what's the clock times he's kind
of meant made that
move a little bit nervous nervy it's
about the clock and the position I think
both our positions that get you a little
tense it's under my spidey sense is
tingling Knight C5 Rook takes E7 Queen
takes C6 but you end up just being an
exchange ah you want to take I we need
arrows to show that yes Peter please
continue what happens with it KN C5 Rook
E7 there is a rook e two
check Knight C5 D takes C5 Rook takes E7
Rook takes C7 Queen takes C6 the tactics
were not working up we're not working up
but now now they do now the threat was
Knight takes C5 so Bishop went back to
d8 so what happened with that Bishop
Sally The Rook on C8 did magically
appear on
f8 still this is annoying annoing
pressure because you really want to jump
with that Knight to D4 F3 Pawn is a bit
soft I mean if I can keep the Queens on
the board and provoke you to go F4 I'll
be super happy but anytime I jump Knight
D4 you always first trade off the Queens
with both hands by the way just grabb
your queen you can't take it back I
think I do start with F3 F4 by the way
even though I do weaken a little bit my
king side nope Rook H1 Rook H1 by nepo I
don't know if he's thinking about Rook
H5 maybe he was thinking just to stop H5
H4 um what Rook F3 takes spawn
there4 check and King comes oh there's a
queen hanging on A4
oh my goodness did Neo Miss this yes he
did yes can you just show the idea that
we're talking well Rook takes F3 Rook
takes F3 King takes F3 thank you for
your Rook choose your check yes check
and queen takes A4 and that wins the
game for uh fabbi
so there there was a miss and we did see
the headshake uh there wow Rook won a
huge blunder by Yan pishi in a position
that he was completely in control so
he's dropped his F3 Pawn with that move
Rook
H1 on the other hand it's still not so
easy because what
compensation now you just offer a queen
trade no now any end game will be better
for me if I just go Knight E5 yeah the
extra Pawn is certainly better for you
the problem is again that the role of
the bishop is such a passive one that
it's going to be very hard to convert uh
Yan is bearing down again the clock
times the clock times a minute and a
half I think against maybe 47 seconds 4
minut for fa there H5 on the board also
I think Knight E5 would have been a
mistake because the knight from F2 jumps
to E4 at the end and you've got problems
on D6 yes correct yes exactly and we've
been seeing that once the Knight does
land on e4 that pawn on D6 is definitely
a weakness now the with the move H5 he
is kind of intimating that you know the
king's uh shelter will
be uncovered H5 now again uh H4 Queen G4
maybe Yan will would be happy to trade
Queens Peter is this enough compensation
you're not happy you BL I wanted to even
offer a very controversial opinion and
say that in Practical terms it's maybe
more fun to play with white because you
have the more the more Knights plus
Queen okay uh but of course black is
objectively better than question is how
much uh exactly I would suspect this is
this should actually be enough uh to
make a draw with best play by the way G
best play no no Queen G4 by Yan he's
he's ready to play for the attack
himself I'm liking black a lot I mean I
just feels as if White's King is in the
open who pay attention there is a knight
F6 check sighting don't even think about
playing Bishop E1 just comes back to DH
can we take on C5 twice W uh taking yes
so you mean Pawn takes pawn and then T
leader our tournament leader mvl is on a
roll as he takes down Ray Robson he does
and now can you Peter's idea of Knight
takes Pawn here yes Knight takes Pawn
takes Queen takes E5 on the board and
then you've got a bunch of checks but
probably nothing more than that then
because I'm definitely like liking the
queen and the Knight and maybe black has
to find a way to I think it's time to
give a Perpetual give a perpetual and
just draw some if I go King H2 I think
the pret whereas if I go King H1 and
invite the bishop to join with with gain
of tempo that's dangerous but he this is
a very interesting decision to my let's
say
courageous yeah Bishop G5 is a draw so I
think I think fa on 15 seconds here just
takes this draw I don't think you you
fool around against Queen and Knight now
now that you're no longer a pawn up
Queen and Knight especially at the
center of the board give one move look
at this let's fool around let's let's
dance he wants to go Queen F2 King to G4
so then there'll be no checks at all I
think this was a very very risky
decision by
fabbi I Yan is playing for the win here
by the way uh the breaking res G7 G6 Yan
Lin's in there because he what he's been
being given a a move to start giving
checks but the bishop on H4 controls all
all of the important checking Square so
well hold on there was a queen7 check G3
King of the Hill for
yishi is the king going to win the game
eventually we've been singing praises of
the queen and the Knight but the king
just wants to go and collect all the
pawns I really don't like what Fab he
should have taken that potential and you
see the Panic on Fab with just one
second on the clock5 check is yeah I
don't know que5 check seems winning your
Bishop is hanging be careful Fabby I
think we can take well I think we can
take everything and take on C5 and win
that position I think he's going for it
but then the G Pawn no my king is in the
Square yes you've got to waste a move
with your and we just Foster and that's
it that's Fab's about to lose the game
absolutely that's game over the the Deep
Pawn just marches and that's it oh Fabby
I he really over pressed his hand he had
the pet but let's go to our last game
Liam versus Jeffrey Jang and I can
always recognize a Jeffrey Jang game
because he's playing so leisurely his
moves look at that look how leisurely he
plays he's got like 20 seconds he just
like
that's this position has to be
completely winning white can he's really
playing the move with beauty here and
that's how we've got resigns as white
could not have picked up that bond by
the way let's playay our respects this
is Jeffrey's first win of the tournament
he didn't get a victory in the the
Rapids but he has gotten his victory in
the blitz well done Jeffrey Jun
uh
Peter I was so I was so I'm still
tasered by that game between uh this now
I remember yeah this was a this was a
line that I played myself with both
colors this is the one we discussed with
uh during the the rapid portion where
white goes King to King F1 this kind of
a strange English uh English opening and
these days even if we start from here
there is a very interesting dance here
going on this is very fashionable you go
on D3 check you go Knight F4 check and
then you just return to D3 apart from
this move Knight E6 which we discussed
during the rapid this also exists and
this results in these very weird kinds
of positions where black this is move 11
by the way development yeah black black
has barely developed three pawns and
there's a knight missing on G8 somehow
white has developed four pieces but has
a king on F1 and black has a pair of
Bishops uh very sharp position and of
course you play H4 yeah and of course
you play H4 and this actually makes
perfect sense because you won this Rook
to participate in the game because it it
gets it gets lifted into the game by the
H3 Square uh and I kind of stopped
watching this is a actually a sharp
position but then a lot of Trades
happened and somewhere around here after
very logical play I felt uh somewhere
around here I just kind of thought okay
this game will be a draw yeah and I
would need to scroll through but you
have to assume that Liam l must have
made must have made a very very big
mistake somewhere but you can already
see that black is making kind of
progress here probably uh you could have
played cleaner and eventually uh you
know by move by move 40 black has this
protected passer on E3 which probably
also didn't need to happen and
eventually eventually eventually it kept
on getting worse and worse and ended up
ended up here with the HB getting
dropped and white having not enough
compensation for it and the other game I
was uh paying attention to was this
tournament leader yeah mvl uh playing uh
against Ray Robson and interestingly the
same structure Fabby had against uh Nea
against NEPA but with the bishop still
on the board the the difference here
being that the the bishop tradeit hasn't
happened yet it seemed fairly uh fairly
balanced once again the same plan of
playing for the F5 break uh happened the
Bishops are now gone there's been also
as you can see black at some point
played Knight D4 there was a trade on D7
a trade on D4 and it all frankly seemed
to be fizzling out uh somewhere around
here uh you probably prefer black after
uh let's say after this trait happens
black has a protected passer on D4 but
the bishop on F6 is so passive and the
position is so closed that you would
assume that something like this is not
really all that bad and as you can see
the engine also doesn't disagree but
something must have happened first of
all uh Ray by passing and then passing
some more allowed the Bishops to come
off uhoh and then you have problems
controlling controlling the C file and I
have a feeling he just Lo lost on time
because nobody resigns here with white
and if the game ends here you have to
assume that something something quite
rare in a Ray Robson because he he very
often is low on time but he doesn't lose
on time normally but in this particular
case he's in trouble now but he would of
course continue from here and maybe not
even have lost but he did lose on time
wow um a very eventful round all
decisive games no draws Tanya tell us
our standings after five rounds of Blitz
please let's take a look Max
vasher lra with that win against re
really nice strategic win and he stays
on top but now the chasing pack yeah the
needle in the threat is thinned out
somewhat thinned out and the chasing
pack is left to yishi at 13 points but
is half a point behind is your pick yasa
with 12 and a half it is Ali RZA fuja
and Fabby He Slipped down to the fourth
place I just want to point out the
obvious had Ali Raza won that at all
French derby he would
be in clear F that was a while back and
that all Frank Derby and Maxim did
fantastic there and we got chasia please
tell us uh about this round very
eventful round what games did you cover
for
us I was taking a couple of games as
well and one of them was um between ala
fua and Sam S they ended up in this
position and I was actually thinking
maybe white can play this move d4 you
know it's normally either you play D4 or
you give this Square for your opponent
but it didn't happen you know even
though I don't know what about you guys
it takes me I mean it took some time to
realize things like what will happen if
everybody will take on D4 so at the end
of the line it seems like black has this
bishop G5 very strong move um making
sure that Rook will move from C file and
then like black and take on e4 so I mean
this this was possible to play something
like that but it didn't happen I think L
decided to take he decided not to
exchange pieces keep everything on the
board and see what happens next so he
changed the strategy after like moves
Quiet Moves Like H3 H6 he moved his
pieces to the queen side and you know he
just brought his Rooks on the C file and
just kind of asked his opponent the
question what are you going to do with
your pieces they actually are very
passive so what's happening and um of
course it was difficult for Sam to play
this position especially in blit when
you have to kind of defend and find the
squares to your pieces so he decided to
trade a few of them and it turned out to
be not so great um at this moment
because after that it things already
went not so not so well for him and
after those trades it was even worse
because you can see the PA structure is
completely ruined for black so uh L Resa
just took advantage of all those uh
weaknesses and he traded couple of more
pieces and simply took one by one
everything yes so you can see at the end
of the yeah okay black man to take on D3
but everything is falling you know E5
and um uh B7 so I mean a a a pawn is
running so after that I think Sam
decided it's time to end this game and
resigned so I also checked the other
game it was very interesting battle
between Anish giri and Wesley saw
believe it or not after like one minute
um from the start of the game I come I
check the screen and I see this position
move 24 and I'm like oh my gosh I mean
what has happened I mean why do they
play so quickly they know everything
these guys it's already move 24 and here
after Queen G4 this was the first moment
when Wesley started to think and he came
out with not so great idea it's
something like this happens when you
start thinking for too long and he
played King h8 and here I think Anish
had a very good chance to um to play
well he could have tried to use the fact
that this G7 square is weak and tried to
play King G3 or sorry Knight G3 and
after F6 move the only move in the
position uh Bishop C7 Queen D4 probably
he missed this idea of Rook E4 and now
Knight on D4 is hanging and there is no
Rook d8 because Bishop is on C7 the best
what black can do is take um maybe this
Pawn on A2 and gave and tried to play
this position with three points for the
piece but yeah okay white should be
better here instead of it he played this
move Rook C7 and after that it turned
out that Wesley was the one who was uh
on the driver's seat from now on he
played very correctly he played F6 like
Bishop before and it turned out that
white doesn't have enough compensation
for the two points they he he gave
before in the game so Bley played very
very good after that I mean not given
any chance to Anish to um to to to find
a way and come back to the game uh
slowly you know improving his position
and um you can see the final position
like he took one more pawn and okay now
with three pawns down Anish gir resigned
I think it's time for Anish gir to find
his lucky lucky hoodie and bring it back
to the to the tournament he told me
yesterday that actually it was a little
bit dirty and that's why he didn't want
to wear it otherwise he would have done
it a so back to you guys thank you
Anastasia nice game there by Wesley and
you know I'm still tasered by that Fabby
uh that final game because essentially
Neo's King literally went from G2 to B7
was one Brave King and Fabby had an
extra Pawn NEPA demonstrating the power
of Queen and Knight and we had a
fantastic end to that game let's take a
look a little slow motion that's and
remember no time on the clock that his
King has just gone all the way up the
board and he's calculated already a king
and pawn AME calculated with seconds on
the clock to Precision that white just
grabs that final C5 pawn and black
doesn't have the moment to push the G
Pawn anymore has to waste the tempo
shouldering white King right there which
gives Yan the momentum to start pushing
the dwn tempo D4 if not for the move
King E5 there was the move King D4 Peter
sare time yeah stop the G Pawn very
impressive game by Yan but also I'm
really surprised by the fact that uh Fab
who at that point I think was also
behind on the clock him not taking the
Perpetual repti in the position where he
had the Perpetual was very very odd to
my eyes because it didn't look like he
was better anymore and his ambition was
too great yeah I think he he didn't need
to go For Broke this like if this were
the last round and he absolutely needed
a win there yes I would understand that
but with what 12 rounds to go I think he
could have he could have much let's take
a look at the pairings for round six
pairings and we've got as always some
great pairings and mvl our tournament
lead leader up against Jeffrey Jeffrey
just won his first game what game do you
like Dan a really important one and
that's what you need when you beat Liam
you've got the confidence to face the
tournament leader Jeffrey starts with
the white pieces but Maxim looking good
with 14 points currently and in second
place Yana pomi with 13 points will take
on Liam in the mix there are two players
just touching the very top which is
alira fuja and Fabby they play against
each other it's tempting I I'd like to
go with the Fabby versus Fuji game just
because there's so many points between
them but mvl and nepo deserve as well
I'll go with Faby fua let's go with this
Mar yeah thank you I need your support
we will keep our eyes on the other
results but it is going to be focus on
Fabiano caruana taking on alira fuja
what are our predictions
Peter fa to come back oh nice all right
that's the thing right uh fua had lost a
game that well with MBL he shouldn't
really have he just won I got to go with
fua cuz it's the streaks right you just
you these are both on paper and also I
think in terms of current form these are
the best maybe two Blitz players in the
tournament Yan probably would be
extremely offended by this character how
dare you yes as he often is but uh but
still and uh Fabi on the wi side I think
is a very dangerous game for for alza
but he's been he's been playing both of
them have been playing really well so
Tanya I got
what do you think about that decision
not to take the Perpetual check by I
think it's the power of hindsight had
things worked out for Fabby we would be
calling that decision very brave and I
think that was the moment when Yan
started putting his King on the dark
squares allowing Fab's Bishop to come in
with checks he did sneak his way up the
port he certainly did the way things
turned out we can feel that Fabby should
have taken it up but I think it was that
moment where you decide you know what I
want to play for more and it could have
gone either way I don't I don't know the
queen and Knight versus queen and Bishop
I just call a time out on that exactly
it's one of those where the common
wisdom of queen queen and Knight being
strong statistics don't really confirm
it all that much but in a Blitz game in
particular on low time you should you
should perhaps just kind of admit that
you were better but you aren't anymore
and it's
time but well none of this hands we've
got the blitz today and tomorrow but the
granddaddy of the mall coming up uh up
the big one the sink field Cup starts on
November 21st right after this event
lots of tour points to be won right big
big players playing on that one it's a
tournament mark your calendars don't
miss it let's take a look at the players
who are fighting it out yes absolutely
uh led by Ali Raza at the very top there
but it's Fabby as the grand chest T
leader Ali RZA comes back to the Grand
chest t as the champion can he defend
his champ a crown and we do have some
wild cards because ding Len is being
replaced and uh lanir and leavon welcome
welcome to you both locals both locals
very strong Town well you know we we we
tried to decide who was champion of
Maryland
Avenue who won it is it still under
dispute the hardly contested hardly cont
cont I mean you know here in St Louis
it's not the question of who's the US
champion it's just the question of who's
the best on the Block and probably the
best on the Block is the US champion
right and it's closed T I got to tell
you lavon's in there as see the players
this is an interesting view of the
playing Hall there are players who like
to be at the board early and just kind
of get the Zen and the focus going there
are other players who get nervous at the
board and they only like to appear when
the bell rings what type of player are
you Tanya usually I'd like to arrive a
couple of minutes before but not too
much not give myself too much time to uh
start taking it easy but just maybe a
few minutes uh a couple of minutes
before the start but it's also
interesting how these players who we see
on our screen Anish Liam and I think it
was Sam earlier currently they're
struggling a little bit in the blitz so
trying to get their focus back and there
we see Fabby walking in he had a tough
loss against Yan a contested decision
about whether he should have continued
that Queen and Bishop versus queen and
knights should he have bailed out at
that moment I think it shows fighting
Spirit it definitly does which leaks for
something and ambition Ali Raza uh
definitely he has uh grounds to growl
and complain that maybe here or there
he's left a point or two but he's
definitely still in the mix and for mvl
he keeps reminding Us by the way mvl who
his boss yeah in BL
why he's one of the very very best in
the world when it comes to Blitz Maxim
Vash lra in po position we will be
focusing on that game between Fabiano
and Ali Rea and let's not forget this
was game number one round number one in
the rapid and Ali Rea made it look easy
against Fabby it's got to be a bit of a
grudge match for Fabby no question about
it and how fortunes have changed we're
about to see also Wesley so versus Ray
Robson that was the last game of the
Rapids Ray was in clear first Ray had
been undefeated Wesley won and it was
good by Ray it has been a good by way
Ray as I think he scored two draws out
of the five games or yes yes it's been
it's been a tough road so far in the
blitz for Ray Robson meanwhile Wesley
has been sneaking his way up with a
couple of winds in the stuning we don't
know what Wesley is going to do in any
given game he hasn't
played his consistent best but when he
does play well he plays great and way we
go we're two nights Joko piano with
Bishop C5 and instantly Bishop G5 by the
way so Fabby has actually
come with a very clear uh opening
preparation for this one uh Tanya and I
want to throw this to Peter Peter with
such little time in between Blitz Games
how much are you really preparing for
the next game I don't think you are I
think you have a certain plan of what
you're going to do in certain games also
Faby I think has been uh he has a blitz
repertoire I think good Blitz players
and I think the first one I've heard
mention a specific Blitz repertoire was
Sasha grishuk who is a three-time world
champion in in this world format and he
would occasionally just prepare
something for one tournament not for one
game for one tournament right I'm going
to play the Kings Indian that just takes
away takes away the decision phase like
you you know you're going to be doing
this in every wi game for instance right
uh and yeah I don't think uh with nine
rounds of Blitz in one day I don't think
anybody actually
is I will stop myself right there there
as we've just seen a peace sacrifice we
know these peace sacrifices exist as
we've seen them played a number of times
night takes G5 H takes G5 and I have to
tell you I have this very strong
Prejudice not to be the one with my
pieces pinned I hate I I I really do I
hate having the pin pieces you Peter you
you you're very familiar with these
sacrifices which side of the board do
you like I I agree with you having
studied these positions a little bit
they often are okayish but they require
incredible Precision from black and much
easier to play from the white side yeah
and also uh if you want to play H6 G5 in
these types of positions you can often
do it with the King back on E8 when
you're which yeah which I think diffuses
the the threat the threat of the
sacrifice a great deal and then once
you've driven the bishop back to G3 you
can Castle King side and people actually
do that quite a lot this is a very very
fashionable line I think Bishop D5 here
is the move I think the way to make sure
that this uh this pin remains uh
forever D5 I don't know if Fab has
anything even stronger in mind he played
Queen F3 no Queen F3 for sure Bishop
E6 Rook F1 very interesting whoa Rook F1
and played quickly enough that I suspect
he might just know this is very strong
yeah I mean he's been playing with s
speed and you go Knight takes Pawn you
pick up two pawns for theit uh for the
piece you go Queen F3 Rook F1 and just
seconds uh Fab is the better prepared
and to me it looks like yes this is the
kind of opening where if you're the
better prepared one you might just get a
really quick point then no question
about it I am familiar with ideas of
Knight V8 Knight D7 in order to to
prepare the queen and I think this is
what he's playing against he wants to
play Queen G3 and then just to follow it
up with F2 F4 as quickly as possible so
Knight B8 Queen G I would look at Queen
G3 yeah Rook h8 played for now and a
good temporizing move by the way because
it does allow if you if you do play
Queen G3 it does allow king f8 sorry
Tanya you wanted to say that this is a
very tematic idea against the peace
sacrifice on G5 you put your king
forward you put your Rook on h8 you're
also not only vacating the f8 square but
very often The Rook slides over to H5 at
the right moment let's say when your
queen is on G3 perhaps it could but the
whole idea is that you start targeting
the bishop on G5 you have to watch out
for Bishop takes F6 check in this
particular position but the Rook belongs
to h8 so I like what Fab's done and now
he goes for the other plan that you're
mentioning of rerouting the Knight to
enforce the defense on the pinned knight
from D7 exactly and if we could make the
legal move F2 F4 we really do understand
why the Rook was brought to F1 and it's
vital for us to play F4 now the question
is how do we get it in if we just move
our Queen
in order to play F4 we are inviting the
king to escape essentially uh so it was
the move Queen G3 that everybody really
likes Queen G3 King f8 again F4 Knight
D7 um well here we go Queen E2 to E2 so
F4 is a big threat that is what it's all
about and is it time to because Knight
D7 F4 and then you could move away with
the
queen yeah he moves away with the queen
instantly immediately Queen
E8 okay so also reminding why that
there's a Pawn on e4 which eventually
might get picked up and maybe the white
king will also start feeling slightly
less safe but it's not on top of
anybody's agenda just here how so Peter
what what A4 A4 is hanging oh pardon me
A4 I heard E4 pardon me you're wow we're
going to give you a gold membership card
into the pawn grubers Association well
done top agent of the day Queen takes A4
and that's great awareness because it's
so easy to forget that pawn we've just
been focusing on the king side so F4 but
do you have time to take on A4 because
here you just have all these ideas of
taking on E5 I'm a little bit worried
about Bishop F6 and takes on e4 but I'm
looking at Knight H7 and that's a very
attractive move if I could take that
Bishop and then take the pawn life would
be very very very pleasant by the way uh
interrupting our commentary on this game
uh our tournament leader mvl Drew with
the black pieces against Jeffrey xong so
Jeffrey continuing his good streak uh
Knight B8 D7 cleared quickly uh again
Knight H7 it was worth investigation he
didn't spend too long on night D7 and
it's a hot potato what do you do with
white what are you doing you've put
you've done
everything properly well he's taken on
E5 we anticipate D takes E5 as a
response a little pause here for why is
he pausing I'm really not sure he must
be seeing something very strong against
D5 because the only other move is KN H7
but you don't particularly want no you
don't do that so and the clock times is
it we we've allowed uh Fab's being well
prepared are we accurate Tanya he's just
a little under 3 minutes at 2:45 and
then we've got fua who's actually got
who's behind by a minute with uh a
minute and 45 seconds and the position
is so tactically sharp and it's so
difficult and he's really taking his
time here to decide about capturing on
E5 I mean if you you can only take it
back with the pawn the Knight needs to
defend the Knight on F6 uh the
alternative is Knight H7 and he decides
to go for it a long time he really spent
a lot of time on that one that was a
surprise I I'm not sure I saw a
reputation to D6 takes E5 Peter I guess
he just feels this is stronger okay he's
picking up a Tempo he's anticipating if
the bishop has to move that maybe he
would like to recapture even with the
knight in that case as his Pawn on F7
would be pretty nice Queen
H5 that jumps in and now you're also
eyeing checks on 86 I would be terrified
with black here it's three pawns is
three pawns and a very exposed King and
takes E5 this is incredibly scary yeah
you have to play King G8 and that there
is no no way for white to give a check
on the G file and yeah ala showing some
very very I'd say nerves of Steel myself
exactly my goodness uh I would not have
invited the bishop to come to H six but
he's saying I can withstand the assault
can he tell you it looks very scary look
at the pieces lined up on the H line
that Rook on h8 Knight on H7 Bishop H6
Queen H5 it's not a position you get to
see every day the H5 is occupied it's
occupied it's fully occupied but the G
file is where the actions at he first
pushes the Knight and I'm guessing the
Knight wo wo uh Knight takes oh there
you're going to get there is a yeah but
we can take on C4 and perhaps play
something like F7 F6 or F7 F5 even but
but we got to show the Checkmate cuz we
don't get that to show very often maybe
just with arrows that your Bishop needs
to guard the G4 square and queen G4
would be game over right and have we
seen Knight C4 yet but we could see
Knight C4 Knight C4 F6 and then the
queen will drop back because Bishop
takes C4 is still not going to be a oh
whoa Rook F3 play instantly by Fab that
was clearly the
intention what about Knight f8 yeah he's
going to play Knight f8 here and he's
done it Knight f8 and and the queen
x-rays the G6 Square so that Rook F3
Rook takes
G3 brilliant or completely Crazy by
Fabby I would have been flagged after
Rook F3 had my opponent not recaptured
and played Rook F3 Knight f8 Tanya what
are you going to do the idea to go
Knight G6 is sticking you can give a
check on G3 but Knight G6 and it looks
like everything is under control and my
Bishop on H6 is pinned as well and Fabby
in a t tank right now I think we missed
it I think he's missed it I think he had
to recapture on C4 cuz currently he's
down two pieces two two pieces and the
big difference is that now if you
capture on C4 black can recapture and
win a win a piece which he couldn't
earlier because Queen G4 G it's gone
wrong there's just no if SS or buts
about it now it has gone wrong for Fabby
and with Knight takes D2 and Knight G6 I
think the tables are firmly on Ali raz's
side of the board knight uh G6 Rook G3
he's looking for tricks now but it's not
over because we still see some ideas
against the black king there there's
definitely potential for cheapos here
I'm just refreshing my board everybody
just wanted to catch up with the players
Rook G3 on the board oh and are down to
15 seconds on the clock yes the one bad
news for for Ali's position is his
Bishop on A7 is really out of the game I
mean he's got two extra
pieces who he sacrifices a thirdd
sacrific the third piece that is three
minor pieces sacrificed by Fab is this a
draw now he can take on G6 twice and
then King F7 probably gets hum and if
you go in the corner Bishop hang on a
second isn't this fine now completely
fine for white not sure that Knight
takes D2 is the right move because the
idea is we take on G6 we oh he just gave
the queen Fab might be better now just
playing whoa completely there goes the
bishop with shck f
has turned the tables completely we're
going to be needing a slow motion recap
of that position at the end of this
round Peter and he res hand shakes it's
all over oh fua just collaps what a
bluff by by but in these Blitz it's uh
about making it work and he did it some
stunning sacrifices we will show that
and go do a deep dive into that position
at the end of the round there's still
action on W liso versus Ray Robson the
the the game that turned the whole
tournament around was the FI final round
of the rapid between these two players
Wesley getting the best of Ray to stop
his streak what do we got Tanya we
have I'm counting pawns that is a five
versus six Pawn so that means it's an
extra Pawn for black a doubl Pawn on the
H file but I'm still choosing black here
are we you got the two Bishops because
the pieces the black pieces look a
little defensive to me did you see what
what yes I did I did almost repeated but
then not 9 seconds versus 14 13
rerouting the bishop to 86 yes to
activate it Bishop to D2 by Wesley it
feels like Wesley is the one playing for
the three seconds for Ray Robson and he
Bishop E7 B Knight to D5 what do you
think Peter is it Wesley for Choice here
or is it just Even
Stevens white is probably a bit better
but the fact that black black pieces are
now becoming a bit more active I
think brings it closer to balance I know
Wesley was a bit this is very clever by
Wesley by the way taking a pair of Rooks
off the board the bishop ending might be
a bit problematic for black even it's
who W there was a moment there should
betray queens and he nearly he did
lose RAR Robson flagged I think that's
the first time
wins
wow what an
end I I am tasered speech last there and
we also see another result coming in
with Yi winning his game against L Wang
Peter I want to say where the action is
but is this a third draw of of the day
maybe fourth but we we don't have very
many of those going have many no they're
R yeah the the game we didn't speak
speak of at all is the game Anish giri
played with with the black pieces
against Sam savian S is not really
having a particularly fun day today this
has been a kind of an old school uh slav
with A4 Bishop F5 and uh they got to a
very interesting and very non-standard
looking position here out of the opening
where uh White has the the two Bishops
but the structure in the center has been
broken up and then uh somewhere here as
you can see some more trades have
happened The Rook on h8 is hanging and
black has to protect it uh and white
wants to play an end game but white
white wants to play play game on on
their terms and Anish says no and
already here it started looking to me
that maybe black is assuming control
because the white king is still in the
center it's not so easy to Castle
because the Rook is open on the H file
and three moves later uh somewhere here
it already look at look at this very
very beautiful shot using the fact that
the queen on the four is potentially
hanging by move 20 Anish assumed more or
less complete control and went on to uh
win this game and Yan pishi ended up
beating Le Liam in a very complicated
grinfield which uh lean played this
bishop B5 line where the main move here
is Knight C6 which leads to uh pretty
much force theoretical draws very often
and actually Anastasia will tell you
about that slightly later in the show
but Yan came to play he played Knight D7
instead a move which is not supposed to
equalize but which keeps uh the game
afloat and they ended up by move 20ish
in this very strange structure where
black has a protected passer on B but
white has the pawn pair oh sorry the
bishop pair and also the Knight on the
Knight on D7 doesn't really have very
many squares uh and it seemed fairly
balanced somewhere like like here I
would maybe even pick the bishop pair
over over the protected passer but
eventually uh White gave up a bishop for
I guess thought he has threats here and
then he must have missed something
because he he's gone for this very nice
tactical shot of Bishop D4 still fine
the idea being that after the capture he
gets to collect a lot of material but
then somehow he didn't find the
Perpetual here I assume I assume the
Perpetual exists these types of
positions generally don't get lost by
the the player playing the white pieces
but something okay yeah now we know what
has gone wrong here now we know what has
gone wrong here Queen F6 yeah King G1
still being a draw there is enough
threats of checks here for black not to
win with B2 but he's gone forward oh my
go allowed K G5 and resign resigned
instantly thank you Peter as another
very very eventful round comes to close
our standings after was that round six
it goes so fast yes it is going into
round seven and there we have it still
at the top of the leaderboard but now
just leading by half a point is Maxim
Basher lra and in second clear second
position is Peter pick
yanomi Fabiano after uh that loss is in
third position after that win he beat
Ali Resa fuja I stand corrected there
and Ali Resa with 12 and a half points
what a turnaround that was oi Ali R
three pieces up losing uh but we're
going to jump to Anastasia in studio to
tell us about the other games Anastasia
over to
you I was actually following the game
between Wesley so and very ofon the one
you you saw at the end and this very
dramatic encounter where Ray lost on
time
um I mean there was a pretty balanced
game but you know these players they're
sharks we have discussed it already we
also spoke about it yesterday with ala
when they see someone is having not a
great tournament they're trying you know
just to get playable position and see
what happens next because if you are out
of shape it's really hard to keep things
under control so this position appeared
also in the same game and I think here
um Ray had a good chance maybe to try
this move D5 and completely crazy
position could happen after cd5 cd5 and
d and D4 so look at it I mean everything
is hanging and it's hard to understand
what what do you need to do but computer
is very optimistic you think that black
is okay here and um it seems so I mean
after some moves like Rook C8 Bishop B2
Bishop G4 um everything is under control
even though it looks completely crazy
after F3 and take on D4 I mean crazy
lines but black is okay everywhere
instead of it uh r played the move C5
and you could could see what happened in
the end I just wanted to mention that in
the position where he lost on time uh
it's still balanced position computer
think it's seal and we can see that it's
it's an ending where Bishop and queen
same amount of Pawns after white will
take on H3 so it was still playable for
a unfortunately he lost this one and the
second game I had my own was uh the game
between Maxim VRA and Jeffrey J uh as
Peter mentioned it was grunfeld and
which eventually finished in a draw
after the line which was happened in the
game it's famous theoretical line um so
I think both players knew it until the
end all the way until move 32 where you
can see that only one Bishop two Bishops
left on the board one day I will learn
all this theoretical lines I will check
all Peter's courses and I will also try
to make draws on this top level but it's
going to be one day and for now it's
time for us to go for the commercial
break as well as you can also check the
chart with with um Lew
[Music]
Liam uh Liam welcome to St Louis chess
club and Grand chess tour it's really
nice to see you here I know that it's
not your first time that you participate
in in those events do you have some
great memories from the previous ones
can you share with us definitely so the
first year I came to America was 2013
and actually that year I was the uh
Reserve player for the SFU cup the first
SFU cup ever and um I always wanted to
play in this events and um first time I
really play in
the in the St Louis rapid and bl was
2017 and then uh in
2021 uh I play another one here so uh
now in 23 I got another chance to play
here so on very excited to come back
here um and play chess it's is the best
place to play chess in America and
probably in the world as well so very uh
excited for that yeah in 2017 you had a
chance to play against even Gary KAS far
you were lucky that you played in the
tournament I think you have even you
even beat him yes in this in that event
yeah I um I lost in the rapid game I
played The Rook very very badly um but
in the BL I think I got one win and one
draw yeah that's great and I know that
you live in St Louis now actually you're
head of the program in Webster
University how is it to how you are
combining your career as a coach and the
professional chess player yeah so um
coincidentally U Webster University
started a chess program uh in 201 uh
2012 so few years before the St Louis
University but um we have been um very
successful in the last 11 years uh Susan
ponga um she was the head coach for n
years and then after she retired I took
over the position I this is my third
year uh coaching the team so I have been
really enjoying doing that um it's
always a pleasure to work with such a
strong team with very talented and
dedicated players and I like to help
them um I want to share my experience
with them and help them become the best
players they can be um as for myself I
still seem myself as a very competitive
player and I like to participate in
strong events uh nowadays I don't get a
lot of time to travel and and play a lot
of tournaments like I used to but um I
always enjoy all the tournaments I want
to play and um for example this one um I
got invite um just a few weeks ago um
but um it's a very pleasant surprise and
of course I I uh didn't uh hesitate to
to accept because it's a very
interesting and challenging uh event to
play yeah um did you have any special
preparation for these few weeks that you
had um so I didn't do really any
specific prep for this uh but more like
General preparation about openings about
skills in general
um as I said I didn't know about this
about my participation in this
tournament until a few weeks ago so I
didn't really prepare too much but I
think listen rapid it will mostly come
down to your farm your uh nerve and uh
it's not too much about
preparation I I've been following your
career actually since the uh the moment
you won a flat open and then you became
the world blit champion in hun Manis if
I'm not mistaken and um I mean do you
think you had enough opportunities in
your chess professional life to play on
the top events I mean how was your life
as a professional chess player during
those years after actually you reached
quite a good success in the Chess World
yeah those are my good years yeah I
remember you were there in uh 2013 yes
yes yes
so yeah I would
say I as a player who grew up in in
Vietnam um I didn't have access to that
many tournaments um
like I wanted to um also at that time 10
20 years ago we didn't have as many
tournaments as we do today so it was a
bit more challenging at that time uh
which is why I moved to America in 2013
uh for more tournaments and and also a
chance to work with uh strong players um
when I came here my teammates at web
University were uh Ray Robson wesle so
uh we have like 10 GM
so um it really helped my chest to move
here and been around um surrounded by
many players that also motivate you to
work harder um I got to play quite a few
tournaments that I like and I did quite
well as well um so I have no regret
about my career um now that I'm not so
young anymore I I don't have that much
Ambitions uh as as I had when I was
young player but I still enjoy it a lot
and all in the tournaments I play I try
to do my best what about this event what
is your like goal in this tournament uh
I don't think I can set a clear goal
like winning a tournament of finishing
second or third I mean I don't think
anyone what will be the good result what
will be the good result for you I'll
just take it game by game my main goal
is just not to blunder uh not to lose
badly
um as long as I feel like I'm learning
from the game I'm learning from my
mistakes and hopefully there are not too
many uh
mistakes um then I would be happy um in
general I mean I'm one of the lowest
rated players in the tournament so uh if
I could finish maybe on the uh upper
half that would be that would be great
yeah all the best of luck for Liam thank
you very
much
the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches its
epic conclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cup and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023 Grand
chest tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess club's twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
1st to find
out hello I'm women's Grand Master V
janova I will be creating content for
Grand store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
premere chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure sure to check
out Q Boutique stl.com for a wide
variety of gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy welcome back everyone three games
remain things are getting more intense
the action is getting crazier let's take
a look at our standings please do the
honors woo I'm
tired I am so tasered by the last result
but let's take a look at our tournament
standings after six rounds of Blitz we
have a clear leader mvl with 142 points
nepo with 14 Fabby with 13 Jump Right In
Ali Rises 12 a half but that three
pieces down that was just crazy round
seven pairings Tanya let's take a look
at the action that's coming up three
games remain for the day and it is Yan
pishi with 14 points taking on a Jeffrey
Jang we've got Ali res are fuja who
suffered a loss against Fabby in the
previous round will be play he's losing
big games he's lost to NBL he just lost
to Fabby his closest rival sorry please
continue it's slipping down but he's got
three games to catch up yes and a big
game for Fabby coming up as he takes on
Anish giri yes which one's going to be
our Mari matchup for this one tough one
I'm going to go with the mvl Wesley so
because again Wesley is capable of
upsetting our tournament leader but B fu
Liam game also has a nice Reserve but
I'm still tasered P Peter you know
cleanse the demons you're three pieces
up will not not three yet so far black
is two pieces up we're talking about the
game that just finished between Fabi
Fabiano corana playing white againsta
fuja and Fabi has made four Quiet Moves
In A Row being two pieces down and
currently his last move is Rook F3 G3
okay and very understandably ala takes
this time to trade some pieces it's what
you're supposed to do as a Defender and
this is a mistake throwing away all the
advantage instead of that he should have
realized how strong of a threat R A F of
six is should have played Rook H7 first
if Rook F6 now he has a very important
Sid stepping move of King h8 and now he
is winning but after Rook H7 perhaps
what he didn't like is allowing white to
bring more pieces into the attack so he
takes on D2 very very understandable
decision Rook F6 comes in and here on
very very low time he panicked and he he
lost in one move but he already has
nothing better than a draw one very
computer's draw is this move Bishop F5
with the intention with the intention of
giving this perpetual and the other one
would be to play King H7 allowing Bishop
of a check another thing that cannot
really be done on 4 seconds so fantastic
semi Bluff I would call it by Fabiano
Carana sacrificing a lot of material to
create problems for ala and uh the round
7 has started but my my board's not
unupdated I don't have any moves yet on
my table I can see that the games have
begun but I can't see the moves on my
board so we're GNA wait for that we rely
upon our camera yes our camera and it
looks like it started as a Spanish
oropez as you say yes and black has
managed to get counterplay on the queen
side very often in these openings it is
about breaking in with B5 B4 and Wesley
has gotten that in I play a little bit
of structures myself with black I would
be happy with Wesley's position oh it's
interesting for me that Wesley declined
the opportunity to clarify the queen
side with the moves B4 takes C3 B takes
C3 it's almost like he's
encouraging um mvl to play the move d4
D5 where I I I do want to take H2
H4 there's been a recent very very
high-profile game which led to got to
this position and H4 was played in that
as well I'm trying to remember who it
was but things are very mixed up in my
in my adult brain by this point and
what's also really mixed up is the fact
to get our head around that Wesley who
had a disastrous start at the rapid has
found himself at 11 and a half points
with still another nine rounds remaining
tomorrow three round open some
opportunities for him doesn't it exactly
been winning a couple of games and now
Maxim vasher lra plays H4 and this this
is Wesley's first big thing so with H4
are you eyeing threats of Knight G5
bringing the queen understand it I truly
don't understand how Knight G5 could be
considered a threat especially with the
D4 Pawn hanging we do at last have this
clarification of the queen side and with
the move Queen A8 to A1 Wesley is saying
by the way there's a tickle I I would
like to capture this Pawn with my queen
queen takes C3 a very unusual way by the
way of striking against the C3 Pawn is
to go to Queen A1 and after D5 uh Wesley
is saying I'm losing a lot of time but
I'm gaining an outpost um Tanya it feels
like the peace activity for black has
got to count for something very often in
these positions black doesn't get this
penetrating Queen into the a file and
the queen lands onto A1 the knight from
A5 also iring squares there The Rook can
join the party from B8 meanwhile we ask
us has white has Maxim really managed to
create anything on the other flank no
not at all I mean again I don't see
where you're going it's a one trick pony
Knight to G5 you're not really
threatening anything by the way C3 C4 is
an indication that Maxine is saying yeah
that pawn is dear to me I do like Pawn I
I liked your suggestion of Rook B8
Bishop A6 Knight C5 all of these moves
make perfect sense to me
uh I like The Outpost Knight C5 best
please the one thing I want to point out
yes I visually love Black's position but
watch out well Max has gone for C5 but I
was also going to say ideas of a rook
lift from E3 and Rook A3 I don't see too
many squares for your queen so always
have that in U mind Maxim uh sorry in
Wesley in this case yes uh Knight B6 a
move very very unex I I would see that
move as uh overly ambitious going for
the C Pawn I really like the Knight on
C5 so he's won a pawn the pawns are
doubled but this Pawn on E5 is a little
bit vulnerable and as you were
mentioning so you know just imagining
that you have to play a move like F7 F6
to defend the pawn on E5 H it's not that
attractive to me that too and also
White's Knight is going to find its way
to F5 uh targeting black side imagine
the queen landing on G4 the Knight
landing on F5 it could be big trouble
yes Wesley has an extra Pawn but I'm
starting to like white play here Wesley
is going to do some repair work here uh
again first thing is this Pawn on E5 is
going to need more protection than the
queen on A1 and he started it I like
that move very much Knight on A5 to C4
first of all the knight's not doing
anything on A5 it does allow for Rook A8
but far more importantly Knight C5 now
as to your knight G3 to Knight F5 yeah I
think I'm going to be obliged to play G6
I do not want to tolerate a knight
sitting on my doorstep and with that not
being a future starts with Bishop B
Bishop to D3 also I queen moving to
either C2 or to E2 attacking the C4
Knight and some discovered ideas with
the bishop and The Rook lined up against
black queen I playing Rook A8 in a
heartbeat here what playing Knight to B2
in a heartbeat here for a trade uh that
was a big surprise for me I I thought he
wanted to play Rook A8 and meet either
Queen C2 or queen A2 with Queen A2 just
defending the knight uh but Knight B2 we
do have a trade is it time for white to
start jumping in with the Knight he
first hits the queen on B2 with Rook E2
but I'm iing Knight E3 jumps now Knight
E3 jumps I think is hoping he will be
able to pick up the pawn on E5 because I
think we successfully disconnect the
queen on the long diagonal from the Pawn
on E5 soonish and yeah Wesley just
soonish became immediate but there is a
PA peski on H4 right Queen
B4 I like this for Wesley I think uh the
PA of Bishops he still has an extra Pawn
even if he doesn't take on H4 after
Knight E5 and just pushes C4 C3 that's
going to be a very very annoying passer
I think he might actually prefer this to
and he's done the pawn grab good point
there Peter uh that pawn on
C3 currently on C4 by the way but the
pawn when it gets to C3 could be an
annoying you could also of course invest
a Tempo in Bishop takes H4 because
because why not thank you thank you
thank you I mean balance has been
restored in the world of comment Pawn
it's a free Pawn you can pick it up but
Wesley go he does go for it yes he
studed the yasa school of Pawn grab the
the Pawn of Hard Knocks we call it uh
Bishop takes H4 Bishop E7 Knight F3
Bishop E7 Knight
E3 um do we like is coming in do we like
um C3 and Bishop or do we want pay
attention to this Knight getting a
square for the bishop exactly by the way
I'm taking a page from the Magnus
Carlson School of Chess Magnus just put
his Bishop on f8 against nepo and every
kind of ruy as imaginable and was qu C1
clever move by the way I'm I'm feeling
it a bit the attack I mean there are
threats and tricks in this position that
Wesley has to be careful about Queen G5
in the air uh do you have time to play
F6 here to try and stop those ideas
Queen G5 Knight H6 how severe is Queen
that's the big question uh coming I mean
I do understand that you have Knight F
H6 as a a potential but I'm looking at
C3 Rook on d8 will be hanging as well
right after Queen G5 okay so C3 Queen G5
Rook D7 do your worst well he has
allowed Queen G5 but in a different way
Yas Wesley chooses to retreat with the
bishop targeting the Knight on F5
instead Queen G5 on the board F6 and
inviting a Perpetual Che gold that's uh
Ben fold police
is never play not touch the FB are we
expecting is is he going to go for 986
97 no I think he feels that he is uh
taking control I think there is plenty
of compensation now something like Queen
F4 and just continue the game Queen F4
Bishop
takes but now you have to go Knight F7
right I don't think so F6 is not really
all that hanging
queen move of the tournament wow hello
hello hello mate in one what is that
position yes Knight E5 works or not that
is a Beauty Rook to D7 and now we can
win the exchange with Knight E F7 check
and then continue on our merry way
somehow I assume that that is just such
a beautiful E5 very very uh picturesque
had he taken the queen that was a checkm
one I didn't like the move Bishop C8 uh
but I must say the move Knight E5 it was
worth it for put on a show exactly for
everyone Knight E5 What a fine by
Max question is do do we Queen F4 yeah
that's my question I think I can take
and play Bishop G7 I have Queen f8 in
the end although yes you do but you
start with Queen takes the other Pawn or
you don't care about that I got we can
take all of them yeah you can take
G7 we do have some stuff and we're
seeing that happen on the board Queen F4
played I I think we're going to see this
line he first picks up the pawn on F6
with a check and yes what you're showing
on the analysis board is about to happen
uh do we have to play Bishop G7 that's
the question Wesley's played it play so
the players have followed our analysis
right up to this moment with Queen takes
C7 now what's the what's the body count
we've got three we got two minor pieces
for Rook but the problem is the Knight
so I have to play Bishop to D4 to
protect the Knight is that your only
problem because I'm looking at the D
Pawn as well which is uh very strong
with the E Pawn he goes for attack I
want to make sure that I keep this Pawn
on the the board though Bishop G4 Wesley
is saying do something with your rook3 R
do a check I've got a check on in my
pocket if you play
F3 this is double-edged what is going on
here Peter this is like rookie three I'm
really unsure I feel like I feel like
you always take E5 is very strong E5
attacking the H7 PA Bishop D4 E5
threatening that was amazing yeah that
really is remarkable and Wesley spotted
it played Knight D7 E5 any giv giving
away his Pawn on
C4 I'm I'm liking my team chances here
this is getting dangerous what's the
clock times it's 4 seconds for Wesley
and he's got to defend a difficult
position unless he finds a way to start
giving this looks like it's it's going
very quickly going and for mvl a victory
would be fantastic I mean for mvl a
victory in this game against E7 coming
in7 is just winning you I think E7 he's
done it and 3 seconds what a game by
Maxim bashra wow Knight E5 that was
picturesque where are we going Tanya it
is Ali roza fua against
Liam and let's get a look let's catch up
some lot of Pawns and it's not white
it's Liam with two extra pawns he should
win this I I mean I don't see uh too
many problems for him here he should
normally yeah yeah is is clock's a
factor at all what what is Al is a
factor in Liam's favor because Ali resa
is playing with 5 Seconds on the clock
while Liam has got those extra critical
seconds to pause and think of a plan of
how to improve his position well so far
he's put his pieces an ideal squares the
King on E5 feels good The Rook h8
someday to try for activity on the other
side I think that's exactly what he's
aspiring for he's I think he's going to
go King F6 to release his Bishop I like
B5 as well to open up open up the the
structure a little bit create additional
options for yourself I I do as well I I
like that by the way uh breaking news
Fabby one Fabby beats Anish giri and Ray
Robson beats Sam savian so more decisive
games we had four decisive
is Liam walking into a knight C3
mate I was about to say Knight E2 to C3
would have been Checkmate but those were
there was yes just in time but you've
got to be careful with knights always
with these checks coming in oh those
tricky Knights Li now also threatening
Rook A3 but look at this Rook B3 check
though I think this this should be
Knight C5 check5 check huge fork and he
sacrificed his Bishop he this might be
the same case as what was that game
where he blundered a piece and one that
was against Fabby right against Fabby
yes this is somewhat similar he didn't
blunder the piece he it was a purposeful
sacrifice but he is winning he's back to
winning Rook D3 oh that was some nice
technique there bishop4 Bishop E4 would
be a cruncher yes he's playing this very
very well and this loss is going to hurt
aliraza fuja very much Rook F3 and you
can't uh avoid you can give a check on G
six but that just puts the Knight
further away from all the action now the
pawn is going to start
pushing I guess is the cleanest yeah
yeah and now you really are in dire C3
completely fine yeah C3
C3 and the King comes to C4 is White's
King going to get checkmated at some
point here I was about to say it sure
does look like it and there it goes uh
wow Ali Raza is actually in a spin sight
and it's a downward spin cycle at that
um Peter where that that was a very quk
if we return to this for a second I just
want to show you the the opening of this
game because this is a very very
well-known uh symmetrical symmetrical
English why is it called the symmetrical
English
because well played sir well played but
when when people were conceiving and
playing like this with white they were
not doing it with the intention of doing
Queen G2 and B3 no they were not and
black as you can see by this point
everybody is so used to this that Queen
D2 is habitually answered to with Queen
D7 B3 B6 Bishop B2 Bishop B7 and alza
continued creating some kind of Mayhem
on the board Knight D4 F3 honestly this
looks kind of ugly it probably isn't
that great no but after Bishop H6 Queen
D1 uh I think cam probably slightly
hurried with a very very natural move
Knight the5 which maybe would have been
winning if not for the fact that Bishop
H3 exists and this position is already
playable for white it's it's a massive
Improvement that we no longer have to
worry about this Knight on D4 but alza
still didn't really play uh play it that
perfectly he played the Knight forward
to G5 and it eventually it got chased
away and as you can see this whole
complex of the white pawns on the King
on the king side is weak and eventually
one by one they started dropping there
were still some Adventures the game was
obviously very long and we saw the the
back end of it Al at some point had
drawing chances but uh the defining
sequence was basically from here uh to
here in in a space of about seven moves
white lost both the G3 and the H4 pawn
and they ended up costing uh costing a
res of the game and uh this one this one
we watched and as for the game between
Yan pishi and Jeffrey Shong uh Yan Juan
eventually a very level end game they
played some kind of a quen Gambit
accepted type position uh and for for
the longest time Jeffrey was playing it
very very correctly this is completely
fine for black and it continued being
completely fine as as you can see the
engine even slightly prefers it for
black continues prefer oops sorry
continues preferring it for black and
then something bad must have happened
yeah already here uh I guess another one
of those good knight versus bad Bishop I
guess trading this Knight for this
bishop shouldn't shouldn't have been uh
shouldn't have been attempted because
white suddenly has this wonderful Knight
on C4 which can no longer be challenged
and then three moves later white has a
Pawn on A7 which is about the queen so
my guess would be was on about 3 seconds
and didn't didn't play the very back end
of this game it seems to me that nepo is
the one keeping Pace with our tournament
leader NBL tell us about the standings
Tanya let's take a look we've had five
decisive games in this round as well and
it looks like Maxim vasher lra who was
tied for a second after the rapid is
running away with day onean he's
consistently kept his lead at the top
with 15 and a half and as you pointed
out Yan see a completely different Yan
in the blitz than the one that we saw in
Rapid in clear second a point ahead of
Fabiano carwan Ali Resa fuja with that
loss against Liam is currently tied for
fourth with Ali Resa fuja and Ray Robson
and we've got Anastasia carich with even
more insights and Analysis with the
action that we just
saw yeah have five decisive games I mean
it was just crazy and I don't know which
game I prefer I kept my eye on two of
them Anish giri played against Fabiano
Karan and another one R opson against
Sam S and I'm telling you both of them
were really crazy it started slowly when
with two nights um defense where Anish
choosed quite modest you know variation
with D3 no KN G5 no nothing crazy but
then he was true to his uh plan he
brought his Knight all the way to F5
like the in the game against um in the
game against Ry Robson so Knight looks
very nice here but the difference is
that black knight also come one day to
F4 and this is what happened later but
before that um Fabby actually got quite
good stable position and he played here
H6 computer doesn't like it so much
because he's probably weakening G6 uh
square but still I mean it was pretty
good position for black I mean nothing
is actually happening no checkmates so
far so had the chance to play also in
the center and this is what he has done
um later on he also pushed like D5 but
before that he moved his Knight on G5
and here was a moment when he could
actually exchange a couple of pieces by
playing like immediately like Bishop F5
very straightforward G takes F5 Bishop
takes C3 and after that just try to get
this Pawn on H5 and if white is trying
to defend it then he has this nice
maneuver with the knight from H3 to F4
and you can see that this bishop is
really out of play while black has this
absolutely great knight so it didn't
happen in the game he didn't play this
way he played like Queen E8 and uh later
on after many many circumstances they
ended up in in the position somewhere
here he managed to push D D5 D4 white
managed to play C5 and um um I mean the
moment when black finally brought his
Knight on the4 was a critical one uh for
for Fabi because he managed to bring
later his Queen on B5 threatening this
weakness on D3 and later he brought all
the pieces um into the king's side you
can see that Knight and queen is
actually dangerous um we know about that
and especially when they tried to attack
the king and this is what happened Anish
couldn't really uh defend this position
anymore I mean Knight G3 is not helping
the situation Queen F3 comes follows and
then just Queen G4 and is a Checkmate so
Anish G resigned here I mean great
victory for Fabby who is coming back
seems in the tournament
and then we go quickly to check the G
the game between Ray Robson and Sam S
such a crazy game I mean the the tables
were turned so many times and it started
all with English opening and um I I
think s play very creatively he pushed
his Pawn all the way to E3 I I would
like to mention the moment when things
started to get crazy after Bishop G2
some crazy tactic appeared like E6 Queen
A7 and then Rook F5 nobody cares about
this the pieces in this game because
after King G2 there were some Knight A2
ideas so Knight A2 comes now and um here
a could have played the move Queen A5
and after Bishop D6 just take on E3
without being afraid with Bishop C5 next
move King G2 so uh instead of it he
played Queen C4 and losing his Advantage
at this moment but I mean everything is
really like falling apart here and Rook
F7 and look what happened here Bishop H3
crazy move you know Queen take it you
know Rook E7 Knight E2 to check King H1
and after Bishop B7 it's crazy I mean
let's try to count the pieces what's
going on it's Queen for uh two pieces
and and Rook so after Queen C7 he made a
crazy mistake Sam here instead of
playing Rook D3 threatening the check
mate on D1 not being afraid of any
checks because he can always come back
instead of it he he thought he played
the same idea Rook f8 but look what
happened after Bishop takes G7 crazy
turn uh and now if black takes on G7 and
that was the best to do here white can
make a draw suddenly can make a draw or
sorry not of course King G8 not not King
h8 King G8 and then there is this draw
with a Perpetual check instead of with
um black took um played differently Rook
f8 Bishop G7 he to he played King G8 and
now again it's was uh Ray Robson who was
winning after that because there is no
Checkmate Bishop takes the Rook after
that so Queen became again strong and he
literally collected all the pieces
absolutely crazy situation um two games
decisive results um I think it's I mean
players are getting a little bit tired
by the end of the day and now it's time
to go back to the studio to yaser T PK
thank you Anastasia that looks like some
real Mayhem craziness was going on there
remind us again of the standings I'm
just uh I'm just kind of like nervous
retion that we saw in NASA said that
players are getting tired but the kind
of chest that we're seeing from easy to
understand why with so many variations
to calculate there we have it MBL clear
first clear first at the top of the
leaderboard and he's been consistently
there some brilliant Moments by Mel
today and then Yana pishi at 15 points
uh Fabby one point behind at 14 and then
there is a big margin the players seem
the top three seem to have Slipped Away
broken away from those TI at for that's
Ali ran Ray Robson with his first win of
the day he was at half out of six a much
needed Point very much so and with round
eight coming up let's just take a look
at the pairings and to decide our
Marquee match up T ladies for Choice
some big matchups at a big moment it is
the penultimate round of the day for the
first half of the Blitz and we've got
Jeffrey Jean playing against Wesley so
so has been sneaking in some WI
playing spoiler to others tournaments
can he continue that streak Sam savian
plays the tournament leader in formed
who looks completely Unstoppable today
Maxim vasher lra Fabby against Robson
Liam plays Anish giri and Neo versus
fucha it's a tough choice yes right
which one's going to be our Focus well
mvl you got to give our tournament
leader some respect right I mean come on
he's been uh he's been uh scoring the
victories nepa's been keeping place but
uh I I I was going to say uh well first
of all more chess after this don't
forget the grand chest store uh the
Marquee uh tournament the
granddaddy that is you're not even
overstating it the big big event of the
chess calendar is coming up starts
November 21st runs through December 1st
clear out your calendar Mark those dates
and it will be the final event that will
decide the eventual winner of the grand
Chester for 2023 and this is our starost
for the singfield cup Ali Resa fuja
Fabby Yana all the Heavy Hitters of the
Chess World joined by the two wild cards
leavon and lanir and Peter do me a solid
show me that visual of mv's 95 that was
just an amazingly beautiful we going to
have it on our screen we got the magic
of Television P we're going to jump that
is the moment of was pretty it was right
here yes okay we got the Knight F7
Perpetual in our pocket all we got to do
is check with the other Knight and take
that photo in take that board position
in that's a stunner of beauty that's a
position for t-shirts exactly belongs on
t-shirts that's your we need a merch of
that knight5 the Knight is hanging the
queen is hanging and another Knight is
hanging absolutely agreed that was great
on that on that note some madeup STS for
you which I I did in my head so they're
probably wrong mvl leading the
tournament on five out of seven today
but Yan pomnish is on six out of seven
today uh and another stat which I'm
pretty sure of because I went round by
round checking 35 game games played so
far how many draws do you think five
five is correct wow five out of 35 great
gu yes go get that lottery ticket today
sharp this is so we can expect a lot of
decisive games fantastic
fantastic fighting Spirit shown by
players and it does feel like they are
getting a bit tired because nobody's
giving an inch everybody seems to be
playing every game to the maximum and
nine game nine games of Blitz in a day
is not easy right when did you see 95 I
I saw it when he played it I saw it when
he played it honestly and it was just
like wow that was a stunner that really
and what is it about these F5 squares we
had the game of the tournament with Ali
Resa fuja sacrificing a queen on F5 and
that we have for me the move of the
tournament Knight E5 Knight F5 and just
uh sorry Knight E5 it was I'm losing my
head it's been a long day yes but I'm
I'm still tasered by The Rook G3 Rook F6
by Fabby versus uh Ali ra he's three
pieces down and he's making Quiet Moves
Peter we're making a lot of core
memories in this really there will be
there will be things which will be stuck
with us for for quite some time it feels
like is it bravery brilliancy
desperation that game by Fabby
sacrificing three pieces taking those
practical decision and he's in the mix
for the top spot who said that was a
good gamble that was a good gamble by
Fabby wasn't it we we did say it after
he won I don't think we were saying it
while the game was in progress I I
honestly didn't think it was such a
great gamble at the time I don't even
think it was a gamble I think it was
Fabby taking a practical decision with
just seconds trying to find a way to
keep the game going and it is difficult
and tricky for black to escape in that
position
with H7 and King h8 what good luck with
that as we are getting uh ready for our
round eight again we're going to say sam
Sean
versus yeah he's kind of feeling did you
say six out of seven six out of seven
I'm pretty sure oh what a streak not I
mean against this field and this guy's
on a streak as well five out of seven
and five and a half he's got reasons to
be very pleased with his chess yeah
today uh leading 15 and a half points
this is the first day of Blitz Sam uh as
Anastasia just showed us Sam could have
easily have won that game against Ray
Robson so I'm just wondering what kind
of shape uh Sam is going to show up I
mean we know that mvl is just feeling so
good about 95 it's not just win but when
you win with Style Style it's the it's
the style points you know you play Move
Like night
and that feels amazing we will uh yaser
of course we'll keep an eye out on the
tournament leader who is playing Sam
savan but our Mary match up I think it's
such an exciting juicy pairing with Yan
nepi taking on Ali Resa F fair fair I'll
I'll you're an influencer and I will be
persuaded by uh your choice but yes NEPA
versus fuja definitely is a game that
we're going to really enjoy nepo once
again tell us why why Peter uh Neo's
been so very successful he's been the
most successful Blitz player thus far I
think outside of world championship
matches he's been the the the most
improved player of recent years I think
it's very possible to make that argument
and he just loves Blitz and rapid and in
particular Blitz and he has always been
very very good at it so none of this is
a shock to me and he's won a bunch of
medals in the world rapid and Blitz
Championship as well and you know I'm
glad we picked this game because we've
got a Kings andion defense on our we
certainly do we we've got a full-fledged
uh battle but wait a minute time out
there I mean it's uh flippant of you to
suggest that nepo might be the best uh
improved Blitzer in the world I'm just
chess player in general just Che but I
mean fua is so young and he's number
one by Blitz rating he's got to be
considered absolutely yeah no I mean
this is a very Stellar field and
nobody's going to take away from from
what ala achieved in uh in quick formats
also in classical but in quick formats
in particular but I think Yan is uh it's
weird to say that about somebody who is
as well established as Yan is but I
think Yan is still somewhat underrated
all right people tend to not take him as
seriously as they should take him
despite all his all his achievement
we're going to pick up the action as
we've just seen the move Queen C2
prepping the move B2 B4 so uh black
stops white from playing B5 he wants to
keep his Knight on C5 Bishop E3 B7 B6
you're invited to take the Knight but
I'll recapture and be very happy I've
got space Tanya white has space and
whose position do you prefer though
white wants to expand on that space with
the idea that you mentioned A3 on the
board uh black stops it fuja goes A4 uh
White wants to try to push on the queen
side as you mentioned with targeting the
pawn and black is eyeing to sacrifice it
and try and get F5 in I think at some
point that needs to move that Knight and
push F5 but he decides not to get greedy
with the pawn I think I think white
actually wasn't winning the pawn in that
line I a knight takes E4 right I think
that was a miscalculation I think Yan
thought this would this would be a pawn
sacrifice but it wasn't there was a
tactical justification for it and now I
think black is just very comfortable
because indeed if that pawn survives
including A3 and A4 is pretty much
always going to be in Black's favor
normally speaking Whit's A3 is not to be
played usually have to play B3 A3 very
slowly get in the move B4 but once black
has achieved A4 this Knight on C5 stays
and by the way the move B2 B4 is a kind
of a statement that
says uh I blew it yes I blew it I just
blew it it does because you want to get
that B4 in by displacing the Knight on
C5 that Knight isn't going anywhere and
now black also has a free hand not only
on the king side to get F5 at a right
point but can start targeting the
weaknesses on the queen side Knight a
for very very good move by uh Ali Raza
and again Ali Raza s sitting there
saying don't forget you do have an E4
Pawn I would like to trade Knights and
take this Pawn Knight B5 now it's time
to move the Knight so we can play F5 I
want to see F5 on the board Knight G4
it's on the board come with a Tempo with
a Tempo and you do you really want to
give your light Squad Bishop with Bishop
takes Knight but if you don't you lose a
very critical moment for black to
actually push the F Pawn exactly uh
usually speaking though the Knight isn't
great on the uh G4 squares what do I
mean by that suppose I play Bishop D2
suppose you play F5 you generally want
to recapture with the pawn right but in
this particular case you do
allow well the E4 is a square by the way
let me just C catch up with the players
for he did decide to not lose the tempo
but lose his light squ Bishop
instead did trade on G4 not a pretty
sight this Knight on C1 where is it
going Knight
D3 Knight B4 Knight C6 it's a long way
it's three moves and by then Black's
going to open up on the king side by the
way big decision F5 because after move
like F3 your Bishop might be wrong
footed on the H5 square but you're also
looking at expanding on the king side
with F4 G5 eventually yes coming in very
quickly F5 big moment here for Yan how
is he going to by the way do not allow
F4 F3 we spoke about that before and he
does F4 I was just about to say this he
asked that maybe he also has the
opportunity to not fall back with the
bishop but go F4 and it looks like a
pawn sacrifice but are you really happy
with taking that Bishop I take on E3
your bishop and my queen is going to
jump in full control of the dark squares
and that looks like a lot of
compensation to me big time uh the
difference here in a normal King's
Indian attack is I might play H3 and
start running towards the center and
saying you know I put my Pawn on H3 I
put my king on F1 by the way he put his
Knight on E2 I'm not a fan I would have
probably put my knight on A2 to go to B4
or to C3 again I'm thinking H3 it's on
the board H played and I'm getting my
king out of Dodge Yana's not doing any
of this he's preparing I think he wants
to smoke out the night on A4 and then he
will play King F1 King E2 because
otherwise I think he gets
yeah it's simply made without without
the light Square Bishop to stop G5 G4 it
just make it much harder to uh to play
you just get completely overrun on the
king side exactly the nice part again of
getting rid of the light squares is it
does allow us to make this King run but
I just don't think there's a choice
anymore this feels like a dream Kings
inan position for black it's all black
it's all black uh but on the other hand
um one nice
thing that white players always enjoy is
if if we ever get into an ending the
bishop on G7 tends to be a passive peace
what Knight C5 on the board and King F1
your idea it had to be played you need
to run out of the house on fire with G4
and many black anyways continues with G4
and the dark Squad Bishop that you were
talking about Bishop F6 Bishop H4 ideas
yeah that's what you want to achieve
whether you get it that's a different
question cuz I I will play King E2 and I
will play Rook H1 by the way Knight B7
what a kg move is he aspiring for Knight
A5 he does it and that's what he's done
the Knight was looking pretty on C5 but
Ali Rea has probably thought that the
bishop might capture the Knight so he's
put his Knight on A5
Peter and we're getting another update
our first result of round eight Le Wang
Lam takes down Anish giri
uh by the way not for nothing but again
I wouldn't have snuck in the move A4 I
would have snuck in King E2 and King D3
I think the King on D3 protects the pawn
on C4 nicely I've heard of King as a
piece in the end game here you wanted to
just March up start uh taking part in
the battle quite early on in the day a
good General leads his army into battle
Tanya the King on D3 would have been
superb by the way Bishop F6 example
there we might be seeing King E2 King D3
so Bishop F6 this was the idea that we
were looking at trying to get that
Bishop to H4 but you won't be in time
because of the prophylactic that you
mentioned Yas The Rook sliding on to H1
after a trade on G4 now imagine that the
the queen was on C2 the king would been
on D3 by now right and the queen in that
case has kind of got a free hand and you
can figure out where you want to go uh
Rook G7 I must say I admire
how I want to say patiently uh fua has
played this position he's playing for G4
he's not I would have said it was time
already but he is giving giving Yan some
more time to perhaps consolidate I
thought it was already perfectly
perfectly good enough to to to play G5
G4 yeah it feels as if black has put all
the pieces on the right square and we
were talking about a king's inion which
is a dream version of it Ali razza gets
it he's going to go G4 at some point he
has to he's done maximum maximized his
position he still Waits Bishop to G6
sometimes you wait too long and don't be
surprised if you see a G2
G4 uh from White especially uh with Rook
G1 is a Prelude to playing that move
King H7 he's really delaying keeping us
on tender hooks it feels as if it's the
execution and a Blitz game is stronger
the threat is stronger than an execution
but it is time to go for the execution
in this case uh Yas this is actually a
bit of a problem now for Yan because he
put his pieces in such positions that A4
is hanging and you can't stop Knight C5
for the tempo
awkwardly so he just gives up on A2
sacrifice yes that will actually give
him something to do surprisingly if if
black takes on A4 that opens the a file
for white so Rook takes A4 Knight to B4
Knight to C6 trade Rooks give me the
open a file and you're right I mean it
looked like Yan kind of wrong footed
himself but right footed it after all
and no harm no how and it's really
interesting how all of Black's Army are
directed towards the king's side while
white towards the queen side and yeah uh
it feels like two different games going
on in opposite flanks exactly uh you do
whatever you want to do I'll do whatever
I want to do and now by the way no G4
anymore m still shuffling around but uh
just a lot of shuffling one gets the
feeling that fuja has missed that
opportunity to break with G4 by the way
just to interrupt ourselves uh Sam lost
to mvl our tournament leader and mvl
it's lights on he is in god mode today
unbelievable chess don't thinking about
95 wow yeah and are the clocks a factory
I mean all of this toing and throwing of
course they are all the pieces on the
board seven pawns on the board still a
break to arise but the big question is
is there a break anymore because black
cannot get G4 in is he looking at C6
perhaps trying to Target the King on the
queen side now yeah I think
that's that's the only uh break
remaining and white recognizing that uh
C7 C6 there's potential for it uh has uh
prepped for the opening of the defa go
ahead play C6 please allow me to take
and uh press you on on D6 and here it
comes the board had to happen someday
the break has arrived Peter you
mentioned it the players are playing
incredibly ambitiously I mean fuer could
have just kept the position and probably
it would have been a draw he's trading
though he's training both Yan and MV in
particular he this is a game where
points count double so to speak it's
against somebody he knows he will be
competing against for the win in the
tour so very understandable decision but
it is now I think a three result game
because you see the six Pawn being uh
attacked yes the King on C2 looks very
vulnerable but you still have to prove
you have any kind of a serious pressure
against it and this is a position you
can definitely imagine losing control of
as he absolutely and by the way Bishop
F7 Knight D5 the Knight this is the
first time I the pawn has been
picked coming check are you kidding me
does this work Peter this very beautiful
a be well I think I take with the Knight
and then after Rook Rook C4 I take with
the queen and there we seei he's paused
but he's only got 15 seconds to figure
it out and he he will go Queen takes C4
after Rook cook takes Knight Rook takes
C4 he will take with the he will take
with the queen C4 because Rook takes C4
would allow Queen takes A4 check
so also realizes that because otherwise
he wouldn't have been pausing here
he but now we can take with the rook and
go King C three this might not be
correct at all so Rook takes rook and
now if you you if he wants to play Queen
B5 because there is a pin okay y goes go
you take the queen you take the pawn on
B5 no this is an improvement for black
because now Queen e to check is an
additional threat but we can play Maybe
Rook C7 anyway wow things are happening
so quickly here so Queen E2 you still
have Rook
D2 yes and then he a che4 yasa the king
comes back because you have to keep it
connected to the white Rook gotcha
but wait a minute there is a bishop
hanging so check I can't play King C2
but I can run the other way and look at
that gives up the bishop for the Knight
to start with and then gives a check oh
but but he loses the bishop he had to go
King to D2 yes of course he blundered
King D2 was Queen F1 was pretty strong
though it it wouldn't possibly wouldn't
have saved him okay we're going to go to
the game uh and we'll just two connect P
SPS Ray Ray with whoa whoa whoa with 5
Seconds and is he going to repeat I
think he's going to repeat and that's it
handshakes but that had to be better for
REO yeah you look at those bonds two two
scores from promotion and uh once again
one draw one draw in this uh round eight
four decisive games where was the action
Peter everywhere absolutely everywhere
so we watched Yan lose to to Al a
fantastic very interesting game if you
don't mind just the final position
because it just happened it happened so
fast he resigned before we realize what
happened yeah if you play kingu here you
do preserve the bishop but you lose the
entirety of your king side probably
after queen queen G2 the black king is
not very safe so in pract like in a
Blitz game this is still something that
can go wrong but generally speaking this
has to be winning as you can as you can
see from the evalation and actually I
think I was correct about being able to
take with the Rook here the engine does
suggest that you are not getting mated
here I think he got spooked by Queen A5
check and after King B2 Rook B8 check
but that actually he probably just
didn't realize he has Knight B6 because
I know I didn't I didn't oh my gosh The
Rook on C4 I I think I think if you
don't have Knight B6 here you probably
lose okay but Knight B6 preserves the
equality and the line we were talking
about earlier and the reason ala paused
here and didn't take is precisely
because of Queen take C4 and the engine
kind of laughing at us says if you want
to get the position you got in the game
this is the move or you were trying you
you should have been getting it was more
correct it was more correct to do it
this way and otherwise if you if you
take on C4 and allow white Rook C4 Rook
C7 as you can see this is already very
playable for white and elsewhere Maximo
gra won a very uh typical grinfield end
game which I personally never
particularly like with black these types
of end games in particular when you have
to play A7 A6 early these end games
there are some very very sharp
variations starting with H4 here which
are supposed to be a forest draw but you
have to be very very precise and also
you can play quietly uh how Sam has
played here and these types of positions
they are fine for black but I think
they're much more enjoyable from the
white side at least to begin with but
then things uh worked out for uh mvl
eventually after the very typical
Shuffle where it seems like white puts
his entire Army on the fourth Rank and
tries to push but Black's position is
incredibly solid eventually the B7 and
A2 pawns were traded this is still fine
but then starting from somewhere like
here uh Sam made a number of very uh
indifferent moves I would say and if you
look at this position and then you look
at this position it's pretty clear that
black made a lot of progress it's still
not that bad but then came this really
really bad blunder egregious with a very
picturesque very picturesque mate on the
F4 Square here and once this happened
there was no coming back and our one
draw of the day was the game between not
not of the day but of the round was the
game between Fabiano Coran and Ray
Robson where Fabi actually took a leaf
out of alir resa's book and went for
this bis slavski with colors reversed
and against ala everybody's been playing
Knight B6 here but Ray Robson thought no
let's play a different structure and
when for this line and there was a very
interesting tactical Skirmish somewhere
around move
20 where there's as you can see there's
this fight in the center and uh Ray was
offering this Pawn on B4 just to get
full control over the D4 Square Fabby
instead play D3 D4 said no I would like
to fight for it and after B takes C3
Bishop
A3 Ray had the option of Tak taking e
takes D4 which seems like it's very very
strong if you imagine white taking on D6
black taking on D6 black is just winning
but the pro obviously what he was
worried about is the move Queen takes C6
and Bishop takes E7 where white is a
piece up but but but honestly in a Blitz
game I'm probably taking black here
there's some music to face on and the
engine is also suggest this is
completely playable instead of which uh
Ray went Knight takes D4 and they uh
ended up playing this position uh which
is frankly unrecognizable from the end
game we we saw on our screens at the end
this should be completely rre for white
right uh you don't often win a position
like this but you should never be in the
risk of losing it but I guess I guess
Fab pressed really really hard and
eventually the structure got changed as
you see the pawn on e4 somehow
disappeared and now there's a trade on
D4 and black has two connected passers
but it seems like it never really left
the the equality margins so that was
that game was drawn so the final
position as well is equal because we
felt our was like come on you know like
wow you know two connected past bonds
and as you as you can see it it looks
very pretty but it's not actually
winning very very nice uh after after
eight rounds of Blitz that have kept is
on the edge of their seats tell us the
standings Tanya truly yes it's been such
a such a fun entertaining day of Blitz
and no surprises there Maxim VRA still
at the top of the lat but this time
going into the final round he's got a
mammoth lead at the end of today Maxim
vagra regardless of the L game result
will still be leader because he's got 16
and a half points nepo could not keep
Pace with the white pieces he lost to
Ali Raza and a point and a half
difference and a half so we have first
second third fourth and fifth the
players are really thinning out as we
jump to Anastasia for another look at
the penultimate round Anastasia what
caught your
eye I have my eye on the game between
leang and danish gir and actually I
heard during the broadcast that anir has
already finished he lost the game so
what happened I thought and because it
was actually developing quite fine I
mean everybody was choosing his own
plans and in this quite mod variation uh
of car's defense and um so what what
happened was actually something
completely crazy at this moment Anish
just simply played the move Knight C5
look at it and just simply blundered The
Rook in this position so after Queen C8
he he just resigned because he is just
Rook down this is very very painful loss
for anent I mean it's really hard to
imagine what he feels now um because the
game itself was I mean really normal
normal one he managed to solve all
troubles in the open and even I think
had some um possibilities to play for um
trying to get some age after the move
King F1 I mean he he doesn't need really
to go for castling maybe he could have
tried to keep his Queen in the in the
center and keep this Rook on h f for the
moment and the position even visually
looks quite interesting for black and
with a good perspective um so it was a
really really painful loss for him and
the second game I was checking was the
game between Jeffrey J and Wesley saw
um again very interesting battle between
uh two players theoretical battle B
basically it seems like both of them
knew the lands quite well and then I
mean after many many moves they ended up
in this ending let me show you um many
many exchanges have been made and here
D6 you can see that the pawn structure
of white is not so great but white got
this D6 pass bone and um of course he
defended it after Bishop A3 um computer
is very optimistic he thinks that it's a
drawish ending but look what Wesley how
great he played here first of all he
played of course H5 making sure that you
know it's temp it's tempting to play
Move Like Knight D5 trying to prevent
Rook C7 but after D7 you just resign of
course so he played first H5 making sure
that eighth rank is is is okay is under
control so white seemed like did
everything correctly like Jeffrey just
brought his King to the center and
things seemed to be okay but black
prevented all the ideas of white he
played A6 move making sure that the king
doesn't go to B5 and um after King D3
which maybe was not so good move King B3
maybe it was better to keep the king in
on the Queen's side after that black
slowly slowly um brought all the pieces
King to D7 then The Rook to G8 to
protect in after Rook G1 the G7 pawn and
I mean Wesley really slowly organized
his pass paone as well and slowly slowly
he managed even to win this ending in
the end he he moved to The Rook he
converted the position Into The Rook
ending and where he was better he
managed to organize two pass PS later on
and won uh won the game precisely after
that so very interesting turn of events
I mean I think Jeffrey drun thought that
position was really good for him but
Wesley found really nice plans and
managed to convert his Advantage later
so now it's time to go go back to you
guys it's I think we're approaching the
end of the
day amazing conversion there I would not
have believed that white would lose that
the players have been fighting
incredibly hard what have they been
fighting for Tanya for Glory yes for
Glory for Glory but also a lot of money
and those very important Grand chest St
points talk to me more about the grand
chest tour points and I think that's
what's on their mind as well yes because
yes we see the top play for the St Louis
rapid and bits goes back with $40,000
but on the right we see that you also
earn Grand Chester points if you finish
a clear first you get 13 points for a
second place Victory there's 10 points
and these matter a lot in our
grandchester standings so let's take a
look I'm mvl I'm in clear first I'm
looking at those 13 points and say what
are you going to do for me let's take a
look at the standings let's take a look
at our grand chest store standings
currently while Fabiano Carana is at 20
GCT points and we see there tied for six
Maxim vasher lra eight points behind him
and Ali Resa fua almost there as well
with 15.8 there so almost 16 points for
ala fuja and both these players Maxim
and alira are in the mix right now they
have the ability to pick up a lot of GCT
points with this event so I'm mvl I got
12 I win I get 13 I'm at 25 I'm I'm
hoping fabbi doesn't do so well but
fabbi is doing well is my problem he's
doing well and you know what if you're
MBL and you're hoping Fabby isn't doing
well you better do well in your last
round of the day because Maxim VRA plays
Fabiano Karana in the final round nine
of day one of Blitz get out did I set
you up for that that's crazy okay wow P
what what nothing nothing to add very
very consequential game there it feels
like if tomorrow goes sort of like today
the the Gap will be closed to a degree
but Fabby should still be leading prior
to the beginning of the field cup yeah
especially if he can stay in that second
third uh position T but it's very
important for the others to get
closer even if they don't end up
overtaking him by the end of St Louis
rapid and Blitz they've got a big one
coming up the big sink field cup well as
you saw on that grand chest tour
standings but first let's take a look at
the pairings for this our ninth and
final round of the day Tanya take it
away and it's a script you could not
have written as we see Maxim VRA will
take on Fabiano Karana the tour leader
he Maxim starts with the white pieces
another big game for our grand chest
standings for ala fua also the JP points
so important he plays against Jeffrey
Jeong nepo with the black pieces against
anary he's got 15 points he's saying to
himself will somebody please stop mvl
and for I'm going to say my pick fua
it's he's been losing games but the
problem is he's been losing crucial
games against his Rivals nvl and nepo
those and Fabby those games really
really do hurt ouch as we are going to
have as a Mary matchup the MV versus
fobby we've got to it's an easy pick
this one yes NEPA will be our Reserve
it's between the tournament leader and
the tour leader prediction times Peter
mvl versus Fabby what happens I'm going
to take mvl I think he's on a rooll I
think with white he's incredibly
dangerous and both of them are playing
really well but I think I'm going to go
with a Frenchman I'm going to go with a
draw if I am the Frenchman mvl and I'm
just thinking like look let me just
secure I you know it's funny sometimes
you want to push your luck when
everything's going uh when everything's
going your way Tanya you sometimes you
just want to push your luck but there's
something about securing a really good
day where everything you don't want to
have a Ray Robson where you lose the
last game of the day I completely agree
with you on that yes it's been a
fantastic day for
maxim day of Fighting Chess for all
chess fans and look at that we've had 34
out of a possible 40 games ending
decisively you know I have cried during
singfield cups when I've seen 18% of the
games being dra got to love Blitz you
got to love Blitz you got to love Rapids
and that's what makes these events so uh
nice especially with the four wild cards
you you you you can't just sit back and
draw against your competitors and then
just beat up on the wild cards cuz the
Wild Card players are not there to be
beaten up on they're ready to take some
scalps and they have been bringing on
some wild action especially in the rapid
with Ray Robson taking it but it has
been a tough day one for Ray Robson in
the blitz uh and what we were talking
about earlier Maxim vasher lra he would
want to end the day in a good note you
know you've had a fantastic performance
against spoil it he starts with white
pieces but I don't think he'll be too
disappointed uh with a draw in this and
that's and that was what I was thinking
too I mean imagining that Fabby for
whatever reasons plays something like a
Berlin I would choose one of those lines
that are just very very dry and just uh
shuts it down as we see Anish the it's
not it's not the hoodie it's not the
white hoodie it's a black hoodie it's a
yes it's not the white hoodie of the
first uh couple of days of the rapid he
switched it up with the hoodie and we
saw him there with his eyes shut fatigue
has to be effective oh no question about
it no question about it uh after eight
rounds of Blitz just calling the action
has been I mean do we get Hazard pay
talk to my
ENT it's been entertaining chess and one
of the players who's been bringing on
the entertainment is Ali Resa fui well
just mixing it up with that whole Knight
takes C4 stuff Peter and what he did
against Wesley with Queen takes F5 Alli
RIS has got a sharp tactical eye doesn't
he not a surprise we we've always known
that but to be able to still show it
eight eight games into a very very busy
day playing the best in the world is
mighty impressive very very much so as
he's getting ready to face Jeffrey again
our Marquee matchup is our tournament
leader mvl as he has played clinically
good Blitz and he's up against Fabby how
is fabby's score in the blitz I mean
he's done well
but why he's currently in third place
how many points I can tell you if you
can tell me how many points he's got
we'll take a look at the
standings
maybe we will get a confirmation on that
but this is our Clash of what did you
finish in
the and there we have it here we're
going to see it okay so he finished the
rapid with 10 so 5 and a half out of
eight today 5 and a half out of was
quick no no he was on 10 right four and
a half out of eight four and a half out
of each that's and and the same for ala
actually which is because ala was on
nine so those are not great days they're
good days of bles but not great days
plus one for by their standards that's
not a good score it still keeps them in
the mix of things here and for Fabby I
think this mocky matchup The Clash of
the Titans Fabby against Maxim Fabby
with the black pieces and is it going to
be a Berlin it is not a Berlin Fab will
be an archangel Bishop c will he finally
play his opening and he doesn't come on
Fabby what's going on here I want my
money
back and we have technical DQ no a CH
yeah that's a that's a classical chor
wow very interesting Turning Point here
because you can play D5 here and close
everything down forever you can play
Knight D2 and allow some more fun lines
for me I used to play the choran with
black and I gave up precisely because D5
exists but yeah mvl allows for more life
yeah I think as as black you prefer this
because it's not that you're immediately
equal here but there's more scope for
you to have counterplay later down the
Peter help me up but after the move
Knight B3
my understanding is the theory goes
endlessly it's like Knight B3 nobody
really looks at this anymore this used
to be incredibly popular in I would say
maybe the 80s and by the time I I
started looking at this as a potential
way to play with black nobody really
knew anything anymore including myself
of course I think it was hilarious it
was a new and chess magazine where
Vladimir kramnick was annotating a game
and he was like four pages of analysis
of these beautiful moves of I think this
variation and finally on the fifth page
of analysis he says so uh my
novelty it was like what all the
previous moves have been played by many
other players so the theory is very very
deep Dan jump in yeah I'm just amazed at
looking at the speed with which Fabby
has been playing the entire opening and
it feels like both players know exactly
what they're doing the plans in the the
position uh and I don't play the Trier
in with black but clearly Fabby he's
managed to create an expansion on the
queen side B4 always in the air he
brings the Rook to E8 first where is
White's play how does this continue does
black ever want to get in B4 in these
positions in some positions but it it
also gives white additional additional
squares for the pieces for instance the
piece on uh any piece on C4 would be a
good Square for it so uh black generally
tries to to wait with it as for white
trading in playing Bishop C5 is very
typical uh just trying to trade those
those two Bishops off leave the position
uh with the bishop on D3 against the
bishop on D7 which is quite awkward for
black I have a feeling I've seen this
before and B5 before is playable here
for instance wow that's 24 moves and
you're saying this has been played
before I have a feeling I've seen this
position before but I I will not be uh
you know committing to the statement
very strongly uh 5 hours into the
broadcast
choran uh variation that the choran
defense in the ruy Lopez it's been
around well since uh Michael Mel choran
himself from the 1800s uh why has it
fallen out of fashion Peter I think
specifically because other things are
more Dynamic and I want to return as to
uh that option that mvl has passed by on
move 12 there is a way to close
everything down D4 D5 and then black is
not really all that much worse but the
the character of the positions you get
there I think attracts very few people
these days gotcha Knight F3 on the board
uh asking some questions what are you
going to do about the E5 Pawn what if
you go Bishop f8 then b c Bop for sure
and then I kind of feel I've got a
nibble uh in terms of an advantage is
what I mean to say Tanya you have to
defend the E5 bar I can't imagine a
scenario where you try to give it up I
mean I see The Rook on E8 but and he
does go for the idea of Queen B8 I kind
of thought there might have been a
counter
attack I don't know what's going to what
was going to happen but Queen I like it
also because you just keep everything
defended and perhaps after Bishop C5 you
have the option to draw back with the
bishop and not really trade the dark
Squad you mean Bishop to d8 in this case
not a happy square but Bishop d8 Bishop
A5 try and get B4 in but we're getting
so many moves in so quickly Bishop C5
Bishop takes C5 and you mentioned Peter
the C4 Square uh that that looks like a
magnetic Square for the bishop pardon
these types of positions are generally
just quite unpleasant for black the they
you often hold them it's not that you're
already in tremendous amounts of trouble
but this kind of symmetry with the pawn
on A3 against the pawn on A4 and the
pawn on A4 against the pawn on E5 why
generally us the side that attacks those
potential problem point points so Bishop
C4 or queen E3 first maybe is also
something to consider but I like the
bishop on C4 very very much me too I
people who play Joko posos do so for a
reason they like the bishop facing that
pawn on I think the only reason it
hasn't been played yet immediately is
after the trade on A3 and queen D6 The
Rook has no squares so you have to start
calculating because Queen E3 yeah and
then Rook C8 and maybe you will have to
trade some pieces you don't want to
trade and we do see a trade on B4 right
away that's a bit surprised
makes defense a lot easier presenting
with a Target on B2 is generally Yeahs
like has play in this position A5 maybe
Queen the queen on B8 was defending E5
no longer Rook A5 seems A5 looks decent
yes looks like maybe the the worst is
behind Fabby here and also I wanted to
say that maybe Fabi is teasing us with
the future courses cuz he's played about
five different R yeah I he feels very
undecided in this maybe he is trying to
gauge the the the audience reaction to
all the all of this uh sublines of the
Spanish yeah I just wanted to point out
that if white was to put put the Rook
from uh C1 to C4 black intends on giving
up the queen for two Rooks with Queen C5
Rook C5 and then takes on C5 so instead
he does trade on A5 and at some point is
black thinking about Bishop C4 on the
board I was thinking push the A3 a pawn
forward and just completely demolish
everything on the queen side and four
versus four clean it out clean clean it
out and it's very BC thank you very much
yep it feels very very balanced now
again I said coming into this round that
if I'm in mv's shoes I don't mind a
quiet draw where I kind of pressed a
little because I've had such a marvelous
day at the office I don't want to spoil
it and the dayice is is about to be
improved by events elsewhere because Yan
pom's completely lost against Anish giri
oh that'sit that out but right now let's
it's also on about 2 and a half minutes
for both these players so he doesn't
really dilute the queen side but keeps
the pressure on the B Pawn so in certain
positions Rook will come into play to B8
but he chooses to square C8 a pin on the
bishop Knight D3 attacking the queen I
was about to say now that we've created
a weakness for ourselves I'm honestly
I'm not in love with what mvl is doing I
I didn't like it either I thought that
he was going to play Queen D2 trade
Queens uh nice handshake thank you for
the day have a good uh should still be
okay but yeah allowing Queen D4 for
instance would have been difficult and
he plays Queen E3 I think I about to say
yeah just not to allow the black queen
to show up on the D4 Square Queen E3
start to finish for me this game has
been Fabby being ambitious he did not
choose the Berlin he went for the cherin
took on D4 quickly played the first few
moves with complete understanding and
speed and he's managed to create counter
play a complete understanding and speed
you ask you you set the magic work what
is the clock times it is under 2 minutes
for Fabby now and about 2 and a half
minutes for maxim V there we see it on
our screens well that's a nice 3
45 second difference that could
become important as oh we just saw the
move Bishop E6 and offers a trade okay
so how does does that work out trades
everything and now we're going into a
queen and a knight middle game with the
E4 Pawn under attack currently I was
about to say that uh there was a option
of Queen takes D3 but there was a check
I beg your pardon F7 would have been
hanging in that case so Queen and Knight
versus queen and Knight E4 um is this
too even uh should be very level yeah if
I guess currently the White Knight is
slightly better position because knight6
has very few squares who what's this
what what that's he wants to trade he
wants to trade E4 for A4 and claim that
he's slightly better there that's too
clever by far I mean queen
C2 this would always be a very difficult
decision for me on the board do you
defend A4 or do you trade the pawn and
give white this pass on the queen side
and there's no comfortable way to defend
it so I think we take on e4 and we go
for those positions they don't scary
yeah and the B Pawn is not so scary and
he's done
it by the way uh nepo went down as we
mentioned before after six out of seven
he loses the last oh this is always the
most painful game that's what I was
talking about you know you had a great
day at the office don't spoil your day
make a make a draw to just go home
feeling good about yourself Queen takes
A4 Knight takes E4 this is getting a bit
double-edged I feel you know material
equal very less pieces on the board but
with the be on alive I like that
centralization w w wo wo wo there's a
King H7 Knight takes E5 uh you could
take on D1 you could give Queen D1 and
take on F2 what's happening after all F7
is hanging Queen D1 take on F2 but I
take on F7 so we're looking at a
position after Knight takes E5 I was
trying to calculate that un fail check
by the way if Maxine wants to draw is
there a Perpetual after Queen E5 I see
Queen E5 and queen F5 Queen C8 easy draw
is that a draw yes it is oh he goes for
it yes I don't know but 95 may be more
ambitious but he goes and this is going
to end in a draw exciting game but the
result you predicted I thought I felt it
all the way it's just the professional
thing to do when you've played really an
outstanding uh first round of Blitz
Peter what's the action where is the
action where should I go the Liam is was
much better now is somewhat better
against Ray Robson yeah ala is going to
be pushing I think that's the one we
should be yes for our as well and who is
Ali Raza playing I'm sorry Jeffrey Jan
Jeffrey Jan okay he is clearly a little
bit better because his Bishop is more
active in the black king once again uh
having played F7 F6 black is never going
to be very happy with with his King
position but this should be manageable
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm seeing Queen H6
in this he's invting Queen H6 completely
ignoring the threat of Queen H6 on the
board this is terrifying for black and
now he's in trouble because also a is
hanging so yeah now he he's lost at
least the H7 Pawn now after Rook B6 and
queen H7 this is going to be very very
difficult to defend that's a pawn I'm
very eager we start by playing A3 hang
on we probably need to worry about
Bishop C5 I want to say that I want to
start with A4 but I guess we centralize
the queen first and he gave one check
and then your idea of A4 on the board
trying to create a weakness on the queen
side for the light Squad Bishop to get
do exactly and he wants queen D5 check
as well Bishop C5 ideas of Bishop C5 can
be be met with Queen D5 check and I can
protect my Pawn on F2 as he's as we're
watching from the D2 square a nice
Square the queen uh stays centralized
but also defends the king and also
threatening taking on B5 Queen E2 check
ideas at some point exactly picking up
the Queens side pawns and here we go we
do have ab ab strictly speaking this is
a draw of course but in Practical terms
this is very very difficult w h on
bled his F2 Pawn for nothing and Jeffrey
pre moved Queen D6 take Bishop after
coming in with a check no he wanted to
trade Queen so he had actually he
literally had premm moved his he had
made his move in advance and now
allowing Queen d8 would not have been my
decision because well have we lost
because Bishop B7 Queen
h8s flag he's flagged he flag that's a
very dramatic end to this game oh but
what you were about to show oh first of
all let's go to Ray Robson and Liam and
this is our four Rook ending an extra
Pawn for Liam yeah but it will be
difficult to convert because White's
position is pretty solid you take with
the H Pawn Yeah the these are once again
uh definitely holdable uh in theory but
in practice still still has still tested
with on the clock oh absolutely no
question absolutely that's not going to
be an easy one by the way it's just it
just amazes me how quickly with just 3
seconds on the clock the players uh
have precalculated if you will the
defensive setup they want with their
pawns their fortresses
and start chasing I would have played
the five earlier as well I thought the
five6 whoa whoa whoa whoa King F6 what
was probably winning to be honest I'm
very surprised more time was not spent
on this but wo wo wo yeah and this is
probably also very close to winning if
not just winning out try what's E well
this is it has to be winning now we've
got two connected strong the king the H
Pawn is about to start pushing forward
so black wants to go Rook H1 G2 correct
yeah Rook E5 give me the pawn oh my God
he made that move with one second king
G7 now wins oh no Rook E8 exists King G7
Rook E8 putting pressure on E six and
then King and then Rook h8 you just keep
defending and now you go forward with
your king but the D Pawn starts pushing
yeah now I think we start creating our
own pass I I wouldn't have made this
move I would have started pushing G5 E4
agreed do you bring the king to E3
closer to the pawns if there was oh he's
got to take he's got to press the oh 3
seconds gives a check this might be
getting getting away uh from from Liam
yeah I think he had whoa King F6 Rook H6
you're still good you're still good yeah
we we SW we swing it over to D6 now that
we have the Rook potentially behind
swing it over to D6 so Rook h8 no he's
still flirting with the trying to win a
Tempo here and there interesting I
thought King D6 King E5 but he he wants
to keep the King on E7 Ah that's the
point no D there's no rook d8 and you
can even come back to E7 but that
doesn't give you progress he goes
forward but now you've got Rook d8
now we got check check and then King
putting your King on a very awkward
Square not ideal I don't know if I like
that check but it it all comes to the
same yeah King E4 and it probably is a
draw but white is still of course the
side it's a race it's a r and you have
to be sure but you have to play h8 there
is no choice and your Rook comes back
but looks like the king is very
close to beook takes
D2 what a dramatic game and that's it
King versus King but I'm still thinking
about the Ala win against
Jeffrey wa what was that at the end
Peter take it away that a great skure
that Ali Raza had on the h8 Square
against many many exciting moments in
this round and Wesley actually I don't
know where to go our our game if you
don't mind Ali Rea just that last moment
there where just so uh to to to talk
about this game ala went for for this
really really kind of risky risk-taking
approach by okay siing the center
completely to black as you can see the
engine kind of dislikes it and will
dislike it even more further down the
line alza just ignoring the queen side
for now creating this idea of Bishop
takes H7 the engine says King h8
recreating the idea of Knight D4 with
this fork and Bishop H7 F5 is just not
good would give black a massive
Advantage after G6 Bishop C4 it said
Knight A5 would have given black a
pretty serious Advantage but then things
normalized and as you can see by this
point the engine prefers white a little
bit okay then ala found this nice tactic
of pushing D3 D4 the KN on B6 will fall
but after this mass of Trades white wins
the piece back by playing Rook D1 and
this is where somewhere yeah we we
joined somewhere here and after king f8
queen D2 the engine suggests playing
Queen G5 to not allow Queen H6 check
right but it was allowed and this is
much much worse for black and in fact
Rook takes B6 is a massive mistake just
playing something like Rook E3 and isang
would have given white a massive massive
Advantage because H7 is still hanging
and with Rooks on the board it's much
easier to launch an attack against this
King on E8 this end game is tolerable
okay and would have continued being
tolerable if if in this position you
play Queen D4 you just don't lose it's
very very difficult to understand what I
I what my guess is he thought he'll just
play Bishop B7 here forgetting and then
he realized this will cost him dearly
the highness and at this point there is
no way to save the bishop on C5
whichever Square you choose there will
be a check that picks up the bishop on
C5 for nothing you know to me it looks
like that moment where Jeffrey missed
Bishop takes Pawn the Free Pawn on F2 it
felt like a collapse after that suddenly
Jeffrey became extremely panicking it
was right here at Peter not playing
mishop takes F2 check here I I don't I
one thing I would say sort of against
your theory is that I don't think he
realized it honestly honestly he didn't
he didn't betray any emotions it didn't
look like he even realized he had the
option which is good for him then he
would have upset if he did realize yeah
but just generally making a kind of a
quiet move and allowing the White Queen
the freedom to roam is never a good idea
in these end
games and uh let's pause our thoughts as
we jump to Anastasia special guest over
to you
Anastasia and I have ala with me again
welcome ala you know it's like you it's
your usual task you know you should come
to the studio no matter what and how was
how was it going for you today yeah uh
started pretty good I was in the lead
when at under round three four so but
then I lost against Maxim and then it
was downhill after that yeah that was
also crazy game against Maxim and um so
which game you think was the best one
today which you like the mosto was a
very interesting game it was a Kings
Indian game he was on the lead with
Maxim so was important for you yes for
the standings I mean now we're playing
for second place with Maxim three how
many points ahead two and a half points
ahead two and half points it's too much
so um but second place is only half the
point I think if I'm not wrong so if I'm
not wrong things were Chang in every
round I have to check after
Maxim uh but yeah this Kings Indian game
was interesting he doesn't have so much
experience in Kings Indian so I said
it's it's interesting to go for it and
here I'm equalized already because in
the opening he didn't remember so much
so yeah it was an interesting game he he
brought his King out of the attack I
think this to run yeah disadvantage is
maybe a bit fake because I couldn't find
how to break like he brought the king we
were
maneuvering and I now my attack doesn't
make sense here so I was looking at the
other side so it's still I felt like I
would uh spend some time here he gets
down on time and I push C6 so here had
like around 10 seconds I don't know if
this is correct yeah yeah yeah this was
crazy moment yes I mean everything
started to hang yeah everything is
hanging and uh here he has to find
Brilliant moves like Rook D5 but I was
lucky I had this B5 thing yes okay
that's an important moment I think
before B5 can we check what was
happening did you see this mov yes you
couldn't do no i s queen queen A4 yes
yeah no this I said Queen takes but okay
computer is five I hear B I mean it's
hard to play like that but I said B5
here is clever but now he says that this
is draw a rook C4 yeah because he
believes that there is no Checkmate
which is crazy to imagine yes Queen B5
Queen C3 and then Queen B2 and after
Rook B8 there is something like Knight
B6 right I mean how can you make this
move still is not easy D5 D5 oh my gosh
yeah Rook takes takes takes and this
bishop opens but he draws
[Laughter]
it looks completely crazy as What's
Happening Now que see to okay this is
crazy this is this absolutely insane but
let's see what have you how far could
you see did you see this Knight B6 no I
saw yeah I didn't calculate so much I
thought it will it was intuition so if
it works it works okay and yeah he
couldn't do the best defense is just low
on time in Blitz is enough this kind of
attacks yeah so how do you feel you just
mentioned that you are fighting for the
second place already is there any
chances you know somehow to do it for
the first I mean what what should happen
I mean I should probably win like eight
games tomorrow too I mean I did it last
year
eight wondering still Maxim should not
get six points he should get like five
and a half yeah then I have chances so
it's it's impossible but but you also
play against him so I mean things can
get still things could get changed okay
that's great I mean we will see what
happens tomorrow thank you so much ala
for for the interview for your comments
and all the best of luck for you
tomorrow thank you thank you Anastasia
and thank you Ali Raza I mean he is
really bringing the action uh Peter and
this is how our standings look after
nine rounds of Blitz Tanya Maxim Vash
gra looking good at the top but twoo
lead ands they won with 17 points and
Fabiano Carana along with Yan Nai at 15
and then we've got Ali Resa who said he
has to win a lot of games tomorrow a lot
a lot a lot a lot at 14 and a half and
of course there are nine games coming up
tomorrow nine points up for grabs we can
still expect a lot uh Peter you've got
more highlights for us just one more
highlight and this is an interesting one
uh and with all the excitement about mvl
score today mvl ended up the day with
seven out of nine after seven rounds he
wasn't the best Blitz tournament Blitz
player in the tournament Neo NEPA was on
six out of seven and crushing right and
then he lost that game to Ala that ala
just showed to us and it's very
interesting to uh to see him describe
his thought process on 5 Seconds finding
all those beautiful tactics and having a
feeling for which works and which
doesn't and as T said they find it sort
of they appreciate it correctly more
often than not and that kind of put a
pamper on on on yeah and and then I
think uh Anish did a very nice Double
Bluff against him because uh this line
has been played against nepo uh by Liam
yeah and 97 was his choice then and I
think uh probably Anish had time enough
to realize that and as I said this is
not a great line right and after castles
castles I think uh I think uh Liam Le
played Rook B1 here instead of which uh
Rook E1 was the choice of Anish and Yan
tried doing exactly the same as he's
done against uh against Liam by playing
A6 and B5 and then he got hit by A4 B4 C
takes B4 C takes B4 and A4 A5 keeping
the Rook on A1 compared to that position
on B1 uh and suddenly this Pawn on B4 is
just incredibly weak isolated and weak
yeah and you can still of course
continue as you see the engine suggests
you have to play Knight B8 and try at
least to get it to C6 it also
reintroduces the idea of Bishop C8 G4 to
at least put some pressure on the White
Center instead I think he maybe made one
more autopilot he move Bishop B7 Queen
A4 and this is borderline lost already
this is move 15 right sorry Queen B3 not
Queen A4 but this is kind of comes to
the similar positions and this is
already so bad that he kind of gambled
with Knight C5 and after this very very
forced very simple sequence of captures
the resulting position is just
completely lost for black two Bishops
two Bishops Bishop H6 is threatened
immediately you you can more or less
resign here and now yeah so uh a very
nice kind of a prep opening prep by by
Anish because he knows his client there
he knows Yan is not going to play kn6
and make a draw because he wants to
fight for first he's not interested in
making a immediate theoretical draw with
no winning chances and he also knows 97
is not great so he just you know sets a
trap and gets gets the the big game
nicely rewarded as we jump back to
Anastasia with a guest in studio over to
you Anastasia
here yes we have Fabiano Kanan here with
us Fabi welcome to the studio once again
we we didn't see you for a while how did
it go for you yesterday with a rapid
portion and today with blitz yesterday
was quite good in Rapid I was quite
satisfied at the end of the rapid that
okay still very much in the race today
wasn't so good I have to say um a bit
too up and down and also not great that
Maxim had a had a really excellent day
and he's has a very very strong position
now and not 100% let's say but very
strong position to win the tournament so
today I think I also did some very silly
things I it's Blitz you know it's all
about Blitz I mean so then which shape
you have uh so did you feel at least
good today coming to the games yeah
actually I felt like I was playing quite
well at the start but I lost this game
against Sam that was very unfortunate
because I was just much better and I
allowed to sacrifice based on a blunder
and uh if I just don't allow him
counterplay I'm certainly much better
and uh and can definitely play for a win
but you had also some brilliancy
brilliancy today everybody was
discussing it I mean Yer Peter T
everybody was screaming when they saw
this move Rook G6 you played it so
quickly can you show the game it was
against no the thing is he kind of got
trapped in a line which I knew about but
I didn't remember any details I just
remembered that white delays castling so
that after black castles which is a
mistake then white again delay castline
and black can't break the pin uh because
the sacrifice is very strong so this was
all played and Anish against ding Len
from
Bucharest and I think this is exactly
what happened but like you play Knight
F1 here you don't play Rook F1 I
mean this is how like Anish played of
course and then I remembered at some
point he played Rook F1 that game and I
was like okay I'll play Rook F1 which is
a ridiculous move of course um so I just
remembered at some point in the game he
played Rook F1 and I decided to do it
now rather than Knight F1 which is the
first move that looked logical to me
then I yeah I things went out of control
I mean certainly it looks dangerous for
black but um I blundered Knight f8 so I
thought this was strong I blunder Knight
f8 then I had no choice what to do I
mean I'm down two pieces so at least I
saw I can continue to sacrifice and
still it's a mess and he was down on
time yeah okay Rook H7 I think like was
it easy to find this defense I mean you
should really see this Rook F6 coming
probably to understand that you have to
play this Rook H7 and King h8 but when
you're desperate then yeah I mean
otherwise I I lose so at least here I I
continue fighting yeah yeah Rook F6 King
h8 okay I mean he's down on time uh it's
winning but okay in Blitz I guess things
could happen here absolutely yes but
yeah he he didn't play Rook H7 here uh
okay this was also blunder but he was
already down to seconds so when you're
down to like 7 seconds in this position
you play random moves it's impossible to
play accur considering the the time
situation I think maybe it was a a
really good chance that you found in
this in this game yeah no it was quite
this was quite important and also the
next game was quite important for me
that I beat Anish as well yeah would you
like to show it very shortly I me know a
moment probably just a second of it I
mean I don't know it was kind of I got
some position from Italian which I
thought like very pleasant very pleasant
for black I mean this position for
example yeah I should have played D5 at
this moment but it's very pleasant
position black can never lose and okay I
played D5 at the wrong moment so looked
kind of unclear but still I my is safer
and my knight on G5 is very good um so
the moment this Knight came to F4 I
thought you were actually doing really
well yeah apparently this is the best
moment in the G for him no I think he
blundered yeah I was very surprised with
Rook A3 I thought actually like Rook A1
because he needs to put this Rook on A3
to defend and here I saw this B6 I was
very happy at this point it looks like
white is collapsing but of course uh
still maybe he didn't defend in the best
way and then also against Ray I should
have won that was kind of a Miss um yeah
I had very like winning very good
winning opportunity against Ray as well
but yeah it's uh Blitz is always a bit
up and down absolutely and do we have
questions from yes or t just to be
sure no questions from me I've got a
question from Fabby yes t t wants to ask
you something every time we've got the
Royal lez against Fabby in the
commentary Studio we're waiting for him
to play his course to play archangels
and we haven't seen that in the
tournament so far what's the reason what
oh you you want him to sorry what
exactly you wanted him to play I why is
he ah why not play what because I was
out of what Tanya is asking is uh Fab's
done a chessable course on the course
okay why don't you play your variations
what's wrong is they're waiting why are
you not playing your opening variations
but now everyone why don't you play your
open everyone can expect it so play
somewh else no I don't think is Max it's
kind of funny to play like the oldest
possible variations I played like like
variations that people have sto in the
last few decades you know some ancient
stuff maybe it's a good trick like when
was the last time you saw choran in the
in a high level game I mean it just
doesn't happen anymore so I it's
actually not so bad these these other
variations yeah the variations are not
so bad guys now we know yes that's it
thank you for your question and thank
you Fabby and all the best of luck for
you tomorrow I think it's still not over
everything is possible yes hopefully
thank you let's hope thank you back to
the studio uh thank you Fabby uh Dusty
part of his opening Library there but
it's a reliable uh defense that you Gore
in yeah there's a lot of depth to to to
to the old Spanish and you can you can
do a lot of things reasonably right uh
to to a decent degree everybody's
leaving points on the table and fabbi
certainly has his reasons to complain
but he's also done very well Peter he's
done well but I you you you see the fr
ation there in the interview he feels he
feels that he should have done better
he's he's had a decent day at the office
but he needed a good one and now the
entire field is left kind of uh uh you
know mvl is watching Everybody in the
rearview mirrror there with a with a two
point two point
cushion fantastic and speaking of the
man of the r we've got him with
Anastasia let's head
over exactly we're here with the hero of
the day Maxim is here welcome Maxim um I
was wondering what did you eat what did
you do in order to succeed to play so
well today what happened I'm joking I
mean of course you're one of the best
players yeah u i mean for year I've been
having tough uh tournaments in Blitz for
some
reason um few years ago I was playing
well every day of Blitz but today it
felt a bit vintage ah yes yes so what
did you do in order to get ready for
this one
nothing too special but generally like
every day before Blitz I would just go
on do some s some tactics and I did feel
a bit sharp so you know but sometimes
it's also like you don't feel sharp and
then uh it reverberates on your play but
yeah I felt sharp and it reverberated
quite well so what kind of tactics I
mean two string moves or something two
moves it's tactics I mean it's bleed
tactics so you don't want to do
calculation like you want to to check
your habits exactly okay so it worked
really well today I don't know how many
points did you score at the end seven
seven points out of nine I mean great
result yeah they especially couple of
clean games I would say especially the
one with Wesley felt nice yeah so which
game which one of the brilliances we
will show uh to our public today which
one was the most interesting for you
yeah I think this one so here have the
game with Wesley yes okay yeah I played
this anti Marshall actually in the grand
Swiss with this idea with H4
mhm and I
think this is supposed to be slightly
inacurate but I don't know maybe maybe
C5 was too early anyway I
felt like this was complicated middle
game I wasn't sure about my play at all
but uh let's say Z it got interesting so
I go kn F5 I go Queen C1 and this was a
moment I thought was nice ah yes of
course everybody was knight5 what a move
huh yeah it's not forced actually Knight
F Knight F7 but maybe it's the same yeah
it's not possible not to make a move
like that yes like everything is hanging
so let's put one more piece I mean if it
loses I definitely don't play it but uh
turns out it's good move and then
yeah yeah then I feel like I played well
Queen F4 was also nice to keep playing
yeah and King G8 Rook E3 felt very
difficult so Bishop G7 is understandable
but then I was already very happy
because I get E5 all the time and yeah
here any time he goes Bishop D4 I have
E5 and I'm well actually no I thought
this was winning but I missed Queen C5
or no I missed Knight F6 but this is
okay so what's move after Knight D7 um
there's no move yeah okay so this was
still okay for him wow it felt for you
that you were you were winning here at
this moment yeah well I mean with my
with such pawns it looks like it yeah
then it felt very nice the center
everything apart M what was the reaction
of Wesley when you played this move
kn5 uh I think he had time to see it
because uh I took my hand and was
putting it under the Knight on F3 before
I played so no reaction like maybe if I
played instantly maybe there would have
been some reaction how can you explain
that there were so many decisive games
today you know like only a few draws
like what was happening inside of the
hall it's not the same it's not the same
yes it was really rapid is too slow
nowadays you know so classical let's not
talk about it but rapid is too slow for
so so we we we come and play great games
of Rapid uh very solid but um in Blitz
of course mistakes happen and brillianes
happen as well yes exactly so what's
happening tomorrow you have this
distance
between between the second place that's
uh have you checked how many points you
have in other I I know how much it's two
points historically it's absolutely no
guarantee mhm so I'll need to play very
well tomorrow and we'll see how that
goes yeah exactly okay thank you so much
Maxim and all the best of luck for you
tomorrow see you tomorrow yeah thank you
thank you thank you Anastasia thank you
Maxine and thank you very much for your
play the Knight E5 will give a lasting
impression telling you it's going to be
on t-shirt it's going to be on mugs it
is fantastic brilliant and here's our
standings after one day of Blitz with
one more day to go Tanya look at the
scores and you started y one more day to
go nine games remaining and as Maxim
said it himself that even with a
two-point lead being on uh the first
position
it still means nothing there is so so
much chess left to be played on day two
and he's got to keep it up got to keep
up the momentum got to keep up his form
in the next nine rounds Fabby and Yan
sharing second and third and Ali Raza
just a half a point behind Peter you get
the final word the final thoughts of
this very eventful uh day well this day
belong to to the man we just watched on
our screens the best result of the day
the best move of the day arguably the
best move of the tournament but think
all three of the people behind him
despite alira just saying na na it's all
over I'm fighting for a second I think
all of them will quietly be thinking if
he has a mediocre not even a bad day a
mediocre day and I have a good day and
all three of them are perfectly capable
of scoring a whole lot of points we
could still have a very very interesting
day tomorrow and I'm very much looking
forward to it well said I uh feel the
same and after today folks I hope you
enjoyed this day because we've got uh
tomorrow all lined up for you clear schu
tell your friends where you're hanging
out we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]
bye
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited
for